STARTED- WE ARE CERTAINLY
HOPING OUR SERGEANTS WILL PUT
OUT A CALL TO OUR COLLEAGUES ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AND
BOTH COMMITTEES BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A GOOD
ROBUST. DISCUSSION HERE WE'VE
GOT A FANTASTIC GROUP OF
PANELISTS- ON A ON A
FASCINATING AND VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC WHICH HAS TO DO WITH
CALIFORNIA'S RISING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS IT'S
AN AREA OF GREAT CONCERN FOR
THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN.
FOLLOWING THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE STATE IS TRYING TO BE A
REACHES- AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS AND CONTINUE TO BE A
GREAT DEAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROGRESS OF THE MAKING IN THE
AREA TRANSPORTATION WHICH
REALLY DO- ACCOUNT FOR. NEARLY
HALF OF OUR- THEY- SO WE-
TOGETHER EXPERTS. BOTH SIDES OF
THE- POLICY HOUSE BOTH FROM-
OUR FRIENDS IN THE AIR BOARD
OUR FRIENDS IN TRANSPORTATION
AND THEN OF COURSE WE BROUGHT
TOGETHER- FOLKS FROM LA- AND
THEN THE NUMBER OF PROFESSORS
IN. AND THOUGHT LEADERS OF FOR
OUR FINAL PANEL SO IT'S GONNA
BE A FANTASTIC I THINK AN
INTERESTING AND INFORMATIVE.
MORNING THAT I HOPE WILL LEAD
TO SOME. BEING UP. OUT I KNOW
PUBLIC. IS OUR- RESIDENT EXPERT
IN THIS AREA IT'S GONNA BE A
VERY CAREFULLY. HOW DID THINGS
GO YESTERDAY. GOOD ON IDEA
ASSEMBLY ONLY GOT OKAY SORRY
MMHM ALL RIGHT HERE I HERE
YOU'RE HERE WAS A THIS IS YOUR
MOMENT TO SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
GETS BELOW ME LET ME OVER THE
MICROPHONE AS CENTER CENTER
WHOSE ARCHER FISHING TO ME.
MORE EVERYBODY. AND THE SENATE
BUT COMMITTEE COUPLE AGO WE
HAVE A PRISON ON GREEN GAS THE
MISSION GOALS AND REDUCTION
ACTS CITIES IN THE CAP AND PRO.
AND THAT WAS KIND OF IN THE
BROUGH CON OF THE JUST TODAY TO
WE'RE GONNA FOR. AND DIG DEEPER
ON THE LEARN ABOUT OUR READER
PROGRAM FROM A TREE.
PERSPECTIVE AND- THE NUMBER
THEY CAME WITH FORTY PER. OF
OUR GREENHOUSE. IMAGE COME FROM
TRANCE SO THAT WE'RE HEAR MORE
THAT WITH THE HERE IS IN A OUR-
OF OUR ECONOMY THE TRANS SECTOR
THAT'S GOING TO GET MY CLEANER.
NOW FOR ME THE COURT IS HOW WE
CAN DO THIS IN A WAY WHICH
DOESN'T. OF COURSE PROMISES
MADE TO THE WITH AS ONE BECAUSE
WE WE'RE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THAT PASS AND IT IS SO
WE WANT TO DO IN A WAY WHERE
IT'S HOPEFULLY. AN EASY WAY TO
DO IT FOR THE VOTERS IN THE
STATE DOESN'T IMPOSE ON ON JUST
BURDEN ON THOSE WHO LEAST CAN
BEAR IT THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT I I'M INTERESTED IN SO-
I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN THE POSITION
OF LOOKING AT. ISSUES WHETHER
THEY'RE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
SOCIAL ISSUES ECONOMIC ISSUES
FROM A- SOCIAL JUSTICE-
PERSPECTIVE. I'VE ALWAYS HAD
AND WE HAVE TO BE SMART. ABOUT
OUR REDUCTION PROGRAMS- THAT WE
IMPOSE ON THE TRANSORTATION
SUCH SECTORS SO WE NEED TO
EXPLORE THE SUBJECT A LITTLE
BIT. THINK ABOUT IT AND- COME
UP WITH SOME ACTIONS. PUBLIC
TRANSIT CAN PLAY A LARGE ROLE
HERE IN MY OPINION- ARE
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN HOW
IT CAN BE MADE MORE EFFECTIVE
AS A TOOL TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
AND I REALIZE WE HAVE A LOT TO
WORK TO DO SO. THIS HEARING
WILL GIVE US MORE CONCRETE
SENSE. ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. HELP US MAKE JUDGMENTS ON
HOW BEST. SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY COME FOR THE MORNING
SESSION HERE AND- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL I GUESS
WE'LL START. YEAH SO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE BRINGING TOGETHER
TWO OF OUR STATES LEADERS IN
THIS AREA- DB KIM SECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY AND MARY NICHOLS CHAIR
OF OUR AIR RESOURCES BOARD UP.
CLOSE IN A CASKET YOU WANNA
MAKE A OF AN OPEN COMMON TO
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LET'S START
WITH SECRETARY AND WE'LL BE
HEARING ARCHER NICHOLS. AND
THIS IS A- AND- GRIP TO FROM
FOLKS MINISTRATION. THE BILL
AND SENATOR WHITE YOU'D GOOD TO
SEE YOU THIS MORNING THANK YOU
FOR THE OFFER TO OUR COMMITTEES
HOW WE ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. AS I MENTIONED
DETERMINE BILLS COMMITTEE JUST
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO. WE ARE
HEAVILY FOCUSED ON KEY
PRIORITIES SUCH AS IMPROVING
STATE OF GOOD REPAIR.
MAXIMIZING EFFICIENCIES. AND
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISES OF
SB ONE. THESE EFFORTS ARE FRONT
AND CENTER BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE ARE WE ALSO HAVE A
LEADERSHIP ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO PLAY INTO IN
TERMS OF COMBAT IN CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND NINETEEN
NINETEEN. CALLS ATTENTION TO
THE FACT THAT 40% OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS COMES FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. SO THOSE
OF US WHO WORK AT
TRANSPORTATION HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION. PROMOTING GREATER
ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS CLEARLY A KEY
STRATEGY. BUT IT GOES BEYOND
THAT RESEARCH AND MODELING ALSO
DEMONSTRATE THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND ENCOURAGING MODE SHIFT MUST
ALSO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
WHAT ARE THE KEY IS TO MODE
SHIFT IS TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO FINANCE A SAFE
ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE RELIABLE
AND FREQUENT- WAYS OF TRAVELING.
THE MORE PEOPLE WHO WALK BIKE
TAKE TRANSIT IN USE MARKHAM
ABILITY ENSURED MOBILITY
OPTIONS THE MORE WE CAN REDUCE
VMT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
MAKES NUMEROUS INVESTMENTS TO
DRESSES THERE'S ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN CONTINUING FUNDING
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL. TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL LOW
CARBON TRANSIT OPERATIONS AND
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
I JUST FUNDING FROM SB FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. DIRECTLY ALIGNS
WITH THIS MISSION. I WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF REVIEWING APPLICATIONS FOR
THE NEXT ROUND OF TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
OR ALSO KNOWN AS T. I. R. C. P.
THE PROGRAM SUPPORTS PROJECTS.
RESTRAINED OF SERVICE AND
PROVIDE A MORE SEAMLESS AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM. T. I. R. C.
P. HAS PROVIDED MORE THAN FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION IN CAPITAL
FUNDING SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AND WE WILL BE AWARDING AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
IN GRANTS IN APRIL. THE MAJOR
PROJECTS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
GROW RIDERSHIP INCLUDE
PARTNERSHIPS ON SOME OF THE
LARGEST PROJECTS IN THE STATE
NOW I WANT TO MENTION A FEW
EXAMPLES. RECENTLY PASSED. FOR
BART IN THE STATE. WE WOULD
ALLOW ABOUT TOUR THOUSAND YOUR
TO BE TAKEN TO. ADDING NEW REAL
CARS BILL IN CALIFORNIA FOR
COMMUTING HELLO MORE RIGHT TO
BE AT THE MO CAN JUST. TIMES OF
DAY. EXTENDING TO SAN JOSE AND
OCT AND GROWING TO PASS ON.
ADDING MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
DAY RIDERS ON ALL THESE TWO
SYSTEM. A MULTI BILLION PARTNER
WITH HEALTH METRO CITY OF LA O.
T. AND NATURALLY TO BRING
SERVICE INCREASES. NEW LIGHT
AND RAPID ROUTE. AND NEW
SERVICE TO DISCOVER COMMUNITIES
ALSO ALLOW HER OF THOUSAND OF
NEW DEHLI TRIPS TO BE. WATCHING
YOU REAL SERVE IN SANTA.
REDLANDS AND HONEST COAST.
INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF. TO
SEND YOU. SANTA BARBARA AND
SANTA OBISPO. AND SUPPORTING
YOU COMMUTER RAIL SERVICES TO
REDLANDS AND ON COASTER.
LAUNCHING NEW ACER ASUS SERVICE
SERIES. RESURGENCE ARE. AS WELL
AS AS A AND SAN JOAQUIN TO SO.
ADDING THOUSAND OF NEW JUST
WRITERS DAY. HELPING THE GROWTH
OF MISS BUS IN THE STATE
STOCKTON FRESNO. HELLO VALLEY
AND MANY OTHER OF THIS. THE
POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS THAT
PROGRAM LIKE TO I. R. C. P.
WILL OF THE GOVERNOR EXACTLY
ORDER AND CHANGE. WHICH DIRECTS
START TO LEVERAGE. FUNDING
REDUCE GREEN GAS. AND MEDICAID
CLIMATE IMPACTS. MEDIA CLIMATE
GOALS WILL WORK US TO EMBED.
CLIMATE CHANGE CONSIDERATIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO TRANSPORTATION
POLICY PLANNING. PROGRAMMING
AND PROJECT DELIVERY AS WELL AS
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE. NOW
MANY OF THESE CHANGES ALL ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY AND PRISSY
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT THE
DIRECTIVE IS A CALL TO ACTION
TO DO MORE. CAL STAR IS LEADING
THE CREATION OF A
TRANSPORTATION ACTION PLAN. TO
IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER. AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THE ACTION PLAN WE
DEVELOPED THROUGH BROAD
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
INCLUDING LISTENING SESSIONS
FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO SHARE IDEAS
AND SUGGESTIONS ON THE CREATION
OF THE ACTION PLAN. WHAT'S THE
DRUG PLAN IS DEVELOPED. THERE
WILL ALSO BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC FEEDBACK. THE ACTION
PLAN WILL INCLUDE SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR ATTENTION AND
MANY OF THESE EFFORTS ARE WELL
UNDERWAY. FOR EXAMPLE SOLUTIONS
TO ENCOURAGE MODE SHIFT AND
HELP REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCY ON
SINGLE OCCUPANCY VEHICLES
INCLUDE. BUILDING AN INTEGRATED
STATEWIDE RAIL TRANSIT NETWORK
CENTERED AROUND THIS CALIFORNIA
STATE REAL PLAN. INCREASING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP IS ABSOLUTELY
FUNDAMENTAL TO VMT REDUCTION AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER. AND THE
WAY TO BOLSTER RIDERSHIP IS TO
INCREASE THE SAFETY
ACCESSIBILITY RELIABILITY AND
FREQUENCY OF TRANSIT SERVICE.
IN ORDER ON THAT POINT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
INTEGRATED TROUBLE PROJECT OR
THIS INITIATIVE TO FACILITATE
EASY AND ACCESSIBLE TRAVEL
PLANNING AND PAYMENT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. KELLY T. P. IS ALL
ABOUT MAKING TRAVELERS SOME
TROUBLE SIMPLER AND COST
EFFECTIVE BY ENHANCING THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. ONE
SEAMLESS PAYMENT PLAN FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
STRATEGY TO ENCOURAGE MODE
SHIFT AND REDUCE VMT IS
EXPANDING BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
DOING SO IN A SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE MANNER. ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION IS A CRITICAL
FIRST AND LAST MILE SOLUTION TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO MOVE AROUND
WITHOUT A VEHICLE. ALSO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS CAN SUPPORT AFFORDABLE
INFILL HOUSING YOUR JOBS. THE
IDEA IS TO ADVANCE PROJECTS
THAT HELP PROMOTE THE RIGHT
KIND OF DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
INCREASING HOUSING YOUR KEY
EMPLOYMENT CENTERS WILL HELP
REDUCE THE DISTANCE PEOPLE NEED
TO DRIVE. ADDITIONALLY WHEN
TACKLING CONGESTION. WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE DEMAND MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES RATHER THAN HI WE
CAPACITY EXPANSION WHERE
FEASIBLE. THIS INCLUDES
STRATEGIES LIKE EQUITABLE
APPLICATIONS OF ROADWAY PRICING
WHETHER IT BE MANAGED LANES ARE
MORE INNOVATIVE PRICING
STRATEGIES SUCH AS COURTING
PRICING WHICH IS BEING PURSUED
IN WEST LA BY LA METRO AND
SCATTERED. FURTHERMORE WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITATES THE
ADOPTION OF CLEAN VEHICLES AND
WE CAN DO THIS BY SUPPORTING
THE DEPLOYMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
FREIGHT. INCLUDING ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
AS PART OF OUR INVESTMENTS.
ALSO WE NEED TO FACE THE
REALITY THAT CLIMATE IMPACTS
ARE ALREADY HERE. INCORPORATING
CLIMATE RESILIENCY INTO
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE IS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT. THESE PRINCIPLES
WILL DRIVER DECISION MAKING ON
WHAT TYPES OF ACTIONS TO
UNDERTAKE AS WE IMPLEMENT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. IN SITUATIONS
WHERE WE HAVE DISCRETIONARY
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WE WILL
USE IT WHERE FEASIBLE TO ALIGN
WITH THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS.
WE ARE TAKING A STRATEGIC
APPROACH TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PLANNING PROGRAMMING AND
PROJECT DELIVERY FUNCTIONS
INCLUDE SCOPING FUNDING AND
BUILDING PROJECTS THAT WILL
MEET THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS.
AS WELL AS SB AS WELL SB ONES
FIXES FIRST PERFORMANCE TARGETS
FOR PAVEMENT. BRIDGES DRAINAGE
AND TRANSPORTATION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS. LET ME CONCLUDE BY
SAYING THAT WE ARE HEAVILY
FOCUSED ON MULTIPLE FRONTS TO
MAINTAIN AND IMPROVE THE
CONDITION OF OUR HIGHWAYS ROADS
AND BRIDGES WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME. UNDERTAKING EFFORTS TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS INCLUDING ADVANCING ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
ENCOURAGING GRAY REMOTE SHIFTED
BY INVESTING IN TRANSIT AND
PASSENGER REAL ALONG WITH
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SECRETARY CÃM HOURS LET'S NOW
HEAR FROM CHAIR NICHOLS AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE A DISCUSSION OF
THE PANEL. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY I'M MARY
NICHOLS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND I WANT
TO- ALSO- ECHO I SECRETARY
KIM'S REMARKS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT AND USEFUL IT IS THAT
WE HAVE THESE TWO COMMITTEES-
MEETING TOGETHER TO DISCUSS
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC- WE CAN'T
ACHIEVE OUR AIR QUALITY OR
CLIMATE GOALS. OR PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT TACKLING EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATON SECTOR SO
I'M GONNA DO A VERY BRIEF I
HOPE OVERVIEW OF THE STATE AIR
QUALITY AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TRANS. BEFORE
DISCUSSING OUR GOALS AND WHERE
WE NEED TO GO- FIRST OF ALL WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS IN
PLACE ALREADY THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO REDUCE THE- PREVALENCE OCCUR.
POLLUTANTS THE EASIEST ONE TO
FIVE ON AND IF YOU THE PRINT
SLICE THAT WE HANDED OUT AT THE
BEGINNING I'M GONNA TRY TO
FOLLOW ALONG WITH THE- CHARTS
AS WELL- SO THE FIRST ONE SHOWS
YOU THE CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
AND- IT FOCUSES ON KNOCKS
NITRIC. OXIDE BECAUSE NITROGEN
OXIDE IS A PRECURSOR THE MAIN
THE MAIN INGREDIENT IF YOU WILL
AND CREATING SMOG OR OWES. WITH
WE- ALL DEALING WITH CALIFORNIA
A ALTHOUGH OZONE IN A OF ITSELF
IS NOW. A KILLER IN THE SAME
WAY AS FIND. KNOX'S ACT I CAN
TO BOTH AND SO IT BECAME KIND
OF THE INITIAL POLLUTANT THAT
WE FOCUS ON MOBILE SO. ARE RISK
FOR THE LARGEST SHARE OF
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS HERE- AND
INCREASINGLY WE'VE CLEANED UP
ENGINES AND WE'VE CLEANED UP
FUELS AND WE'VE GOT INCENTIVES
IN PLACE TO TURN OVER THE
VEHICLE FLEET. ALL OF WHICH
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
REDUCTIONS THAT YOU CAN SEE IN
THESE VERY TINY NUMBERS HERE ON
THIS SLIDE- BUT AT THE KEY THE
KEY THING IS- OBVIOUSLY THAT WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO WE'RE NOT
WHERE WE NEED TO GO. AND
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE IN THE
AND IN THE HEALTH BASED
STANDARDS WE STILL ARE AND
SEEING INCREASES AND VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED WHICH IS WHERE
WE GET THE- BURNING OF DOLE'S
FASSEL FEELS IN TURN. LEADS TO
THE KNOX. SO JUST THIS AHEAD
YOU SEE ON THE FIFTH PAGE OF
THIS HANDOUT WE DID. THAT WE'RE
SEEING GREENHOUSE GAS. HER UNIT
OF. AT YOU TO. GDP GOING DOWN.
BY THE OVERALL A NUMBERS STILL
GOING. WHILE POPPY. IS STAYING
THE SAME. ENDS RALLY FOR I
SHOULD SAY THE TRENDS ARE REAL
FOR AT THE MOMENT. AND SO WE'D
BE IN OUR- IS NOT A NOT A MUCH
AS NEEDED IT TO BE IN ORDER TO
MEET. OUR GOT ENTRANCE MISSION
IS THE BILL MAHER. OF ALL OF
THE QUEUE. CONTRIBUTORS PASCAL
EMISSIONS SO WE HAVE GOALS ON
THE BOOKS RIGHT FOUND THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK TOWARD A-
LUCK BEGINNING ON PAGE. HERE
HELLO. HAS BEEN THE KEY TO OUR-
AND I REGULAR TO ACTIVE IN THIS
AREA- AND ALL WE HAVE ORDERS IN
PLACE NOW THAT WOULD GET US TO
A 100% NEW CAR SALES IS BEING
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
INCLUDING SCHOOL BUSES MARINE
AND PORT AND AIRPORT EQUIPMENT
ALL CAN BE STATUS SHOT TO THE
AIRPORT- THE END THERE MENDES
OUT OF ACT. GOING ON IN AREA
BUT WE NEED TO ACT ACCORDING TO
CARBS ANALYSIS HAVE ALL
PASSENGER VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
BE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
THAT COULD INCLUDE FUEL CELLS
NOT JUST BATTERY ELECTRIC BUT
SOMEHOW ZERO EMISSION. TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WHERE OBVIOUSLY VERY
LONG WAY FROM THAT OR RIGHT NOW
WE NEED TO BE REDUCING THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED PER
CAPITA AND- WE NEED TO HAVE
OPTION AT SEC. KIM POINTED OUT
EARLIER TO MAKE IT DOWN IN THE
CURRENT SO WELL THERE'S A OF
TALK NOW AT THE MOMENT ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER WE NEED
EVOLUTION VERSUS INCREMENTAL
CHANGE AND THAT'S POLITICAL
DIALOGUE WERE IN. I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT WE ARE LOW
THING IN. THAT'S SOMETHING WE
ANNOUNCED TO EVOLUTION HOPE IT
HAPPENS IN A PAIN WAY IS DONE
IN A WAY WHERE JAMBOREE. REACH
READ THE CAN IS TO OFTEN THE
BLOW FOR THOSE FOR WHOM WOULD
BE A BIRD. BUT. SECRETARY KIM
TALKED ABOUT THE DO SCOPING
PLAN THAN A RB IS WORKING ON
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE ISSUES AND
BEING. A STATE THAT HAS A VERY
ROBUST- CONSTITUENCY AROUND ALL
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES IT MEANS
THAT WE CAN'T DO THIS BY
OURSELVES- OFF IN A IN A ROOM
SOMEWHERE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO. ACTUALLY ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AT BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL AND LARGE CITIES AND
SMALL AND TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT WILL ACTUALLY.
MAKE PROGRESS WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
THAT WE CAN DO THIS- BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH IN THE PAST- BUT-
WE DO FACE SOME OBSTACLES ONE
OF WHICH OF COURSE IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S CURRENT
EFFORTS TO TAKE AWAY OUR
AUTHORITY- AS A STATE TO- TO
REQUIRE. ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
AND TO TAKE A POSITION THAT THE
STATE HAS NO AUTHORITY TO DEAL
WITH. DILIGENTLY IN THE COURTS
AND WITH THE AGENCIES TO TRY TO
CHANGE THAT POSITION BUT THIS
IS STILL- STILL AN ONGOING.
STRUGGLE SO- I WANTED JUST-
FLIP AHEAD HERE A LITTLE BIT TO
TALK ABOUT LIGHT DUTY VERSUS
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES BECAUSE-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES MOST PEOPLE I THINK
PICTURE- YOU KNOW A LEAF FOR
TESLA MAYBE OR SOMETHING. THAT
IS AN INDIVIDUAL DECISION TO
PURCHASE AND WE ARE VERY
ENGAGED IN THAT- IN THAT
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
EXPAND THE OPTIONS AND THE
CHOICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE. AND
TO MAKE OF VEHICLES AVAILABLE
AND ALL DIFFERENT
CONFIGURATIONS AND- AT PRICES
THAT PEOPLE CAN AFFORD HEY. WE
HAVE USED THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT AS A WAY TO
PROVIDE REPEAT STEP. SERVERS AS
A BRINGING DOWN THE CALL. WE
HAVE ANOTHER. THAT SEEKS.
ADEQUATE CONSIDER. BY BRINGING
UP THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT AT-
A PERSON WHO HAS A CAR THAT
FAILS THE SMOG CHECK TEST CAN
GET TO PURCHASE A NEWER CLEANER
CAR. SO THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
ACTIVITY IN THAT SPACE AND IT'S
MEANT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
BECOME THE- EPICENTER FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN THE
COUNTRY WITH MORE- MORE
PASSENGER VEHICLES HERE THAN
ANY PLACE ELSE AND IN FACT MORE
THAN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
AB COMBINED BUT IT'S STLL ONLY
DEALS WITH ABOUT HALF THE
PROBLEM IF YOU- FLIP THE HEAD
TO- THE TENTH PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT. YOU CAN SEE THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES MAKE UP 20% OF
TRANSPORTATION RELATED J. M.
AND OF LARGEST. OF KNOX
EMISSIONS WITHIN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THAT 43%
SO IN ORDER TO MEET BOTH THE
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS AND
PARTICULARLY TO REDUCE THE
BURDEN OF POLLUTION IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CENTERED
AROUND FOR. RAIL YARDS
TRANSPORTATION HUBS. CENTERS
LIKE THE WAREHOUSES- THAT WE
HAVE IN THE EASTERN AND THE LA
BASIN. WE HAVE TO TAKE A
BROADER APPROACH TO
ACCELERATING A LARGE SCALE
TRANSITION OF ZERO EMISSION
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
AND WE'RE DOING THIS THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN ADVANCED
CLEAN TRUCK REGULATION THIS IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS AT THE
MOMENT BUT IT'S INTENDED TO
ACCELERATE A LARGE SCALE
TRANSITION. OF ZERO EMISSION
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
BOTH THROUGH A SALES
REQUIREMENT OF FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS AND A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT FOR- PURCHASERS FOR
FLEET PURCHASERS IN PARTICULAR
AND WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN BOLSTER
THIS. WHOLE AREA AS WELL
RECOGNIZING THIS COMPLICATED
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE ECONOMY THAT WE DO THIS
RIGHT BUT WITHOUT SENDING SOME
PRETTY- STOFF LONG TERM GOALS
AND COMING UP WITH METHODS TO
PUSH PEOPLE IN THAT DIRECTION I
DON'T THINK WE CAN JUST COUNT
ON NATURAL ATTRITION TO GET US
TO WHERE WE NEED TO GO. ANYTIME
SOON SEC. WE'RE TRYING TO
ANSWER PROJECTS IN THE HEAVY
DUTY AND FREIGHT SPACE AS WELL
WE HAVE HAD PROGRAMS IN EFFECT
DOWN FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW TO
FUND THE PRE COMMERCIAL
DEMONSTRATION PHASE PILOTS
EARLY COMMERCIALIZATION WHICH
CAN HELP WITH THE COMMERCIAL
DEPLOYMENT. AND MARKET SCALE
ADOPTION OF CLEANER
TECHNOLOGIES FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND FREIGHT EQUIPMENT.
BUT AGAIN INSTEAD OF. IN
SUPPORT FOR COOPERATION AND
COLLABORATION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FACE
OPPOSITION THERE AS WELL AND SO
WE ARE TRYING HARD WORKING OUT
WITH AGENCIES WITH THE INDUSTRY
WHICH WANTS TO SEE A NATIONAL
APPROACH HERE. FIVE TO GET OUT
OF PROGRAM WHICH WILL ACTUALLY
BE MORE EFFECTIVE FOR US AND
FOR OTHER STATES THAT FACE SOME
SOME SIMILAR CONCERNS.
ATTAINING THE FEDERAL OZONE
STANDARD IN THE SOUTH COAST LA
ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARDINO
AREA- IS GOING TO- REQUIRE A
60% REDUCTION IN TOTAL KNOCKS
BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE. TO MEET
THE OZONE STANDARD AND THAT'S
AN EX BEEN EXTENDED OUT MANY
YEARS INTO THE FUTURE FROM
WHERE IT WAS ORIGINALLY SET TO
BE. AND 72% REDUCTION BY TWENTY
THIRTY ONE TO MEET THE EIGHT
HOUR OZONE STANDARD. ABSENT
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY KNOCKS EMISSIONS
FROM THE FEDERALLY REGULATED
SOURCES WHICH WE DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DIRECTLY CONTROL
WHICH INCLUDE THE INTERSTATE
TRUCKS PLANES TRAINS AND SHIPS
WILL EXCEED THE EMISSIONS FROM
ALL OF THE SOURCES THAT CAR.
DOES ACTUALLY REGULATE SO OUR
THIRTY IS OBVIOUSLY NOT ON
LIMITED HERE BUT WE ARE STILL
TAKING STEPS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS FROM PHRASE WORKING
OTHER WITH A POOR. ON OUT BIRTH
REGGAE. ENGINES THEMSELVES BUT
WE CAN WORK WITH THE PORTS AND
THE- AND THE OWNERS OF THE OF
THE- BIRTH THERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN THE SHIPS CALL THEY
ARE SWITCHING TO ELECTRICITY-
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
ELECTRIFY TRANSPORT
REFRIGERATION UNITS- TO POWER
THE THAT POWER THE
REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS ON TRUCKS
AND- SHIPPING CONTAINERS. AND
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE PLAN
TO ALSO PROPOSE REGULATIONS FOR
ZERO EMISSION CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS ON ROAD
DRAINAGE TRACKS. ALL OF WHICH
ARE CRITICAL FOR REDUCING
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
MOVING CARGO THROUGH PORTS AND
RAIL YARDS SO WITH ALL OF
THESE- MOVEMENTS A FOOT AND A
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENTS GOING ON
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN
DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
HERE. I NEED TO ALSO POINT OUT
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A SYSTEM
APPROACH HERE THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT A TRUCK OR A PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT A
ROBUST FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE
NETWORK AS WELL AS REPAIRS AND
OTHER ASSOCIATED FACILITIES.
THAT WORK WITH THE IS AB
VEHICLES AND SO OTHER AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND THE CPC ARE BOTH INVOLVED
AND WORKING HARD ON THAT TASK
AND WE CONSIDER THEM ESSENTIAL
PARTNERS IN THIS IN THIS
EFFORT. BUT WITH ALL THAT WE
CAN DO ON TECHNOLOGY AND
TRANSFORMATION OF THE SYSTEM WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES WITH US FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME. AND THAT
MEANS THOSE VEHICLES ARE NOT
ONLY GONNA NEED TO HAVE- THE
FUEL CONTINUALLY SUPPLIED BUT
HOPEFULLY GETTING CLEANER AND
LESS- CO TWO- INTENSIVE- WE
ALSO NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
ACTUALLY. REDUCE THE NEED TO
USE THOSE THOSE VEHICLES AND
AGAIN THIS IS ONE WHERE. A ARE
B. HAS AUTHORITY AS SOME PIECE
OF WHAT HAS TO BE DONE- SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THE WAYS
ALL THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY- WE'VE SEEN SOME
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND AGAIN NOT
JUST ATTRIBUTABLE TO A RP BUT-
WORKING WITH- PR WE- CHANGE THE
DEFINITION THAT'S USED IN C.
CA. WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
PROJECT AND YOU WANT TO SEE
WHAT THE EFFECTIVE IT'S GOING
TO BE ON TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS WE DON'T JUST LOOK AT
THE OLD- METRIC OF LEVEL OF
SERVICE THAT IMPLIED THAT JUST
GETTING PLACES. GETTING PEOPLE
FROM PLACE TO PLACE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE THROUGH AN
INTERSECTION WAS GOING TO BE
THE ONLY. METRIC THAT WE WERE
GONNA DO AS WE NOW LOOK AT. THE
M. T. AS AN E. A MORE EASILY
TRANSLATE A BULL- MEASUREMENT
AND THAT IN TURN HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR. WHAT
ALTERNATIVES WE MIGHT WANT TO
BE LOOKING AT WHEN IT COMES TO
NEW PROPOSED LAND USE PROJECTS-
REDUCING THE NEED TO DRIVE AS
SECRETARY SAID INCLUDES A LOT
OF OTHER. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INVESTMENT IN ALTERNATE IS AND
IT HAS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
EFFORT TIONS. COMMUNITIES
SERVED. GET DEAL WITH RELATED
ISSUES CONGESTION AND LONGER
COMMITTEE TIMES WE RECENTLY
HAVE FORTIFIED OUR WORK ON SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE TO TRY TO
STRENGTHEN THE LONG TERM GOALS
THERE. IN THE HOPE THAT THAT
WILL ALSO BE AN INCENTIVE FOR
COMMUNITIES TO LOOK MORE
SERIOUSLY AT PROJECTS THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THAT JUST INCREASED CAPACITY
FOR. VEHICLES BUT DON'T
ACTUALLY DO ANYTHING TO HELP
WITH THIS TRANSITION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT A NEWS
DATEABLE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECT. AS PART OF OUR LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
WITH THE GOAL OF INCREASING
EQUITY IN DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. BY GRANTS
TO DO MORE LOCALIZED PLANNING
AND CAPACITY BUILDING ON THE
PART OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS- WE RECOGNIZE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES OVERLAPPED
WITH OTHER AGENCIES THAT WERE
TRYING TO. BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WE SHARE THE
THAT LOOK JUST HAS TO PASSED
BILLS IN THIS AREA INCLUDING AB
ONE EIGHTY FIVE LAST YEAR WHICH
ADDED THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AGENCY TO THEM
MANDATED MEETINGS BETWEEN
CARBON THE CTC JUST ONE MORE
EXAMPLE WHERE JUST HAVING TO
GET TOGETHER SEVERAL TIMES A
YEAR AND HAVE A JOINT AGENDA
AND ACTUALLY TALK TO EACH
OTHER. DAS LIED TO INCREASED
AWARENESS AND HOPE PLEASE AT
LEAST. AB RATE PROGRAM SO WITH
ALL OF OUR- I THINK AS WE LIKE
TO CAN TO PLAY A ROLE IN.
CREATING SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND BEING THE-
BEING THE SOURCE OF ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY DO FOR AIR QUALITY-
AND FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A PROBLEM WHICH AFFECTS
US ALL AND- WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
HAVE I THINK STRONGER AND MORE
HOLISTIC- INVESTMENTS IN THE
SUSTAINABLE. COMMUNITIES AND
PLANNING AREA IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE INTEGRATING OUR
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS- ALONG WITH OUR GOALS
FOR AIR QUALITY IN CLIMATE IN
WAYS THAT ACHIEVE THE GOALS
THAT WE'VE THAT WE ALL.
SUBSCRIBE TO AND THAT. YOU AND
TO THE GOVERNOR HAVE AT
CONTINUE TO REINFORCE- IN TERMS
OF REDUCING EMISSIONS AND
FACILITATING A TRANSITION AWAY
FROM OF PETROLEUM BASED ECONOMY
AND ONE THAT IS- CAPABLE OF
BEING RESILIENT TO THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE THAT'S
ALREADY UNDER WAY. THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU AND- LET ME ASK
YOU QUESTIONS AND I'D LOVE TO
OPEN IT UP- AND OTHERS CAN BE A
LOT OF PEOPLE ASKING QUESTIONS
BUT I SUPPOSE. I'M I MENTION
TONS OF GREAT THINGS I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE FOR EXAMPLE MAY
HOW HOW WE MOVE THAT BEYOND A
GOOD FIGHT DISCUSSION- YOU KNOW
WE MAY BE PLANNING BEEN HAVING
CHATS ABOUT HOW TO BEST
IMPLEMENT BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WITH SB
THIRTY THREE SEVEN FIVE IS THAT.
IT DOESN'T AUTUMN AND WE HAVE
ENOUGH TEETH- YOU KNOW ARE WE
WE'RE NOT FINDING WHEN I
BUILDING THOSE PROJECTS. HOW DO
YOU TRANSLATE THAT CONVERSATION
INTO SOMETHING IT'S MORE
TANGIBLE. WELL AS AS I'M SURE
THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS VERY WELL
ANY DISCUSSIONS THAT INVOLVE-
WHAT SEEN AS INTERFERING WITH
LOCAL LAND USE DECISIONS. MEET
WITH- PRETTY STRONG RESISTANCE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE- LOCAL
LAND USE AGENCIES AND EVEN WITH
THE OVER RIDING STATE GOALS HAS
BEEN VERY HARD. FOR US TO. DO A
LOT ESPECIALLY. WHEN THERE
AREN'T A LOT OF CARROTS- BUT
CERTAINLY NOT MUCH WITH STICKS-
THE PARENT WITH SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE. EXPEDITED REVIEW AND
BASICALLY ELIMINATING THE
OBSTACLE OF HAVING TO LOOK AT
THE GREENHOUSE GAS. IMPACTS OF
PROJECTS THAT TRIGGERED SEE
CA THAT WAS WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO. BE THE- THING THAT
GOT LOCAL COMMUNITIES. WILLING
TO ACCEPT- PLEASE MORE STRICT
AND RIVER COMMENCED. LOOKING AT
G. H. T. OR REALLY VMT RELATED
OUR GUEST. AN A. R. P.'S ROLE
IN THAT WAS LIMITED TO HAVING
THE TARGETS WHICH WE DID AND-
WITH. THE MPO. AND THEN TO.
OKAY AT THE ANTHEM SO THAT WERE
DEVELOPED AND SAY WHY THEY MET
THOSE TARGET AND YOU KNOW THE-
THERE'S A LOT OF- A LOT OF ROOM
FOR- VEGA DONE US OR
INTERPRETATION IN THESE KINDS
OF- OF EXERCISES AND WHERE IT
GETS TO BE REALLY INTENSE AS
WHEN. YOU'VE GOT A SPECIFIC
PROJECT UNDER WAY I SUDDENLY
OPPONENTS AND PROPONENTS ARE
ALL GATHERED AROUND YOU KNOW
EAGERLY TRYING TO USE THE-
PROCESS- AS A WAY TO ATTACK- OR
SUPPORT OR WHATEVER YOU KNOW
THE PROJECT IS I'VE BEEN.
PERSONALLY WATCHING THE
EVOLUTION OF SOME OF OUR
EFFORTS- TO LOOK AT STADIUM
PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE RECENTLY
AND SEEING HOW- A SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO LOOK AT A GIVEN
PROJECT AND MAKE A FINDING THAT
IT WILL NOT- EVER HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON AG EMISSIONS
IN THE FUTURE I MEAN WE DO IT
BECAUSE- WE'RE REQUIRED TO AND
WE GO THROUGH AN EXERCISE AND-
YOU KNOW WE FOUND WAYS. TO
CONVINCED THE DEVELOPERS IN
THESE CASES THERE YOU KNOW
LARGE AND WELL HEELED ENTITIES
AND SO IT'S RELATIVELY EASY
COMPARED TO SOME SITUATIONS TO
GET PEOPLE TO AGREE TO PUT IN A
LECTURE CHARGING AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BUSES AND-
BUT- ABSENCE OF A MORE
INTEGRATED APPROACH. THAT THE
COMMUNITIES BY INTO AND THAT-
THE AGENCIES ARE ALL A PART OF
ITS IT FEELS SOMETIMES LIKE AN
EXERCISE IN FUTILITY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THERE'S A DESPERATE
NEED TO THESE. PROJECTS IN THE
MINDS OF THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD
THEM AND SUPPORT THEM. AND.
COMMUNITIES GENERALLY AT LEAST.
IT IF IT. IN THIS KIND OF CRAP.
AT THE SAME TIME PEOPLE GOING
TO BE A- BY THE ADDITIONAL
TRAFFIC OR- FEEL LIKE IT'S
GONNA YOU KNOW. HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THEIR- QUALITYOF
LIFE ARE FIERCELY OPPOSED AND
YOU FIND YOURSELF HAVING THIS
BATTLE BEING FOUGHT OVER
GREENHOUSE GASES AS OPPOSED TO
WHETHER THIS IS ACTUALLY A YOU
KNOW A GOOD A GOOD THING TO BE
DOING ARE NOT. ALL I'M SAYING
ABOUT THAT IS THAT I THINK WE
NEED A BROADER BASED PLANNING
APPROACH- TO THROUGH TO GET TO
WHERE WE NEED TO GO AND PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THAT FOR A LONG TIME
BUT I CAN WHAT'S ABOUT. BEING
THOUGHTFUL AND BUT THE MADE
WITH YOU THERE'S LEAN
CERTIFICATION AND THEN AND THEN
AND THEN I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE APPROVING ANYMORE
MAJOR STADIUM PROJECTS ABOUT IN
YOUR RAIL AND IT. COMPONENT TO
EVERY PROJECT THAT HAS TO BE A
GIVEN I THINK AT THIS POINT
GIVEN THE WAY. OVER AND SEVERAL
YEAR AND I IT WAS A MISSED AND
I WE NEED TO. YOU KNOW. WE HAVE
WE'RE WE'RE BUILDING OUT IT AND
MASSIVE FROM TRANSIT SYSTEM IN
LA. I'LL GET THE LYMPICS COMING
UP IT'S THE LARGEST
TRANSPORTATION IS LARGEST
TRANSIT. BUILD OUT IN THE
NATION RIGHT NOW AND- I ANOTHER
ELECTION ISN'T IT TO TRY TO
CREATE A REAL SPUR- TO THE
STADIUM. AND SO YEAH FOR
ANYHOW- LOOK AT ONE OF THE QUIT
WHY WHEN ASKED ABOUT ABOUT
AVIATION YOU KNOW THAT SEEMS IS
ENORMOUS AREA OF EMISSIONS AND-
I KNOW. IT SEEMS THAT WE JUST.
WE JUST SAY WELL WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ROLL OVER ANY EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUT OF STATE
TRAVEL AND IS THAT A TERRIBLY
TRUE AND CAN WE DO
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE GIVEN ALL
THE EXCITING THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING WITH SHORT LEGS
ELECTRIFICATION AND BIO FUEL
OPPORTUNITIES THE AVIATION
SECTOR. BUT IT'S CERTAINLY TRUE
THAT WE DON'T GET TO SET AN
EMISSIONS STANDARD FOR
AIRPLANES THE WAY WE DEAL WITH-
CARS OR- BANDS AND SO FORTH
BUT- WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THIS SPACE BOTH IN ENCOURAGING
AND SUPPORTING- TRANSITION TO
CLEANER AVIATION FEELS. AND
ALSO- WE'RE SEE I'M SOME REALLY
EXCITING WORK GOING ON- MOSTLY
FILL IN THE PRE COMMERCIAL
SPACE BUT SOME OF IT MOVING
TOWARDS COMMERCIALIZATION FOR
SHORT HAUL AVIATION TO BE ZERO
EMISSION- AIRCRAFT THERE
ACTUALLY ARE NOW WORKING
DEMONSTRATIONS OF AIRPLANES
THAT COULD TO DO A FAIR AMOUNT
OF THE- SMALL BOWL- TRIPS THE
SHORT HOPS THAT VIEWS. ARE USED
FOR DELIVERY PACKAGES MAIL
ETCETERA- IN A COMPLETELY ERO
EMISSION MODE THE AIRPORTS
THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN INTERESTED
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING- PLAY
ACCESS TO IS ONE. RAIMES
MIGLIOR WITH DILIGENTLY FOR YOU
IS THAT WITH A LOT OF PUSH FROM
THE SOUTH COAST DISTRICT TO
ALLOW UP TO FIVE THE THING ON
BROWN'S. ITEMS USED SMOKE. YEAH
I'M WHAT ABOUT I WANT ONE OF
THE ONE I SEE THAT YOU YOU MADE
SOME PRETTY. WE HAVE A- STRONG
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED TO
TRANSITION- AWAY FROM- INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE- IF THAT
TRULY HAPPENS DOES IS THE MTS
BIGGER PROBLEM. MOVING FORWARD.
HI IN THE IDEA BEING THAT DATE
RIGHT NOW WE ASSOCIATE VMT SO
MUCH WITH THE MISSIONS BECAUSE
WE WERE DOING AND WE'RE DOING
SO ON THE BASIS OF THINKING
ABOUT A CAR AS A- AS A HEAVY
POLLUTER- BUT IF WE'RE ABLE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY TRANSCEND
TRANSITIONED OF THE OUR
AUTOMOBILE AND TRUCK FLEET.
TOWARD LOWING LOWER POLLUTING
VEHICLES IS MUTE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED SPEAK A PROBLEM. OF IT
AS- AT OF SUGGESTIONS THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AT A CLEAN MILE
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH
VEHICLES ARE BEING USE. THAT
MIGHT BEA METRIC THAT YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY HAS EVEN A VERY CLEAN
VEHICLE BUT IT'S BEING USED.
MOST OF THE DAY TO ADD IN SOME
INSTANCES IN AN AUTONOMOUS
FASHION WHEN IT ISN'T EVEN.
CARRYING ANYBODY OR ANYTHING-
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT. THE OVERALL
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT FOR
TRAFFIC FURTHER ROADS THE-
SAFETY THESE AREA. THE NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT IT'S A BIG
PROBLEM YET TRAFFIC CONGESTION
PERSPECTIVE YEAH SO FROM A FOR
A RARE. PERSPECTIVE IF IT'S
REALLY BEING READ. THIS IS.
EMISSIONS AND FUEL MEANING THE
OTHER. IS ALL RENEWABLE YOU CAN
GET PRETTY CLOSE TO A ZERO- A
ZERO EMISSIONS MODEL AND- I
THINK WE'RE GONNA SEE A LOT. OF
THAT ESPECIALLY IN URBAN AREAS
YEAH. WE WENT WITH IN MIND I
KNOW OF THE PRICE YOU PRICE A
LITTLE MADE A BRIEF ALLUSION I
KNOW A CONTRA TOPIC BUT I THINK
IT IMPORTANT SUSPENSE MORE TIME
LOOKING AT- I WAS AT A
PRESENTATION THIS LAST WEEKEND
FROM A PROFESSOR DOWN A USC
PROFESSOR BARNETT WHO. TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW. PARKING
SCARCITY IN PRICING I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT CONGESTION. PRICING
SOMEONE WHO. SOME MODELS HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN EUROPE
WHERE. WHERE WE- ON ON THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE MISTER
SECRETARY. PRICES A HUGELY
IMPORTANT STRATEGY IN AS YOU
POINTED OUT CHAIRMAN ALAN IT IS
CONTROVERSIAL IT IS SENSITIVE.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IF WE'RE GONNA
GET SERIOUS ABOUT REDUCING VMT
REDUCING. GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND- URGING GREATER
MOTIONS AND SO I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGED THAT UP. ORDER
PRICING IS BEING EXPORTED LA
BY- WEST OF WEST LA BY ONLY
METRO SKAGGS OF THE BAY AREA IS
DOING SOMETHING SIMILAR I
BELIEVE RUN TREASURE ISLAND.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS WE NEED TO HAVE.
AND SO AT THE STATE LEVEL- WORK
FOR GAEA AND WE NEED WE NEED TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS OF.
PROFESSOR BARNETT I KNOW HIM
WELL- WHEN THE LEADING EXPERTS
WHEN IT COMES TO PRICING. AND
WHEN IT COMES TO PARKING
PRICING DYNAMIC PRICING CORDON
PRICING YOU CONGESTION PRICING
THERE ARE MANY WAYS YOU CAN DO
THIS- IN A WAY THAT IS FAIR AND
EQUITABLE. AND ACHIEVE THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE WHICH IS OUR-
OKAY AND THEN I WANT TO ASK YOU
SB SECRETARY- WE TALKED ABOUT
TRYING TO. REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS. BUT THERE'S ALSO THE
FACT THAT THE CLIMATE IMPACTS
ARE. MARK ON AN- IMPACT OUR
SYSTEM IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
REGARDLESS OF THE WORK WE DO-
I'VE I WANTED TO RAISE A
CONCERN ABOUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE BEING
CONSIDERED BY STATE ENGINEERS
AS ROADS AND HIGHWAYS ARE
BEING. PLANNEDAND BUILT AND-
CAN YOU GIVE US AN
UNDERSTANDING AS TO AS TO. WHAT
TO WHAT EXTENT OUR PLANNERS IN
OUR ENGINEERS ARE
INCORPORATING. BEST THE BEST
POSSIBLE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT ABOUT
HAD THE GROWING IMPACT OF
CLIMATE ON OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS ARE MAKING
PLANS ABOUT I'D WITH THE REST
OF BUILDING BRIDGES AND ROADS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE. CALTRANS
HAS LAUNCHED A SERIES OF-
CLIMATE VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENTS IN EACH OF THE
TWELVE CALTRANS DISTRICTS SO
THEY ARE- GOING ALL OUT TO
REALLY BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH- OUR CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IMPACTED BY
SEA LEVEL RISE ANOTHER.
EXAMPLES OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO
WE'VE GOT OUT THAT'S A GOOD
BASELINE OF INFORMATION AND WE
CAN BUILD ON THAT IN TERMS OF
HOW DO WE BUILD RESILIENCY INTO
PROJECTS. EXAMPLE IS INTERNAL
WHITE HOUSE USER IS HIGHWAY%
THIRTY SEVEN- WHICH IS-
SURROUNDS IN AND SURROUNDS THE
BAY AND WE'RE SEEING IMPACTS OF
THAT AND THEY'RE OLD WE NEED TO
BE A LONG TERM SOLUTION- IN THE
FORM OF EITHER RAIING. THE
ROADWAY FOR MOVING AWAY SO HUGE
AND CENTERED ON SORRY SENATOR
DODGE AREA YES- AND SO THAT'S A
GOOD THAT' A IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A POSTER CHILD FOR ON THE
IMPACT O CLIMATE CHANGE ON ON
THE TRANSPORTATION OF SOLD
EITHER OTHER EXAMPLES AS WELL
BUT- THE TO THE TO CLASSIC.
OKAY SHOULD THE ARBOR THE STEAM
TRANSPORTATION. IF YOU TOOK A
HISTORICALLY- OF WHAT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVEDONE IN TERMS
OF. YOU KNOW FINANCING
TRANSPORTATION OF WE COULD
START WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE- SO WAS THE LAST TIME THEY
RAISED- ANY KIND OF REVENUE
INCREASES FOR TRANSPORTATION.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND-
BECAUSE THE GAS TAX IS A PER
GALLON TAX- IT DOESN'T RESPOND
TO INFLATION SO IT WE LOST THE-
OVER TIME- BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DUE TO. THE INFLATION FROM THE
FEDERAL SHARE OF-
TRANSPORTATION THERE THE STATE
SO. OF INCREASE THE GASOLINE
TAX IN NINETY TWO AND THEN THE
SP ONE. AND WE ALSO INCREASED A
VEHICLE MADE HIS FEE AND THE
DIESEL FUEL TAX DIESEL FUEL TAX
WENT TO TRANSIT. THE FUNDING
SOME OF THE TRANSIT PROGRAMS.
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF PAST-
SO- SALES TAX INCREASES. OF
SOME COUNTIES HAVE SUCCEEDED
SOME HAVE NOT. IN OTHER
COUNTIES THE- THEY TRIED OF IT
BUT IT REQUIRES OF COURSE A TWO
THIRDS VOTE- AND SO WE HAVE
SOME WINNERS AND LOSERS THERE
IN TERMS OF FUNDING- THE STATE
ALSO DID BONDING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX THE TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION BOND AND- FOR
BILLION AND HOUSING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOR BILL FOR
OUSTING. SO. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
FUNDING. TRANSPORTATION AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. IF
YOU DEVELOP A PLAN ARE YOU. IF
YOU DEVELOP A PLAN DON'T TRY TO
COME UP WITH A WAY OF FINDING
IT I THINK THAT WOULD BE A BIG
MISTAKE. I THINK I THINK YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN THAT
ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING OR
OTHER AND GATHERS DUST ON. THE
ACADEMICS BOOKSHELVES SO. WOULD
YOU CONSIDER WHAT KIND OF
OPTIONS WE HAVE FOR. FUNDING
TRANSPORTATION THAT ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE- GOALS WE
HAVE FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS COULD YOU
COULD YOU CONSIDER BONDING
BANZER INTEREST RATES RIGHT NOW
IS PRETTY GOOD. OF IF YOU BUILD
THE PROJECTS IN LOS ANGELES FOR
THE OLYMPICS AND THE BARD TO
SAN JOSE AND OTHER PROJECTS
QUICKER WITH BINDING- YOU
ACHIEVE. DECADES WORDS OF
ADDITIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE PROJECTS DONE FASTER THE
PROJECTS ARE ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS ALREADY READY TO GO
THEY'RE TRYING TO BUILD THEIR
TRYING TO FINANCE THEM AND
BUILD THEM IN PHASES BUT STILL
BUILDING PHASES THEY CAN BUILD
THE WHOLE PROJECT IN ACHIEVE-
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOLD A
LOT QUICKER IF YOU CAN BUILD
THEM FASTER SO. WHAT KIND OF
WHAT KIND OF. WHAT KIND OF
FINANCING- WITH THE STATE COME
UP WITH IF YOU DEVELOP YOUR
TRANSPORTATION AIR QUALITY
PLANNING THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. FOR A CLOSER LOOK AT OUR
MONEY OF COURSE AS GOOD AS THE
COURSE. GERMAN BILL ALL THE
OPTIONS YOU YOU OUT ONE HAVE TO
BE ON THE TABLE- AND AS WE AS
YOU POINTED OUT AS WE DISCUSS
THE LAST TIME MOST BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE. SB ONE. A
MAGNIFICENT ACCOMPLISHMENT. IT
DOES NOT MEET ALL THE NEEDS OF
THE STATE WHEN IT COMES
TRANSPORTATION- THE US
DEPARTMENT TRAVELS DAILY FOR.
BACKLOG OF REPAIRS THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE FOR. DECADES
CORRECT THAT'S AND- THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION EVERY
YEARPUTS OUT A REPORT CALLED
THE ANNUAL CONDITIONS AND
PERFORMANCE REPORT WHICH LOOKS
OUT. WHAT IT WOULD COST TO
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM BOTH
HIGHWAYS AND TRANSIT. AND WHAT
WOULD IT COST TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM THERE IS NOT ENOUGH NOT
ENOUGH MONEY. TO MAINTAIN. LET
ALONE IMPROVE THE SYSTEM. AND
SO THIS IS AN ISSUE- NOT UNIQUE
TO CALIFORNIA'S NATIONWIDE
ABOUT YOUR CALIFORNIA ALL THE
OPTIONS HAVE TO BE ON THE TABLE
INCLUDING- PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS. NOW THAT IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR PUBLIC FUND
FUNDING- THREES WORK IN SOME
SINCE THE TUITIONS BUT NOT
EVERYWHERE- AND SO ALL THOSE
ALL THOSE OPTIONS MUST BE ON
THE TABLE. IF THE FOR MY
BILLING- METRO. IN LOS ANGELES.
AND I END UP BECAUSE OF LACK OF
FINANCE EVEN THOUGH I HAVE THE
PLAN AND- THE PLANS BEEN
APPROVED ALL THE DOCUMENTS.
WITH THE FIND EVER BART TO SAN
JOSE OR CALTRAIN OR JUST NAME
ANY OF THESE TRANSIT PROJECTS
ARE ALL IT'S ALL THE SAME OKAY
IS NO DIFFERENT REALLY BUT YOUR
BILL IT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE MOSTLY MOSTLY
LOCALLY FUNDED. THEY'RE
BUILDING I'M IN PHASES. THE
BUILDING AND PIECES. AND
BUILDING THINGS IN PIECES.
DOESN'T ACHIEVE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION BECAUSE
YOU GOTTA HAVE YOU GOTTA HAVE
TRANSIT THE GOES FROM POINT A
TO POINT B. COMPLETED RATHER
THAN LITTLE. PIECES ALONG THE
WAY LIKE GOING DOWN WILSHIRE
BOULEVARD- GOING GOING THROUGH
THE LOS ANGELES METRO GETTING
TO THE AIRPORT- OF ALL THE ALL
THE ROOM THE LINES THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO BUILD AND SAN DIEGO
AND- AND- EXTENSION OF THE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION. IN TO-
MEANT FOR OR- WE SHOULD NOT WE
SHOULD LOOK AT FINANCING THESE
THINGS BECAUSE OF WE GET OF GET
IT DONE QUICKER. THE DIVIDEND
IS MORE TONS OF POLLUTANTS OUT
OF THERE RIGHT I MEAN YOU KNOW
YOU GET YOU GET BETTER GET
BETTER BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IF
YOU FINANCE THINGS LIKE THAT
AND GET HIM BUILT OSCAR. EVEN
THOUGH YOU MIGHT BE PAYING HIM
OFF OVER TIME YOU'RE STILL
GETTING A DIVIDEND THAT EXCEEDS
THE INTEREST COST. IS WHAT I'M
SAYING YOU KNOW AND- PROBABLY
THE CONSTRUCTION COSTS LOST. SO
IS THERE IS IT DO YOU HAVE SOME
SCHEMES THAT ARE BEING WORKED
OUT. TO PROPOSE. SOME FINANCING
FOR SOME OF THE TRANSIT
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. I
THINK YOU CORRECTLY POINTED OUT
THE FACT THE REALITY THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO TRANSIT EXTENSIONS
WEATHERBY BARGE SAN JOSE OR THE
LA NATURAL PURPLE LINE
EXTENSION. THOSE ARE BEING DONE
IN PHASES BECAUSE THAT THE READ
THE FUNDING FOR PULLING OUT A
COUPLE ON. THE REALITY OF
FUNDING THE WAY THESE FUNDING
PROGRAMS WORK ESPECIALLY THE
FEDERAL LEVEL DOES NOT ALLOW.
IN TIRED EXTENSION TO BE BUILT
IN ONE FELL SWOOP AND UNTIL
THERE IS WHOLESALE CHANGE
ESPECIALLY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IN TERMS OF HOW. TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND SYSTEMS ARE OFF.
FOR IT'S GOING TO BE THAT MEAL
UP. THAT SIMPLY THE WAY THIS IS
SET UP SPECIAL THE FEDERAL. AND
DELETED DURABILITY BE A CHANGE
ON THAT NOW THIS THE TRIGGER
THAT'S MY NEXT QUESTION THE
FEDERAL- THE FRAMEWORK HAS BEEN
RELEASED BY THE HOUSE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE. WE
HAVE THE FRAMEWORKS IT SEEMS TO
BE SOMETHING THAT'S OVER
ORIENTED TOWARDS REDUCING.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS I LOOK
AT YOU LOOKED IT AND MY
CORRECTED TO. THE NEW FRAMEWORK
PRESENTED I THINK IS ONE BY THE
SENATE ALSO. OF THE SENATE HAS
PRODUCED A DOCUMENT AS WELL FOR
THE FIRST. THING AT THE FOR THE
GOING TO TRY TO FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THIRTY YEARS OR
WHATEVER. TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOME FINANCING OF
INFRASTRUCTURE- WITH THIS
DOCTOR WITH THIS DOCUMENT- FIT
IN WITH OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. PLANNING AND- AND
THE GOVERNOR'S INTENTION TO
HAVE A- A TRANSPORTATION ACTION
A TRANSPLANTED ACTION. PLAN
THAT WE NEED TO FINANCE WITH
THAT WOULD THAT BE. SOMETHING
YOU THINK IS COMPATIBLE WITH
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. AND
HOW CAN WE HELP THEM GET THAT
ARE APPROVED. YET YES
ABSOLUTELY GOVERNOR GO OUT AND
START. YOU KNOW BROWSE THE
TROOPS SERGEI YOU MIGHT SAY THE-
HELP US GET THIS. BECAUSE THEY
NEVER YOU KNOW THEY SHOULD BE.
THIS SHOULD BE A KEY ISSUE IN
THIS SPECIALLY IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION RIGHT.
RIGHT OUT OF FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO ABOUT THIS
POLLUTION YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS STUFF. ABSOLUTELY AS
WE DISCUSSED LAST TIME THE
HOUSE YOU KNOW I COMMITTEE CAME
OUT WITH A FRAMEWORK THAT IS.
REALLY PROMISING- SO I'M
ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A LANGUAGE ON RESERVE
RESILIENCY AND CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE FACT THAT IT INCREASES
FUNDING FOR ALMOST A%
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING RAIL.
TRANSIT INTERCITY PASSENGER
RAIL YOU NAME IT- THERE IS A
LOT TO LIKE IN THE IN THE TEEN
ARE FREE WORK. THE PERENNIAL
QUESTION ALWAYS BEFORE CONGRESS
IS HOW DO YOU PAY FOR IT. THERE
IS NO POLITICAL CENTERS ON HOW
YOU DO THAT WHETHER IT'S
INDEXING THE GAS TAX RAISING
THE GAS TAX- OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM. THAT IS WHAT'S
HOLDING BACK- SWIFT ACTION ON A
CONGRESSIONAL REAUTHORIZATION
THE FAST ACT- I WAS IN
WASHINGTON LAST WEEK WE MADE
THE ROUNDS WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION. WE
ALSO KNOW WHICH SHERMAN PETER
DEFAZIO THE HOW CAN I COMMITTEE
BECAUSE YOU AND- AND MENTIONED-
OUR OUR VIEWS ON HIS FRAMEWORK
AND WE SAID WE SAID GOOD THINGS
ABOUT IT IT'S- IT'S FOR
PROMISING. UP AND ONLY LIKE TO
BE ONE. YES IN. THE GAS TO. IT
HAS BEEN ONE IN THE- RESET WE
GOTTA DO THE FEDERAL. YEAH
THAT'S RIGHT I WOULD HELP A LOT.
SO ON THE ONE HAND IT'S VERY
PROMISING TO SEE WHAT'S COMING
OUT OF THE HOUSE AND THE U. S.
SENATE. ON THE OTHER HAND UNTIL
THEY COME TO A CONSENSUS ON HOW
TO PAY FOR IT- THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE. THANK YOU- MEMBERS. START
SORRY I DON'T MEAN TO RUSH BUT
I. AND I HAVE TO I HAVE TO JUMP
I JUST WANTED. MAKE A FINER
POINT ON CHAIRMAN BILLS
CRITICAL. EMPHASIS HOW SHORT
ARE WE LETTING THEM YES IS
DIFFERENT HOW MUCH MONEY WILL
COST TO ACHIEVE OUR
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
SCHOOLS LIKE IF WE WERE
ACTUALLY TO. MEET. OUR
OBJECTIVES HOW HOW SHORT OR WE
RIGHT. I'M SURE WE CAN DO SO
BALCONY OF THE- CALCULATIONS
WITH THE HELP OF SOME ACADEMIC
EXPERTS BUT IF I GET BACK TO
YOU WE ARE SHORT THERE'S NO
QUESTION. LET ME KNOW WHEN I
WAS LOOKING A RODENT REPAIRED
JUST BACKLOG THERE THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY REDUCING EMISSIONS
AT ALL I THINK WE'RE SEVENTY
EIGHT BILLION IT SHORT- BASED
ON. THERE'S A RAND STUDY THAT'S
JUST ON THAT SIDE A THINK WHAT
WE'RE GONNA FIFTY EIGHT BILLION
OFF SB ONE JUST TO DO THAT SO
THEN. THAT'S JUST MAINTAINING
THE EXISTING SYSTEM. YOU CAN
ARGUE ACTUALLY DOESN'T. DO
ANYTHING MUCH TO HELP. BUT ARE
WE TALKING THAT ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE ARE WE TALKING LIKE
IN A HUNDRED BILLION RANGE ARE
WE TALKING IN THE FIVE BILLION
RANGE I KNOW SOME OF IT IS
STICKS TO SO I. IT'S A QUESTION
THAT IS A FLUID. IT YOU KNOW
ORIENTATION AND THAT WAY RIGHT
BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU HAVE
STRICTER YELL VMT OR HOUSING
POLICY OR IF YOU POLLED TURN
THIS LEVER HERE ON THE VEHICLE
SIDE BUT- I'M TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF. WHAT A REASONABLE
SCOPE TO IT OVERALL
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
REDUCTION INVESTMENT STRATEGY
LOOKS LIKE HERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN
SAN DIEGO- WE'VE GOT THE DEL
MAR BLUFFS WHICH IS JUST NORTH
OF SAN DIEGO THE CITY OF DEL
MAR. THAT IS HOME TO ONE OF THE
MOST- ACTUALLY CERTIFICATE RAIL
CORRIDORS ANYWHERE- IT'S HOME
TO THE LOS AND CORRIDOR AMTRAK
PACIFIC SURFLINER FROM SAN
DIEGO TO LA TO SAN LUIS OBISPO
IT ALSO CARE FREE REAL. DAHLE
MORE BLUFFS IS EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT EROSION EVERY TIME
THERE'S A MAJOR STORM EVENT AND
THERE ARE EFFORTS UNDERWAY TO
STABILIZE THOSE PLUS BUT THE
LONG TERM SOLUTION. IS TO MOVE
THOSE RAILROAD TRACKS AWAY FROM
THE BLUFFS. THAT'S A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSITION IF
YOU MULTIPLY THAT BY ALL THE
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE
HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY AND
SENATOR DODD'S AREA- MANY
OTHERS HIGHWAY ONE LAST TRANCE
GREAT UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IT COULD BE I'M
JUST GUESSING BUT IT COULD BE
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS IT'S A LOT
OF MONEY. I WAS JUST GOING TO
ADD THAT- WE ARE FOCUSED HERE
ADD RIGHTLY SO ON THE PIECE OF
THIS INVOLVES. BE EMPTY BUT- WE
STILL HAVE TO DO THE
TRANSFORMATION TO. ELECTRIC
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND WE
DO HAVE A ESTIMATE OF THE PRICE
ON THAT WHICH IS NOT NEARLY AS
SITE IS SO. GIVE US A SENSE- OF
WELL THE I THINK A BETWEEN THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND- A. R. B.
WE SHOULD PROBABLY GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT BUT- WE'VE LOOKED
AT- YOU KNOW KIND OF TEN YEAR
PROJECTIONS TO GET TO THE-
GOALS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SAID AND IT'S- MORE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF A COUPLE OF
BILLION A YEAR. OVER A TEN YEAR
PERIOD. AND I MEAN WHEN I LOOK
HERE I SEE A 5% CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION OPERATIONS CHUNK.
THERE IS NO LONG TERM FUNDING
STREAM ON LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION WRIT LARGE EVERY
YEAR IT'S UP AND DOWN AND CV
ARPINO C. V. R. P. AND THERE'S
A LOT OF FITS AND STARTS WHICH-
IS. DEEPLY CONCERNING TO ME
THAT THE MARKET HAS NO. THERE
BUT I JUST I THINK THOSE
NUMBERS WOULD. I KNOW THEY'LL
BE INTIMIDATING WHEN YOU ALL
COME BACK TO US WITH THEM- BUT
I THINK WE NEED TO BE HONEST
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE
CHALLENGE. AND REALLY RIGHT
SIZE OUR CONVERSATION. AND THEN
SAY OKAY. WERE THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS SHORT. ARE WHAT
IS THAT LOOK LIKE BUT MAYBE WE
CAN EXECUTE. THIS IS A HAVE
PIECE FOR TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS OR- GO BEAT THE FOUR OH
FIVE IN THE FIVE FREEWAY FOR
WHATEVER THE- THE D. I'M- OF
THE SURFLINER BY THE WAY.
WAITING FOR THE FREIGHT.
FRIENDS TO MY FOR AND GOODS
MOVEMENT BECAUSE WE NEED. I
LOVE THAT LINE ANY TRUST ME TO
KNOW WHEN THEY GOT ME EVEN. WE
CAN SEE ICE BE REAL TALKED
ABOUT YET IN THIS HEARING- OR
ON THE LIST OF ANY OF THE
STRATEGY SO I AM CURIOUS ABOUT
THAT BUT- I GUESS EVEN SETTING
THAT ASID- THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA ALONE. DWARFS
THE 25% CONTINUES APPROPRIATION
THAT IS GOING JUST TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL NOW RIGHT I MEAN AND
VERY LITTLE OF THAT IT'S COMING
DOWN TO LA SO I JUST I WANT TO
RIGHT SIZE THAT CONVERSATION I
GUESS THE LAST QUESTION WOULD
BE. IS SETTING ASIDE MAYBE THE
BIG INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE FOR YOU
SECRETARY CAME IN MAY BE ON THE
SAFE SIDE- AND LOOK IN THAT
SORT OF CARBON SPACE L. CFS
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT HOW TO GET
MAYBE MORE CREATIVE ABOUT THAT
COMPLIANCE MARKET I KNOW THAT
BILLIONS IN THAT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE TEN BILLION
OVER THE NEXT DECADE THAT COMES
IN BUT IT COMES IN AFTER THE
FACT IN A LOT OF THIS FLOWS OUT
OF STATE. THEIR WAYS TO
MONETIZE YOUR SECURITIZED. SOME
OF THAT COMPLIANCE MARKET TO
HELP AT LEAST TO THE V.
INFRASTRUCTURE BETTER SO WE
DON'T JUST HAVE TO LEAN ON JI
JURA FOR EVER. YEAH I THINK OF
THE FIRST PHASE OF OUR EFFORTS
TO KIND OF- THINK MORE
CREATIVELY ABOUT THAT PROGRAM-
HAVE BEEN TO WORK WITH THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO TAKE SOME
OF. THE VALUE THAT WENT TO THEM
FOR MOVING OUT WITH ELECTRIC
CHARGING STATIONS AS A WAY OF
GAINING CREDITS. UNDER THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD. AND HAVE
THEM CONTRIBUTED TOWARDS A
PROGRAM THAT WILL PUT. MONEY ON
THE HOOD AS WE SAY OF BUYING A
LECTOR VEHICLES SO GIVE THE
GIVE THE DEALERS AN INCENTIVE
TO BE MORE. ACTIVELY INVOLVED
AND THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
AND THE WILL TO. DOWN COSTS
UNTIL WE TO REAL PARITY. IN THE
NEW CAR MARKET- BUT THE NEXT
IDEA WHICH YOU'RE ALLUDING TO
WHICH IS TO HOW TO FOCUS ON WHO
GETS THE CREDIT SEND. GETS DONE
FROM IS THE- NEXT NEXT IN LINE
IN TERMS OF OUR ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU THE CHAIRS AND THANK
YOU BOTH FOR COMING TODAY. MY
MIND IS ALL OVER THE PLACE I
HAVE A LOT GOING ON IN MY HEAD
RIGHT NOW AND I'M GOING TO TRY
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
THIS HEARING IS BASICALLY.
TOUCHES ON A LOT OF AREAS AND
YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT TO JUST
STATE FIRST YOUR APPOINTED AND
THAT'S A NICE PLACE TO BE AND
WE'RE ELECTED WHICH IS
SOMETIMES NOT SO NICE PLACE TO
BE WHEN YOU'RE HAPPEN TO
GRAPPLE WITH ALL OF. OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW WHAT I HEARD CONVERSATION
EARLIER ABOUT. YEAH YOU KNOW
STADIUMS LIKES OF WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS POLITICALLY IN THIS
BUILDING. BUT I WANT TO JUST
KIND OF MAYBE BACK UP A LITTLE
BIT AND TALK ABOUT YOUR
TRANSPORTATION AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE'VE HEARD FOR SINCE SHE
SENATOR KEWL DID SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE A LONG TIME AGO
AND WHEN I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WE WERE LOOKING AT
THOSE INSANE HOW ARE WE GOING
TO COMPLY WITH THIS AND NOW.
ALMOST FIFTEEN OR EIGHTEEN
YEARS LATER WE'RE TRYING TO
COPE WITH TRANSPORTATION AND
WHEN YOU'RE ABOUT THREE MILLION
HOME SHORTEN CALIFORNIA HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO GET THOSE HOMES
WHERE PEOPLE GONNA LIVE WHEN
WE'VE DONE ALL KINDS OF
LEGISLATIVE. FIXES I GUESS WE
HAVE EIGHTY USE NOW THAT WE CAN
PUT IN PEOPLE'S BACKYARDS-
WHICH DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
TRANSPORTATION SO WHERE I'M
HEADING WITH THIS IS THAT
POLITICALLY YOU KNOW WE HAD SB
FIFTY HERE AND WE COULDN'T GET
THE WE COULDN'T GET OUT OF
HERE. IT GOT HUNG UP AND YOU
KNOW WE HEARD THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN. IN
THAT AREA. AGAIN THIS YEAR AND
THEN WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME
AND I HAPPEN TO BE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO SIT ON BOTH THE
CHAIRMAN'S COMMITTEES AND I'M
REALLY SUPER EXCITED ABOUT
THAT. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
OVERLAP IN HOW WE LOOK GLOBALLY
AT. OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT I THINK THAT
WE REALLY MISS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I KNOW THAT. THAT THE CHAIR
OF THE AIRPORT WHO SAT ON THE
BIODIVERSITY COUNSELED MANY
YEARS BACK AND I HAPPENED TO
BE. A PARTICIPATING THAT AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR WITH RC RC IF
YOU RECALL- WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FIRE IN WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE PUT IN SB
NINE A ONE TWO. TO CALCULATE
THE AMOUNT OF YOU KNOW FORCE
FIRE MISSIONS THAT WE- YOU
KNOW. THE AND MET IN CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK THAT WE MISSED THAT
WE MISSED THE BOAT THERE THEN
WE DON'T. TALK ABOUT THAT AS
MUCH AS WE FOCUS ON.
TRANSPORTATION A LOT AND IT'S A
VERY HEAVY BURDEN FOR BUSINESS
AND IT'S COST. PER TIME THE
COST IS VERY HIGH AND THEN ON
THE I WANT TO TOUCH ON THIS
WHICH- I KNOW NOBODY LIKES TO
HEAR IT BUT IT'S A FACT. WE
HAVE THE BULLET TRAIN THAT'S
BEING. SUPER SPENDING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON THAT AND I I'M
CONVINCED WE SHOULD CUT OFF
THAT AND- LEAVE IT AND TAKE
THOSE RESOURCES AND- GO DO.
RAIL TRANSPORTATION. IN IN HIGH
POPULATED AREAS IN THE CITIES
WHERE WE CAN REALLY MAKE AN
IMPACT ON GHG. SO I JUST WANT
TO THROW THAT OUT I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON. AND THEN WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT AND I WANTED ALSO TOUCH
ON. YOU KNOW. YEARS BACK WE
TALKED ABOUT GOING REDUCING
OUR- FOOTPRINT WITH COAL AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO NATURAL
GAS. AND NOW WE WENT FROM
NATURAL GAS TO BATTERIES THAT'S
WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING A LOT
ABOUT IS STORAGE IN BATTERIES
IN THIS BUILDING SO I HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT TV'S I'M
ACTUALLY DOING SOME LEGISLATION
IN THIS AREA I DID SOME
LEGISLATION THIS AREA ON. ON
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT WHAT
WE GONNA DO WITH IN THE LIFE OF
BATTERIES NOBODY'S REALLY HAD
THAT CONVERSATION AND WHAT IS
THE WHAT IS THE FOOT PRINT LOOK
LIKE TO THE ENVIRONMENT WHEN WE
HAVE A MILLION DVDS AND THEY'RE
INTO THEIR LIFE IS THERE. SO I
DID SOME LEGISLATION WERE
SUPPOSED TO GET BACK SOME
INFORMATION ON WHAT THE PLAN
IS- GOING FORWARD. SO I WANT TO
JUST. THROW THAT OUT TO YOU I
ALSO WANT TO SAY. THAT THIS IS
A DIFFICULT SITUATION WE NEED
TO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
HOMES WE IT'LL BUILD. REDUCE
FIELD MILES TRANCE ED THE-
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AND YOU
KNOW I HEARD IN YOUR COMMENTS
YOU SAY THAT YOU KNOW. WE NEED
A REVOLUTION I DON'T KNOW WHAT
KIND OF REVOLUTION YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR BUT- AND ALSO WE
NEED TO PUSH PEOPLE TO GET
WHERE WE WANT TO GO. AND I
THINK THOSE ARE DANGEROUS AREAS
IN THE IN THESE FOR THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE TO PUT OUR NAME ON THE
BALLOT AND- ACTUALLY EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
AND I DON'T THINK. THIS IS THE
POINT OF MY MESSAGE. I WANT TO
BE THE TABLE WITH YOU ALL TO.
TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS ONE
BY ONE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE SILENT BUT HOLISTICALLY
I THINK WE- DON'T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB. BUT WITH TO BRING THE
PUBLIC ALONG WE HAVE NOT SPENT
THEIR MONEY WISELY. I THINK WE
TOO ARE NOT CREDIBLE ONE WHEN
WE COME BACK AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COST PER TON. I THINK THERE'S
BETTER WAYS WE COULD REDUCE OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT AND I AND I
SAY THAT WOULD FORCE FIRE THINK
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD USE NATURAL
GAS AS A BRIDGE UNTIL WE GET
THE EEVEE STAGGERED OUT AND
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AS FAR
STORAGE GOES I DON'T THINK
REMAIN CLOSE THEIR TECHNOLOGY
WISE. A LOT OF PEOPLE THEY'RE
SAYING THAT BUT THE COST TIME
AND FORCING PEOPLE OUT I HAD
THE MANUFACTURES OF DVDS-
OURSELVES BE OTHER CAR DEALERS
WHO ARE FORCED BASICALLY TO
SOMEONE ON THE LOT THEY'RE NOT.
WE GET ABOUT WE'RE WE'RE
PUSHING THE PUBLIC IN A WAY
THAT I DON'T THINK IS THERE ONE
TO GO OR THEY DON'T LIKE IT AND
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT WILL HEAD BUT
I THINK THAT'S DANGEROUS I
THINK THAT WE'LL GET SOME
BLOWBACK. AND I THINK WE NEED
TO DO IN A BETTER WAY SO I WANT
TO BE THE TABLE AS WE SHOULD
HAVE THE OF I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
WE'RE SPENDING MR ASKING FOR
MORE I MEAN. WE HEARD THAT IN
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE STUDYOR
HEARING WE HAD A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO AND I DON'T THINK WE'RE
SPENDING HAVE. PROBABLY SO WITH
THAT. AS ONE. THAT WE NEED
MAYBE SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT
HERE AND LOOK AT WAYS TO MYBE.
LEGISLATORS GAY SOME OF THESE.
OUT OF THE OUT OF THE HOUSE
HERE- THROUGH YOUR THE HELP OF
YOUR BOSS- TO PICK ACTUALLY
DEUCE. SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT LIKE SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE. SAID IF WE
CAN'T GET THE TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING IN THE SAME PLACES.
THANK NO I JUST WANT O POINT
OUT TO THE ANNOUNCED TO THE
COMMITTEE OF TRANSPORTATION
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING OUR-
REVIEW OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUSINESS PLAN ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH OF THE DOCUMENT IS NOW
AVAILABLE FOR YOU TO LOOK AT-
THE- PRESENT A- BUSINESS PLAN
UNDER THE STATUTE TO. THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES EVERY
TWO YEARS SO THIS PLAN WILL BE
PRESENTED TO OUR COMMITTEE ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH. WE WILL
HAVE TIME TO REVIEW IT- BEFORE
THEY ADOPT THE BUSINESS PLAN.
WE GOT A- NIFTY BACKGROUND
INFORMATION WE NORMALLY KILL
SIDE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT-
WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THAT- WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING TO REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS I
JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON SOME
OF THOSE WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THE CORPORATE. AVERAGE
FUEL ECONOMY THE CAFE STANDARDS
IN AN EVIDENTLY THERE'LL BE
LITIGATION THAT THERE IS
LITIGATION TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE MAXIMAL MAXIMUM FEASIBLE
LEVEL IS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WHEN I'M- INTERESTED IN IS
WHOSE MAY MEANING THAT STANDARD
TODAY WHAT ARE AND I GOT
PLAINTIFFS DEFENDANTS DON'T
REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
BUT IN THE- THE AUTOMOBILE
WORLD WHOSE MEETING THOSE.
FLEET STANDARDS TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION IF I COULD
JUST QUICKLY- MAKE SURE THAT
I'D SAY FOR THE RECORD AND MY
LAWYERS WOULD BE MAD IF I
DIDN'T THAT- ERROR BE AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DON'T
ACTUALLY REGULATE FUEL ECONOMY
WE HAVE NO LEGAL AUTHORITY IN
THAT AREA AT ALL. THAT'S ALL
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT'S A
WHERE WE COME INTO THE PICTURE
IS THAT WE HAVE STANDARDS FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. NOW
AS IT TURNS OUT GREENHOUSE TO
MEET A GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
STANDARD FROM A VEHICLE MANY OF
THE THINGS YOU WOULD DO ALSO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON FEEL ECONOMY
SO THE TWO STANDARDS WERE DONE
TOGETHER AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND THEN CALIFORNIA BOUGHT INTO
IT. BUT WE'RE VERY CAREFUL
NEVER TO SET A FUEL ECONOMY
LEVEL OR SAY THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE ARE ONLY
FOCUSING ON ON ON THE HOUSE
GASSES. AND ARE. TO MEET THOSE
STAND AS THEY ALSO DO SOME
THINGS RELATING TO OPERATION
THE VEHICLES ACTIVE ERIC THING
SYSTEMS AND OTHER THINGS LIKE
ONE. ACCOUNT WELL I THINK IN
THE LONG RUN THAT'S THE
DIRECTION ACTUALLY THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
HEADED IN AS WELL BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLAINTS
THAT THE CAFE SYSTEM. ALTHOUGH
IT WAS WELL INTENDED TO HELP
SAVE PETROLEUM AND A TIME WHEN
THAT WAS THE THING WE ARE MOST
WORRIED ABOUT AS IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED- IT INCENTIVIZE
LARGER HEAVIER VEHICLES AT THE
EXPENSE OF LESS. Vì AND MORE
FUEL EFFICIENT VIA. HAS OTHERS
ANGEL TEACHERS ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY. I'M NOT
PARTICULARLY HOPEFUL TODAY IS
CAP A STANDARDS. CAN THEM I IN
THE IN THE TOP FOUR TIME THANK
THE WAY THIS WORKS THE PEOPLE
GET. AND THEN A CAN SELL BLOOM.
TO OTHER MEN IF. SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN BE IN COMPLIANCE EITHER BY
PRODUCING CARS THAT MEET THE
STANDARD OR BUY CREDITS FROM
OTHER COMPANIES THAT HAVE NOT
LIMON ATTY AND SO EVERYONE IS
IN COMPLIANCE AND MOMENT. A LOT
OF THE FIGHT IT'S GOING ON AT
THE PRO LEVEL TO DO THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A COUPLE OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE NOW MOVING
INTO HAVING TO BUY. MOST OF
THEIR CREDITS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A FLEET THAT MEETS
THE STANDARDS AND THEY REALLY
DON'T WANT TO BE IN THAT
POSITION SO THEY'RE TRYING TO
GET THE STANDARDS WEAKENED. AND
I GUESS THAT BRINGS US TO THIS
ZEV MANDATE BECAUSE WE HAVE WE
HAVE A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
VEHICLES THAT MUST BE SOLD. IN
CALIFORNIA- BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE CAN YOU UPDATE THE
COMMITTEES ON HOW THOSE ARE
GOING BACK BECAUSE WE KNOW
THERE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
VEHICLES AND THAT'S VERY. THE
LARGEST BIT BUT BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE'RE ON
TARGET TO MEET OUR STANDARDS
GIVEN THE CURRENT. SENSE IS
THAT MANDATE- WAS INTENDED TO
SET A FLOOR. AND WE ARE NOW
DOING OR OR BACK ON TRACK. WITH
THE WITH THE MANDATE TO GET TO
THE 10% THAT WAS REQUIRED UNDER
THAT REGULATION. BUT AS I
INDICATED IN MY TESTIMONY WE
NEED A LOT MORE THAN THAT. IN
ORDER TO MEET OUR AIR QUALITY
AND TRANSPORTATION GOALS SO
SOME PEOPLE HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
WE SHOULD JUST RAISE THE
MANDATE THAT WOULD BE A WAY TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND- NOT.
WORRY O MUCH ABOUT INCENTIVES
IN THE MARKET AND SO FORTH THAT
IT HAS BEEN A CONSCIOUS
DECISION ON OUR PART THAT WE
WOULD DO BETTER. AND IN IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING WHERE CONSUMERS
ULTIMATELY HAVE THE HOICE AS
TO WHAT THEY WANT TO BUY AND
WHETHER THEY WANT TO BUY A NEW
CAR AND ALL. THAT WE SHOULD TRY
TO MAKE IT MORE ATTRACTIVE AND
EASY FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE THE
SWITCH INTO INTO THIS ALLEN
MISSION WORLD. IT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION WE HAD. BUDGET ONE
GREEN AND- DID YOU HEAR F. FOR.
THAT THE- OUR GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SPENDING THE FUNDS
FOR THE- SCV OUR P. HAS BEEN
REDUCED FROM A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION TO A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION AND THERE'S SOME
OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS BUT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT- A
REDUCTION I. AM I GUESS THE
SIMPLE THINKING WOULD BE IF YOU
GIVE PEOPLE A TAX CREDIT- YOU
GIVE PEOPLE MONEY TO BUY
SOMETHING THERE'S MORE
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO BUY IT
HOW IT WHAT'S THE- THE
DEPARTMENTS WERE THE AIRPORTS
THINKING IF WE REDUCE THE
INCENTIVE AS WE KNOW HOW DOES
THAT HOW DO WE MAKE THAT UP I
THINK THE BEST ANSWER TO THAT.
THE POINT IS TO SAY THAT. THIS
IS A TOPIC THAT NEEDS A BROADER
DISCUSSION- THAT AS A AS WE
WERE SAYING EARLIER THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT ALL OF OUR
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND THE
MANDATE FOR EXAMS. AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S A COMBINATION THAT'S
GOING TO GET US THE FOR THIS
THE FASTEST MAN. OF I THINK
WE'LL HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITIES
TO REVISIT THERE AMOUNTS THOSE
PROGRAMS WE MOVE ON IN THE
BUDGET. CONVERSATIONS AS WELL.
AS A GUEST SUITE THE QUESTION
IS THAT COSTS BECAUSE I THINK.
YOU FOLKS JUST ISSUED A REPORT
ON OR THE ENERGY. DEPARTMENT H.
ISSUE THE REPORT ON WHAT'S THE
BENEFIT HOW MANY MISSIONS ARE
WE GOING TO GET REDUCE. IN BY
TWENTY FORTY OR WHATEVER THE
DATE IS IN AN OUR REPORTS IS
NEARLY. THREE BILLION I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S THREE BILLION BUT
WHERE ARE WHERE THE WHERE THAT
NUMBER CAME FROM BUT- CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE COST. OF THE C.
V. R. P. PROGRAM WE YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT THE METRIC TONS WHAT
IS A COSTS IS FOR THE DOLLARS
THAT WE SPEND ON. ON THAT
PROGRAM IS IT ECONOMICAL OR IS
IT THE BEST PROGRAM WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. REDUCING
SECTOR SO I KNOW THE LIMITED
THE CHARGE BUT I HAVE A NUMBER.
I THINK IT SHOULD YOUR NUMBER
OR THAT THE ENERGY DEPARTMENT
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE.
DOLLARS PER METRIC TONS.
THROUGH THE C. C. R. P. PROGRAM
THAT SEEMS HIGH. OF WELL FIRST
OF ALL I GUESS ISHOULD SAY
THAT UNDER- AB THIRTY TWO WHICH
IS WHAT STARTED US DOWN THE
PATH TOWARDS DOING- GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION PROGRAM THOSE
EMISSIONS STANDARDS THAT WERE
IN THE ORIGINAL POWERFULLY
LEGISLATION. AB FOURTEEN NINETY
THREE I BELIEVE IT WAS-
REQUIRED THAT WE SAT AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
STANDARDS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
OVERALL AND THAT MOVED US INTO
CHANGING THESE HAVE MANDATE
WHICH IS REALLY ONLY FOCUSED ON
CONVENTIONAL AIR POLLUTANTS
INTO SOMETHING THAT WAS FOCUSED
ON GREENHOUSE GASES AS WELL AND
THAT BECAME KIND OF THE CORE OF
THE WHOLE SCOPING PLAN THAT WE
NOW HAVE AN EFFECT FOR
ACHIEVING OUR CLIMATE GOALS SO-
THAT PROGRAM IS SET IN THE LAWN
NOW AND- IF WE WERE TO LOSE
THAT. OR CHANGE IT WE'D HAVE TO
GO BACK TO GROUND ZERO IN TERMS
OF HOW WE'RE MEETING OUR
OVERALL GREENHOUSE GAS
OBJECTIVES THE MANDATE ON A RP
BUT TO TRY TO DEVELOP A COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM I MEAN WE
WERE REQUIRED TO DO THAT AND SO
WHAT WE DID WAS TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT IS A MIX OF. AYE
AYE CAPTAIN PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW
AND THE OF DIFFERENT. MATT
ELEMENTS IN GETTING THE
GREENHOUSE GAS PIPE TYPE
EMISSIONS STAND. AND PUT THAT
TOGETHER SO THAT THE NET OF
THAT SHOULD BE A MOST. COST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ACHIEVING THE
OVERALL GOAL AND WE'VE HAD THAT
LOOKED AT SEVERAL TIMES BY
OUTSIDE ECONOMISTS WHO HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY THOUGHT.
THAT KIND OF A NAY PROUD WHICH
WAS FACT THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT
SOME INCENTIVE SOME MANDATES
DIFFERENT SECTOR APPROACH TAKEN
TOGETHER MAKE SENSE OF THE
EXPENSE THE COST AS- AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE TO GET
TO THE TO GET TO THE GOAL. TO
WHAT YOUR MODELING NOW ARE
WHERE THEY ARE MODELING THAT
USE BETWEEN D. V. PURCHASES IN
THE- PRICE OF GASOLINE BECAUSE
ONCE UPON A TIME YOU KNOW I'M-
HAVEN'T HAVEN'T BEEN QUIET
ABOUT WHERE I THINK THE PRICE
OF GASOLINE SHE GO TO BUT- BUT
YOU MUST HAVE SOME MODELING AT
THE AIRPORT AND-
TRANSPORTATION. THEY SAID YOU
KNOW I GOT ELECTED IN TWENTY
TEN IF YOU WOULD HAVE TOLD ME I
WOULD BE BUYING GAS IN
SACRAMENTO IT'S TWO DOLLARS AND
NINETY CENTS A GALLON IN TWENTY
TWENTY I WAS SAID NOW IT'S
GOING TO BE. HAS TO BE HIGHER
IN THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE HAPPY
THAT SO WHAT'S YOUR MODELING
NOW AND THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT
THE AIRPORT HAS ON THE- PEOPLE
WHEN THE PEOPLE SWITCH OVER. IN
THE MARKET BASE IF WE'RE NOT
GIVING HIM AS TV E. R. P. TEN
OF US. POVERTY INTEGRATED AND
THEY GET THAT THERE'S A BY IN
E. V. AND THEY'RE STILL.
CHARGING STATE ANXIETY WHAT'S
THAT PRICE MODELING THAT YOU
GUYS ARE USING I WOULD HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT BUT THE
PEOPLE WHO DO THAT ARE ACTUALLY
AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION. FOUND
TO LOOK AT THE GASOLINE PRICES
AND AVAILABILITY YEAH. THAT'S
THAT'S WE WORK WITH THEM ON
THAT. OKAY ON THE TWO. BUT AS I
THINK ABOUT THE ACT PROGRAMS
BUT- WHAT WE PROMISED THE CHAIR
THAT WE GET ARE OUT HERE AT TEN
THIRTY BECAUSE I KNOW SHE'S GOT
OTHER COMMITMENTS- SO JOINT.
CAN YOU MAKE A REQUEST HI I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO THE
BUDGET SUB TO DISCUSSIONS ON.
THAT THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND IN I CAN GET OUR NEXT
SPEAKER NEXT PANELIST THE-
ALLEY- IN THE ALLEY- HAS
INDICATED THAT THAT WE THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE 40% OF THE
PROCEEDS FROM CAP AND TRADE.
SHOULD LIMIT. OUR EXPECTATIONS
TO EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS A TWO BILLION
DOLLAR A- YEAR PROCEEDS FROM
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM SO.
MISTER SECRETARY THE- LONG LIST
OF PROJECTS THAT YOU HAVE SEEM
TO BE GETTING LESS MONEY UNDER
AT LEAST FROM THAT FROM THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. THIRTY
ANTICIPATION OF THE NEXT SERIES
OF YEARS IF THERE'S NOTHING
DONE WITH THE WAY THAT THE
OPTIONS ARE ARE YOU KNOW
OPERATOR RIGHT NOW SO JUST
LEAVE US WITH THAT IF THE
STATUS QUO WE EXPECTING A
SHRINKING BUDGET. IN AN INSTEAD
OF AN EXPANDING BUT FOR ALL
THESE PROGRAMS THAT WE LOVE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS REALLY DO APPRECIATE-
FASTENING DISCUSSION AND I WILL
SAY THAT IN MANY RESPECTS THE
NEXT PRESENTATION OF THE AUDIO
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT COST
EFFECTIVENESS- THERE'S SOME
INTERESTING CRITIQUES AND-
COMMENTS AND I KNOW THAT ROSS
IS GONNA BE MAKING SO. THANK
YOU TO THIS PANEL AND LET'S.
LET'S BRING UP BROWN SENT
PRINCIPLE. FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST WITH PHYLLIS OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE'LL
HEAR. ROSS PERSPECTIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRS ARE AND
MEMBERS ROSS PROBLEM AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SO TODAY I'M GONNA TRY TO HIT
ON JUST- THE HIGH POINTS OF
REPORT THAT OUR OFFICE
RELEASED. A LITTLE MORE THAN A
YEAR AGO- WHERE WE- ASSESS THE
STATE'S POLICIES THE MAJOR
POLICIES IN THE. TRANSPORTATION
AREA THE SERGEANTS TO BE IN AN
OUT HAND OUT WHICH TRY TO
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THOSE POINTS
I'LL BE ONE THROUGH TODAY. I
JUST FOR CONTACTS SO THAT
REPORT WAS DONE IN RESPONSE TO
THERE IS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT THAT OUR OFFICE.
REVIEW THE ECONOMIC AND TAX AND
BENEFITS OF THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS
ANNUALLY. AND SO THE APPROACH
WE'VE TAKEN IS TRY TO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT SECTORS AND KIND OF
POLICIES IN THOSE SECTORS. AND
TRY TO LOOK AT THE AVAILABLE
DATA AND INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT THOSE
POLICIES HAVE ACHIEVED BOTH
GOOD AND BAD. AND WHERE THERE
GAPS IN INFORMATION SO IT'S
LARGELY A- KIND OF
RETROSPECTIVE VIEW ON KIND OF
WHAT WE WHAT WE ACHIEVED SO FAR
WHICH WE HOPE IS KIND OF
INFORMATIVE FOR YOU AS YOU SORT
OF THINK ABOUT YOUR- YOUR GOALS
GOING FORWARD. SO IF YOU TURN
TO THE HAND OUT I'LL WE'VE
TOUCHED ON SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION ALREADY SO TRY TO
MOVE THROUGH IT FAIRLY QUICKLY
AND OF COURSE HAVE AN ANSWER
QUESTIONS. PAGE ONE OF THE HAND
OUT TO STANDING GIVES YOU. SOME
HIGH LEVEL CONTACTS FOR THE
STATE'S REENHOUSE GAS SCHOOLS-
ESTABLISH MAY BE THIRTY TWO AND
SB THIRTY TWO. AS YOU KNOW WE-
HAVE KIND OF HIT THAT- TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET A FEW YEARS
EARLY. I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
TAKEAWAYS FROM THE CHART ON
PAGE ONE IS THAT THE- TWENTY
THIRTY GOAL IS YOU KNOW IS MUCH
MORE AMBITIOUS THAN. TWENTY
TWENTY GOAL IN TERMS OF KIND OF
ANNUAL REDUCTIONS REQUIRED TO
MEET THAT TARGET- JUST FOR
CONTEXT THE KIND OF ANNUAL
REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO MEET THE
TWENTY TWENTY TARGET WERE.
ROUGHLY 1% PER YEAR. OR AS THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET IS CLOSER
24% PER YEAR SO THAT GIVES YOU-KIND OF A SENSE OF THE- LEVEL
OF AMBITION ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. TWENTY THIRTY. TURNING TO
PAGE TWO. OF THE HAND OUT-
DISTILLING DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON KIND OF WHERE WE'VE
SEEN EMISSIONS GO OVER THE
LAST. COUPLE OF DECADES. BROKEN
OUT BY DIFFERENT SECTORS- I
THINK THE MAIN STORY HERE IS
THAT IT'S REALLY BEEN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR THAT HAS
BEEN THE DRIVER OF ALMOST ALL.
OF THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS WE
SEEN OVER THE LAST. DECADE OR
SO YOU CAN SEE. THE KIND OF
THAT THE- LEFT SIDE OF THAT
CHART THE SECOND HIGHEST LINE
IS KIND OF THE ELECTRICITY. ON
MISSIONS- AND ABOUT A DECADE
AGO YOU SAW THOSE- MISSIONS
DECLINED RATHER RAPIDLY-
LARGELY IN RESPONSE TO A CHANGE
IN THE MIX OF. A GENERATION
RESOURCES WE USE TO POWER
ELECTRICITY GRID- ON THE OTHER
HAND A LOT OF THE OTHER SECTORS
HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY FLAT AND
YOU CAN SEE THE- TOP LINE THERE
ARE TRANSPORTATION THE MAJOR
SOURCE OF- BECAUSE- A SINGLE
SOURCE OF EMISSIONS- DECLINE
FOR A WHILE. AROUND THE TIME OF
CRASH. RISK WITHIN IS S. AN
UPTICK OR LOSS OF YEARS SOON AS
YOU KNOW. SO TURN INTO PAGE
THREE. OF THE HAND OUT- I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
JUST LAY OUT NEAR THE POLICIES
THAT WE TRIED TO LOOK AT AS
PART OF OUR REPORT AND JUST
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT POLICIES THAT THE
STATE HAS- IN DIFFERENT AREAS
TRYING TO ACHIEVE OR ARE
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS IN
TRANSPORTATION. SO WE DIVIDED
ON INTO FOUR DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES- THE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE PROGRAMS- I'M NOT GONNA
GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT
ESSENTIALLY THERE'S- A MIX OF A
LOT OF DIFFERENT- POLICIES HERE
SO WE HAVE REBATES FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AS YOU DISCUSSED- HV
STICKERS- WE HAVE REGULATIONS
HICH ALSO A MENISCUS- CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN A PUBLIC
FUNDING FOR ELECTRIC CHARGING
IN IS ALSO A BIG OF THIS ON THE
HEAVY DUTY SIDE AND WE FOCUS
MOSTLY ON THE INCENTIVES THERE
ARE SOME REGULATIONS IN HEAVY
DUTY SECTOR BUT- OUR ANALYSIS
WAS MAINLY IN THE- THE
INCENTIVE SIDE OF THINGS. EVEN
WITHIN THAT THERE IS STILL A
DIFFERENT FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE AND THEY CAN FOCUS ON
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF KIND OF
THE HEAVY DUTY CHALLENGE SO
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
PILOTS AND DEMONSTRATIONS
TRYING TO PROMOTE A NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND LEARNING THOSE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND PILOTING
THOSE. THE ARE MORE FOCUSSED
KIND OF PLANE MORE WELL
DEVELOPED TECHNOLOGIES AND KIND
OF EARLY- COMMERCIAL DEPLOYMENT
STAGE THROUGH- VOUCHERS- THEIR
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE FOCUSED
MORE ON LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS I LIKE THE CAR WHERE
PROGRAM A. B. SIX SEVENTEEN
FUNDING- AND THEN. AGAIN IN THE
HEAVY DUTY SPACE THERE'S- A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
RELATED TO- TO TRUCK CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. AND FINALLY LAST TWO
CATEGORIES LOW CARBON FUELS IS
A LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
WHICH IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED.
AND THEN SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
SO REAL QUICK- JUST WANNA KINDA
HIT THE HIGH POINTS ON FOR EACH
OF THESE CATEGORIES WHAT KIND
OF OUR MAIN TAKEAWAYS WERE
AFTER HAVING TRIED TO REVIEW
ALL THE- AVAILABLE INFORMATION-
FOR THE LIGHT DUTY PROGRAMS I
THINK. KIND AND FRANKLY THE
MAIN TAKEAWAY IS THAT THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE EFFECTS OF ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- WAS
LARGELY ON CLEAR- AND I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW IN LARGE PART
DUE TO JUST THE WIDE VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN THAT AREA
AND WE DO THINGS- YOU KNOW EVEN
THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
EMISSIONS OF PICKED UP OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE DO THINK
THAT. THESE PROGRAMS ARE HAVING
SOME- AFFECTS OF KIND OF
REDUCING EMISSIONS ASSIST
RELATIVE TO WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN BUT TRYING
TO TEASE OUT. BASICALLY WHAT IS
THE EFFECT OF OUR REGULATIONS
VERSES ARE INCENTIVES VERSUS
OUR FUNDING FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING AND
THERE HASN'T FRANKLY THAN A LOT
OF- CREE WORK IT'S AVAILABLE TO
COUNTER. TRYING TO GET ANSWER
TO THAT. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FIVE- MOHAMMED ON TO THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE PIECE OF IT- AND
THAT KIND OF MAIN TAKEAWAYS
THERE. ARE THE- WHEN YOU LOOK
AT SOME OF THE ESTIMATES THAT
HAVE PRODUCED BEEN PRODUCED BY
THEIR BOARD AROUND THE GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS FROM THOSE
PROGRAMS. THEY ARE- GENERALLY
MUCH MORE COSTLY THAN SOME OF
THE OTHER POLICIES WE HAVE SO.
ON AVERAGE WE LOOKED AT IT WAS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
TON FORTY EIGHT SHE'S. A
RANGING FROM TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TO THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
TON. AND COMPARING THAT TO
pPROGRAMS WE HAVE CAP AND TRADE
ALLOWANCE PRICES FOR CONTEXT OF
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS PER TON- WE
RECENTLY REVIEWED SOME- POLICY
THING ELECTRICITY SECTOR- THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
WHICH RUN THE RANGE OF SIXTY TO
SEVENTY DOLLARS PER TON SO THAT
CAN SEE A- A BIT OF CONTEXT FOR
THAT NUMBER- BUT I. ALSO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KIND OF KEEP
IN MIND THAT SOME OF THE GOALS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROGRAMS
GO BEYOND JUST SORT OF- NEAR
TERM COST EFFECTIVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION WHEN
KIND OF WAY IN THE TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROGRAMS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE SUPPORT IN EARLY
STAGE TECHNOLOGIES WE THINK
THERE COULD BE. A VERY KIND OF
APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR THE STATE
THERE AND KIND OF- PROMOTING
KNOWLEDGE BILL OVERTON
PROMOTING TECHNOLOGIES THAT
MAYBE THE PRIVATE SECTOR. WOULD
PROVIDE ON ITS OWN- AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE LOCAL AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS YOU CAN GET FROM A LOT
OF THESE PROGRAMS A LOT OF THIS
PROGRAM AS I MENTIONED. ARE
KIND OF TRYING TO TACKLE SOME
OF THOSE. MORE LOCAL AIR
QUALITY CHALLENGES AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES ARE. THE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO- TO THOSE
CHALLENGES AND SO. ON WHEN THE
KIND OF THINKING ABOUT KIND OF
THE OVERALL BENEFITS AND COSTS
OF THESE PROGRAMS IT'S- AN RV I
THINK KIND OF A MATTER OF. WAY
IN THOSE RELATIVELY HIGH KIND
OF NEAR TERM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION COSTS WITH SOME OF
THOSE OTHER BENEFITS THAT YOU.
CAN SEE. FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
FUEL STANDARD WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY A KIND OF PROGRAM
THAT ESSENTIALLY- PENALIZES
RELATIVELY HIGH CARBON FUEL
SUPPLIERS AND YOU KNOW-
SUBSIDIZES RELATIVELY LOW
CARBON FUEL SUPPLIERS THROUGH
THE SYSTEM INCREDIBLE CREDITS
THEIR ESTABLISHED- AND SEE A
BASED ON SOME OF THE
INFORMATION FROM CARVE IT- THE
PROGRAM THE CARBON INTENSITY OF
THE TRANSPORTATION FUEL MIX HAS
DECREASED SINCE TWENTY TEN BY
ABOUT. 4% AND I THINK IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE SEVEN OF THE HAND
OUT- ANTHOLOGIZED ON MOVING
THROUGH IT RATHER QUICKLY
BECAUSE AND- YOU WANNA LEAVE
TIME FOR QUESTIONS BUT I THINK
THE ONE OF THE MAIN TAKEAWAYS
IS THAT NEW CREDIT PRICES IN
THAT PROGRAM. RIGHT NOW AROUND
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TON SO
LESS THAN KIND OF SOME OF THE
COST ESTIMATES RELATED TO THE
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS BUT
RELATIVE TO. SOME OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE CAP AND TRADE-
QUITE A BIT HIGHER- AND AGAIN
AND I THINK WE THINK SORT OF
SOME OF THE KEY QUESTIONS TO BE
ASKED IN OUR- WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE OTHER BENEFITS THAT YOU'RE
BEGINNING FROM. THE LCS US
PROGRAM THAT YOU CAN'T GET FROM
SOME OF. SOME OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT BE A BIT
MORE COST EFFECTIVE SO FOR
EXAMPLE. IS THE L. SURFACE KIND
OF PUSHING INNOVATION IN THIS
SPACE AND A LOW CARBON FUEL
SPACE OR THE DOING SORT OF A
YOU KNOW OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW CARBON PRICING
FOR EXAMPLE LONG CAN. CAN
ACCOMPLISH. PAGE EIGHT- HAS
JUST SOME COMMENTS ON SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. SELECT THERE'S
BEEN. QUITE A ROBUST DISCUSSION
AROUND THAT- THAT- PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE SO FAR I THINK OUR
FINDINGS KIND OF REFLECT A LOT
OF THE- THE DISCUSSION THAT'S
HAPPENED SO FAR THAT THAT YOU
KNOW THOSE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. ARE TARGETS OF NOT
REALLY BEEN MET AND THERE'S-
YOU KNOW THAT'S A TOUGH ISSUE.
SO IF IT I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO.
PAGE NINE- WHERE I'M GONNA
HOPEFULLY TRY TO KIND OF WRAP
UP- YOU KNOW THE- THE WIDE
VARIETY OF COMMENTS RELATED ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
KIND OF. SYNTHESIZE BUT WE
THINK ARE KIND OF THE KEY TAKE
AWAYS- FIRST AS ANY OF THE
OVERALL MAGNITUDE OF THE
IMPACTS OF THE POLICIES IN MANY
CASES NOT IN ALL THEIR SOME
GOOD INFORMATION BUT THE
OVERALL MAGNITUDE. OF THE A IN
TAXES SOME OF THESE POLICIES IS
UNCLEAR- I THINK THAT WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT GOES
INTO. WHEN THESE POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS ARE DEVELOPED- UP
FRONT WHAT KIND OF THE
ESTIMATED IMPACTS OF THOSE WILL
BE- THERE'S RELATIVELY LITTLE
WORK. AND KIND OF STRUCTURE IN
PLACE FOR ABOUT A WOOD IN AFTER
THE FACT AFTER THE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED. WHAT WE
KNOW SEVERAL YEARS DOWN THE
LINE ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND SO. YOU KNOW
IT THAT THAT TYPE OF ANALYSIS
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE LARGE
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS IN TRYING
TO. TEASE OUT EXACTLY WHICH ONE
IS DOING HOW MUCH AND WHAT- BUT
WE DO THINK- OUR RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT THE LOS LEGISLATURE
THINK ABOUT WAYS TO KIND OF
ESTABLISH A MORE. ROBUST SYSTEM
FOR EVALUATING. THE EFFECTS OF
THE POLICIES AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SO YOU CAN HAVE
THAT INFORMATION. FOR POTENTIAL
MODIFICATIONS GOING FORWARD.
THE SECOND MAIN POINT- IS THAT.
BASED ON OUR REVIEW IN THE
INFORMATION THAT'S AVAILABLE SO
FAR- THE POLICIES AND
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
RELATIVELY. COSTLY COMPARED TO
SOME OF OUR- OTHER POLICIES-
AND SO WE DO RECOMMEND SNOW
FOCUSING TRYING TO FOCUS ON OUR
MOST COST EFFECTIVE POLICIES WE
THINK IN OUR- IN OUR RECAPPING.
TRADE AND JUST ECONOMY WIDE
CARBON PRICING IN GENERAL IS
THE MOST. COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH- AND WE THINK NO COST
EFFECTIVENESS BECOMES EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AS THE GOALS BECOME
MORE AMBITIOUS HANDS. ON SOME
OF THE WILL AND IN FOR. TARGET
TAKEN AND SO TRYING- YOU. PLACE
EVEN A GREATER EMPHASIS ON COST
EFFECTIVENESS MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE- WITH THAT SAID THERE ARE
SOME. VERY GOOD REASONS TO
IMPLEMENT SOME COMPLIMENTARY
POLICIES WHERE THEY MAKE SENSE
AND SO- I THINK OUR- OUR
SUGGESTION IS JUST KIND OF
THINK ABOUT- WHAT ARE THE OTHER
GOALS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH SOME OF THESE
OTHER POLICIES THAT. MIGHT BE
MORE COSTLY ON ON A KIND OF
NEAR TERM GREENHOUSE GAS BASIS
BUT- THEY'RE STILL A STRONG
RATIONALE FOR. THE STATE TO
INTERVENE IN AND ADOPT AN
ADDITIONAL POLICY IN THAT AREA
SO TWO. EXAMPLES THAT I
MENTIONED ARE KIND OF IN THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT SPACE
AND PUSHING TECHNOLOGIES WHERE
EVEN IF THERE IS A HIGHER
CARBON PRICE IT MIGHT NOT- YOU
KNOW IN. THE PRIVATE SECTOR
MIGHT NOT KIND OF THE DOCTORS
TECHNOLOGIES DUE TO A VARIETY
OF OTHER FACTORS- AND THEN
FOCUSING ON LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
THERE MIGHT BE. KIND OF AGAIN
YOU KNOW VERY- SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
REDUCTIONS AND LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION BEYOND SORT OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS SPACE AND SO
THERE MIGHT BE A VERY GOOD
REASON TO. TO BE PUT ON
SOMEBODY'S POLICY AND THEN THE-
COMMENT I GUESS I JUST US. BACK
A LITTLE BIT IS AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT KIND OF THE
APPROPRIATE MIX OF POLICIES
GOING FORWARD. THINK ABOUT
WHICH POLICIES ARE. NOT LIKELY
TO ENCOURAGE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS GIVEN THE GLOBAL
NATURE OF THIS PROBLEM.
CALIFORNIA BEING A MALE ABOUT
1% OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THING ABOUT WHERE
OUR POLICIES MAKING A
DIFFERENCE DIFFERENCE EVEN
OUTSIDE OF THE BORDER IF KIND
OF THE PRIMARY TARGET HERE IS
SORT OF GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
IN ADDRESSING THAT AND- THAT
COULD MEAN THINKING ABOUT IT IN
A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS ONE.
OUR POLICIES SERVING AS
AFFECTED DEMONSTRATIONS TO
OTHER JURISDICTIONS SORE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS KIND OF LOOKING
TO CALIFORNIA AND- AND LIKELY
TO KIND OF A TOP SOME OF THE
POLICIES THAT WERE TESTING OUT
HERE- AND THEN THE OTHER IS
THINKING ABOUT IT ON A- FROM A
TECHNOLOGICAL LENDS OUR OUR
POLICIES PUSHING. TECHNOLOGIES
THAT- IF THEY BECOME CHEAPER
AND MORE ACCESSIBLE ARE LIKELY
TO BE ADOPTED IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AND SO THAT. HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO KIND OF HIM
MAXIMIZE AND KIND OF INCREASE
THE OVERALL EFFECT THAT THE-
THE STATE'S POLICIES HAVE HERE
BEYOND JUST CALIFORNIA BORDERS
SO- THAT. TRIED TO COVER A LOT
OF MATERIAL- PRETTY QUICKLY
THEIR SON HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON. I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
COMMENTS- I WILL. ALSO WONDERED
DID THE FOLKS FROM CARVE WANNA
HELP PARTICIPATE IN THIS
DISCUSSION- BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW. YOUR AGENCIES. MEMBER
KID HERE- KIND OF MERRY I'VE
SAID TO LEAVE BUT IF YOU GUYS
WANNA. BE HERE FOR THE
DISCUSSION. DO YOU DO YOU WANT
TO MAKE ANY KIND OF REACT A
GOOD INITIAL REACTION BEFORE WE
OPEN UP TO THE SENATORS ARE. M.
GOOD MORNING AT SENATORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHAIRS. I
REGION- SO HEAD OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD AND-
MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT ROSS
MADE WE ACTUALLY VERY MUCH
AGREE WITH. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE OTHER FACTORS
FOR THESE PROGRAMS MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CALLED FOR IN
THE REPORT FOR LA YOU. ARE
ACTUALLY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SCOPING PLAN FOR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO ACHIEVE OUR TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. WHEN WE DEVELOP
THAT SCOPING PLAN WE WENT BACK
AND LOOKED AT MANY OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO SEE IF WE
COULD LEVERAGE THOSE EXISTING
AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS FOR THEIR
CO BENEFITS FOR GREENHOUSE
GASES. WHAT WE REALIZED WAS WAS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE FDERAL
MANDATES FOR STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PROGRAMS ARE
REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH WE HAD
IN A- TOOL KIT OF
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS ORDER
IN PLACE THAT WE COULD LEVERAGE
FOR THE SCOPING PLAN. SO THE
pPROGRAMS. IS ACTUALLY AIR
QUALITY WE'RE LEVERAGING THE CO
BENEFITS AND SO WHEN WE GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THOSE WITH GIGI
LANDS WE'RE NOT SEEING THE
COMPLETE PICTURE. AND MISTER
BROWN FROM LA- ACTUALLY SPOKE
TO THAT THAT YOU'RE NOT SEEING
THE BROADER PICTURE. AND SO IF
WE WENT BACK TO THE SCOPING
PLAN AND WE PULLED OUT SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE WE SAID WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE A SCOPING
PLANET JUST THINK ABOUT- DO WE
NEED THESE PROGRAMS AT ALL. WE
WOULD SAY YES BECAUSE THEY ARE
NECESSARY FOR AIR QUALITY
TARGETS AND GOALS. PROGRAMS
LIKE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD.
ARE ACTUALLY DISPLACING ABOUT
TWO POINT THREE BILLION GALLONS
OF DIESEL. FUEL EVERY YEAR IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THEY
REFUSE KNOCKS BY ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED TONS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SO. TO READ ABOUT AIR
QUALITY FIRST. AND THEY TO LIVE
CO BENNETT U. G. SO. OKAY WELL.
ALRIGHT I KNOW WHO TO A CATCH
YOU CAN HAVE SOM QUESTIONS
HERE THIS. WE ALWAYS STRUGGLE
WITH SCORING- THE COST AND OF
COURSE A GREENHOUSE GASES AND
WE HAVE OUTSIDE THE
TRANSPORTATION FIELD WE HAVE
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS WE HAVE-
VARIETY DIFFERENT A DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS- ARE WE- IT. SHOULD WE
BE LOOKING AT THOSE OTHER
PROGRAMS AS WELL FOR THE
TECHNOLOGICAL BREAKTHROUGHS OR
THE BEST PRACTICED CHANGE AT
CHANGES I'M THINKING METHANE
REDUCTION IN A WE HAVE THE
ANAEROBIC DIGESTERS WE HAVE
MANY WERE MANAGEMENT. MUCH
LOWER PRICE FOR CARBON
REDUCTION- IN FIVE AND IF
EFFECTS THE WORLD IT AFFECTS
THE WAITED THAT. MANURE
MANAGERS ALL OVER THE WORLD
WILL WORK ON IT I'M IN FOR A
FRACTION OF THE COST OF THAT
WE'RE PAYING FOR THERE ARE
VEHICLE PROGRAM HOW DO I
BALANCE THAT YOU KNOW BESIDES
BALANCING THESE OTHERS
EXTERNALITIES HOW DO I LOOK AT
I GET LIMITED FUNDS WORK THE
MONEY IS. SHRINKING. YEAH I
MEAN IT'S A TOUGH BALANCE AND
AN EIGHT TO BE QUITE FRANK I'M
NOT SURE THAT I CAN KIND OF
GIVE YOU AN EXACT ANSWER OF
KIND OF EXACTLY HOW TO WEIGH
THOSE THINGS BUT I THINK YOU'VE
KIND OF HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD ON. HOW WE THINK YOU
SHOULD BE KIND OF THINKING
ABOUT TRYING TO PRIORITIZE
THESE DIFFERENT FUNDS I MEAN IN
ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT IS
LOOK AT. YOU KNOW PURELY ON
KIND OF YOU KNOW NEAR OR MID
TERM- ANNOUCEMENT OPTIONS
WITHIN THE STATE WHAT'S THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ACHIEVE THOSE REDUCTIONS AND-
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS MIGHT
SCORE OUT PRETTY WELL BASED ON
THAT METRIC AND IF THAT'S- THE
PRIMARY GOAL- THEN YOU'RE
FOCUSING RESOURCES AND
PRIORITIZING RESOURCES IN THAT
AREA. I THINK YOU MENTIONED
SOME OF THE BAG AND MATH PIECE
DOES THOSE ARE PIECES THAT KIND
OF CONCERT FALL OUTSIDE OF. THE
KIND OF SCOPE OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AS WELL AND SO WE
THINK THAT'S KIND OF ANOTHER
REASON TO KIND OF THINK ABOUT
FOCUSING ON- RESOURCES AND
FUNDING IN THAT. KIND OF ON IT
IS THAT MAYBE I TARGETED BY. OR
COVERED BY THE CAPTAIN TRADE
PRO. BUT IT IS THIS BALANCE OF
CAN ABOUT WELL. THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY OTHER BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR SON.
TECHNOLOGIES AND PUSHING THOSE
NEWER TECH JEEZ SLEEP YOU DO
THE YOU MIGHT HAVE PLUS THIS IS
FOR SOME OF THOSE. THE THINGS
THAT JUST TALKING ABOUT AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S A- YOU
KNOW AN EASY ANSWER ON KIND OF
YOU KNOW HOW YOU WANT TO
PRIORITIZE. AMONG THOSE THINGS
BUT- TYPE OF THINKING OKAY PLAN
THOSE THOSE THOSE. BENEFITS
WITHIN IS THE WAY TO. A TWO
APPROACH IT. YEAH ME. THE POOR.
I MEAN. THE BUDGET HAS SAID.
THAT CHURN. HAS A DRESS. READ
IN THE C. V. R. P. PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE A DRASTIC. REDUCTION
IN. THE BUT- PASSED MY MIND-
IN. A CAR MORE YOUR PROGRAM-
INCENTIVES THAT WE HAD YOU KNOW
THE SENATE HAS HAD LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET WANTED TO INCENTIVIZE
HE'S VERY POPULAR PROGRAMS IT
SEEM TO YOU KNOW MOVE PEOPLE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. WHAT'S
YOUR ANSWER TO A NO OF A PUSH
BACK FOR- THE BUDGET THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AND WITH
THESE WITH THESE POPULAR
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OVER
SUBSCRIBE DID SEEM TO GET US TO
YOU KNOW OUR E. V. E. N. A. N.
HELPS US WITH THE EMISSION.
REDUCTIONS THE AIRPORT. DAVID
GARCIA LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- IS ABOUT
WELL IN ANY BUDGET IS ABOUT
BALANCING PRIORITIES AND THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THERE IS
JUST LESS MONEY AND GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUNDS THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUES IN IF
YOU WANT WE CAN ANSWER THE
SPECIFICS OF WHY THAT HAPPENED-
BUT- FINANCE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OR THE PEOPLE WHO
BALANCE THOSE PRIORITIES WE
WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO THEM IN
TERMS OF THE DECISIONS THEY
MADE. I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE A
YEARLY- EXERCISE THAT WE HAVE
THE BUDGET COMES OUT THE LA
APPLE N. CENTER WHAT CASKEY HAS
PROJECTIONS ON WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
FUNDS THE GOVERNOR FINANCE
LOBEL SAID AT THE END OF THE
DAY WHEN WE FINALLY HAVE OUR
LAST OPTION IN MAY THE- FISCAL
YEAR. WE'RE IN THREE POINT TWO
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION ABOUT
A BILLION MORE IN AUCTION
SALES- EACH YEAR IT IT IN THIS
IS YOU KNOW THIS IS MY SIX YEAR
IN THIS THE SENATE AND IT THIS
WE GO RUN AROUND AND WE STILL
HAVE A SLUGGISH- RANGE YEAH. WE
HAVE IN SIX YEARS WE'VE STOP
QUEEN. SINCE EIGHTEEN DOLLARS
MILE I'M IN THE STATE SENATE IN
N. Y. WHY IS THE REPORT COMING
UP WITH SUGGESTIONS OR TO
INCREASE THOSE OPTIONS AND
INCREASE THE PRICE OF CARBON
THAT THE DEBT THE STATIONARY
SOURCES THE COVERED ENTITIES
FUNDED. THE PROGRAM WE WERE
WERE STUCK AT SEVENTEEN IT
SEEMS TO BE TO ALL THESE
EXTERNALITIES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOUR YOUR NEW
SCOPING PLAN. FOR PUBLIC. WHAT
DIRECTION WE GETTING FOR YOU.
TRYING TO CAR MORE
APPROPRIATELY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION  KNOW THAT IT'S
BEEN OF SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN
MANY OF THE HEARINGS LATELY AM
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM HAS ALLOWANCES THAT ARE
ISSUED EACH YEAR AND EACH YEAR
THE AMOUNT OF THOSE ALLOWANCES
DECREASES BECAUSE YOU WANT
EMISSIONS TO DECREASE OVER ON
THE STATE. ACCORDINGLY LESS
ALLOWANCES PERMITS TO POLLUTE
THAT ARE PROVIDED. SO YOU HAVE
THAT DECLINING POOL OF
ANNOUNCES THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
SALE YOU HAVE SOME THAT ARE
GOING TO INDUSTRY AND
420-212-2030 WE ARE ACTUALLY
INCREASING A LITTLE BIT THE
AMOUNT OF ANNOUNCES THAT ARE
GOING TO INDUSTRY BASED ON
DIRECTION THAT WE RECEIVED N
AB THREE NINETY EIGHT. BUT IN
THE DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN ESCALATING
FLOOR PRICE FOR THE AUCTIONS
AND ESCALATES EACH YEAR BY 5%
PLUS INFLATION SO IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE FLOOR PRICE
WAS TEN DOLLARS. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY OR TWENTY
TWENTY IT'S NOW ABOUT SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE BUT THE ALLOWANCES
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THE DEMAND
IS THERE DEAR SOMETHING OUT AND
ABOVE THE FLOOR PRICE SO AT THE
LAST AUCTION- ALLOWANCES SOLD
AT EIGHTEEN DOLLARS A TON ABOUT
THE FLOOR PRICE. AND SO WE ARE
SEEING THAT INCREASING CARBON
PRICE SIGNAL AND FOR THE
ECONOMY AND IT'S BASED ON THE
DEMAND FOR THE BALANCES THAT
DID IS BASED ON. IN MAKING TO
ON SITE. AND HOW OTHERS ARE
PERFORMING TERMS LIKE
ELECTRICITY TRANSPORTATION
ETCETERA. SUE THERE IS AN
ANTICIPATION THE MARKET THAT
THE MARKET'S GOING TO GET TIGHT
AND IT'S GOING TO GET TIRED
VERY QUICKLY STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. YOU'RE SAYING THAT
BECAUSE BEFORE PRICES ARE
ALREADY FOR THE FOR THE
ALLOWANCES ARE SELLING ABOUT
BEFORE PRICE TODAY. TOO EARLY
NOW. I. ARE WE ARE WE
COMFORTABLE ARE WE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE 5% INCREASE IN THE IN
THE FLOOR PRICE GIVEN WHAT THE
EUROPEANS ARE DOING AS HAVE
THEY'RE HAVING THEIR OPTIONS AT
THIRTY DOLLARS- PER METRIC TON
IN WHAT THE WORLD BANK HAS
SUGGESTED THAT THAT THE PRICE
OF CARBON ARE ALLOWING SHE
SHOULD BE FORTY TO EIGHTY I
MEAN WE'VE GONE FROM SEVENTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN IN THIS THIS TODAY
TODAY'S AUCTION OR LAST WEEK'S
AUCTION- IS THAT IS IN THERE
MORE INCENTIVE THAT THE AIRPORT
COULD DO OUR OR SIGNALS TO THE
MARKET ABOUT WHERE WE WANT TO
SEE PRICES IN. IN FOUR YEARS
BECAUSE IF WE GO 5% PER YEAR
PER YEAR THAT'S WAS AT.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETY CENSUS
THREE DOLLARS FOUR DOLLARS SOME
FOR TALKING ABOUT 4% DECREASE
PER YEAR TOTAL EMISSIONS YOU
KNOW WE'VE GONE 1% TO TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WE HAVE TO GO 24%
AND WE'RE TALKING FOUR DOLLARS.
SEND SEND OF ENOUGH FOR YOUR
MODELING. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT CAP
AND TRADE IS NOT THE ONLY TOOL
THAT WE HAVE TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS ANDIT'S ONE OF MANY
TOOLS AND A SUITE OF POLICIES
AND THE SCOPING PLAN WHAT YOU
SEE IN THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS A PRICE THAT'S ON
TOP OF THE COST REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND ALL THOSE OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE OUR PS ADVANCE
CLEAN CARS- SB THREE FIFTY FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. AND FOR THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD SO
WHEN WE SEE VALUE SUCH AS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A TON WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS PRICES IF
THERE WAS ONLY A CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND THERE WERE NO OTHER
POLICIES AVAILABLE TO HELP
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND SO-
COMPARING THOSE PRICES AGAINST
EACH OTHER ISN'T COMPARING
APPLES TO APPLES NECESSARILY.
IN TERMS OF THE PRICES FOR THE
PROGRAM AND THE NEXT DECADE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT WE'VE
REDUCED EMISSIONS BELOW THE
TWENTY TWENTY TARGET FOR YEARS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE THE CAPS ARE
SET ACCORDINGLY IN THE PROGRAM
WITH THE OTHER POLICIES LIKE LC
FAST ADVANCE IN CARS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD THE TWENTY TWENTY
TARGET. WERE HAD A SCHEDULE BUT
WHAT ALSO HAPPENED IN THE LAST
COPING PLAN IS WE SIGNALED THAT
STARTING FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY THIRTY WE HAVE TO
HAVE A MORE STRINGENT PROGRAMS.
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
STRINGENT WE MADE ALL CFS MORE
STRING. WHICH IT MADE OUR
STRINGENT AND SO THOSE PER AND
THAT STRAY STARTS TO KICK IN IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY EARLY
TWENTY TO START EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I DON'T. ALL SIX
LOOKS LIKE SO THE NEXT DECADE
IN TERMS OF RESPONSE FROM
BUSINESS RESPONSE FROM
CONSUMERS RESPONSE IN ENERGY
SOURCES- IS GONNA LOOK QUITE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE TODAY BECAUSE EVERYONE'S
GOING TO BE RESPONDING TO MUCH
MORE STRINGENT PROGRAMS THE LA-
RICHEST REPORTED THAT ALL THE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS FOR TWENTY
TWO UNDER AB THIRTY TWO TO
TWENTY TWENTY CAN BE-
ACCUMULATED ELECTRIC TRICITY
SECTION IS THE R. P. S.
STANDARDS ALL THE REST OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOW COULD BE
MORE STRINGENT DID NOTHING.
ESSENTIALLY FOR AS FAR AS HE
MISSION REDUCTION RELATIVELY
NOTHING I MEAN THEY THEY MOVE
FROM ONE SIDE OF THE GRAPH THE
OTHER SERIGRAPH BUT FLAT LINED
SINCE SINCE WE STARTED THE
AUCTION PROGRAM SEVEN YEARS AGO
SO. I'VE BEEN CRITICAL OF I
THINK IT'S NOT ENOUGH OF THE
GUIDANCE THAT YOU GIVEN TO THAT
THE MARKET PLACE AND YES WE'RE
ALL GOING TO HOLD OUR BREATH
TILL TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
MOVEMENT AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN. INCREASES IN SOME OF
THESE AND AREAS SO I A CAN YOU.
OTHER THAN YOU HAVE A PLAN AND
YOU HAVE A OR YOU'RE YOU'RE
HOPING FOR IT THERE ARE OTHER
MECHANISMS SO YOU CAN YOU YOU
CAN PRICE. THE CARBON I MEAN
YOU YOU. THERE'S THERE IS A
SIGNAL THAT YOU CAN GIVE TO THE
MARKET- WITH THE WITH THE PRICE
THAT- THAT YOU'RE NOT DOING
THERE SEEMS TO BE A HESITATION
BY. THIS ADMINISTRATION TO TELL
CALIFORNIANS OR TELL THE WORLD
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
PRICING CARBON AND WE'RE WE'RE
SORT OF RELYING ON THESE
PROGRAMS. THAT HAVE A
LACKLUSTER. FIVE PERFORMANCE
SAVE THE U. BIO USED SAID OF
HAVE HELPED BUILD THIS OUT ON
OUR EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. I AM
SO I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE LIKE
A LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
VANCE CLEAN CARS THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE DELIVERED REDUCTIONS IF IT
WEREN'T FOR THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
MISSIONS WOULD BE A LOT HIGHER
TODAY AND SO EVEN THOUGH WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE GRAPH IT LOOKS
LIKE. THE REDUCTIONS HAVING
OCCURRED WE'VE ACTUALLY
CONSTRAINED REDUCTIONS AND IN
THE ABSENCE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
REDUCTION OR EMISSIONS WOULD BE
MUCH HIGHER- WITH LC FEST WE'VE
DONE ESTIMATES BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE ESTIMATES THAT THEY
WOULD BE FIVE MILLION TONS
HIGHER EVERY YEAR FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS IF THAT PROGRAM
HADN'T BEEN IN PLACE. AND SO WE
TOOK TO HEART THE COMMENTS THAT
THE EARLIER REPORT MADE ABOUT
THE RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSES AND
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THAT AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO T.
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION OUT TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE. AND IN TERMS
OF THE SIGNALS AND THE PRICES
AND WHY WE SEEM A LITTLE
RELUCTANT TO ENGAGE IN SOME OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS MARKET
ADMINISTRATORS WHAT WE SAY AND
HOW WE DISCUSSED THE MARKET
FUNDAMENTALS AND MARKET DESIGN.
CAN SEND UNINTENDED SIGNAL TO
THE MARKET AND ADD UNCERTAINTY
AND SO WE TRY TO AVOID THAT IN
PUBLIC DISCUSSIONS WE TRY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO THOUGHT
FLUENTLY REALLY HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SO THAT EVERYBODY
IS ABLE TO GET THE INFORMATION
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE CONTEXT AROUND IT. I
THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CAPS
FOR CAP AND TRADE YOU SEE THAT
THEY ARE DROPPING FOURTEEN
MILLION TONS YEAR OVER YEAR
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT'S A HUGE SIGNAL TO THE
MARKET PLACE. AND THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN PRICED IN AND
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SEEING PRICES
IN THE OPTIONS STEP LEAVE ABOUT
FOUR PRICE TODAY. LISTEN
INTERESTING BUT WE'RE I DO ONE
MORE QUESTION ON THE ALLOWANCES
PRODUCER HAS BEEN INTERNATIONAL
CRITICISM OF TOO MANY FREE
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S BEEN A
PRODUCT OF AS THE- AS THE
OPERATOR OF THE MARKET THAT
THEIR URGES THERE ARE WAY TOO
MANY AND THE SIGNAL THAT YOU'RE
GIVING IS THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE MORE FREE ALLOWANCES. THAT
ARE GONNA BE AVAILABLE THERE'S
A GLUT OF ALLOWANCES RIGHT NOW
THAT IS NOT CHANGING BEHAVIOR
FROM THE STATION SOURCES IN THE
COVER. COVERED ENTITIES WHAT'S
THE- I FEEL LIKE I'M IN A
DEBATE CLASS SERVICE. I HAD A
ROUGH DAY YESTERDAY I'M SORRY
OKAY. OKAY SO THE AMOUNT OF
ALLOWANCES THAT WE GIVE IT TO
INDUSTRY IS TO FOLLOW THE
DIRECTION AB THIRTY TO ABOUT
MINIMIZING LEAKAGE YOU DON'T
WANT INDUSTRY TO MOVE
PRODUCTION IF YOU DON'T WANT
INDUSTRY TO PICK UP A MOVE
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO IT LOOKS LIKE ON OUR BOOKS
WE ACHIEVED A REDUCTION BUT THE
AT THE EMISSIONS ARE ACTUALLY
KERN SOMEWHERE ELSE THEY'RE
STILL HAPPENING SO WE GIVE
ALLOWANCES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN HELP KEEP THE INDUSTRY
COMPETITIVE BUT STILL SEND SOME
SIGNAL TO THEM THAT THEY NEED
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND SO WE
DON'T GIVE ANYBODY A 100% OF
THE ALLOWANCES THEY NEED TO
COMPLY. WHAT HAPPENS IS IN AB
THREE EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT
WE GOT DIRECTION. TO CONSIDER
ALL INDUSTRY. AS HIGH RISK FOR
LEAKAGE. AND SO WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN A REGULATION NOW AND
THE- REGULATION THAT WE ADOPTED
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT IS. THE WE
HAVE A SUSTAINED AMOUNT OF FREE
ALLOCATION TO INDUSTRY- BASED
ON DIRECTION IN LEGISLATION.
BUT STILL EVEN UNDER THAT
SCENARIO WE'RE STILL NOT GIVING
ANYBODY A 100% OF WHAT THEY
NEED. SO PEOPLE ARE STILL
FACING- A NEED TO EITHER REDUCE
EMISSIONS ON SITE OR GOING TO
THE MARKET PLACE AND BY
ALLOWANCES. OKAY MR HOTEL HAS
OF COURSE I WOULD SAY YOU WON
THAT DEBATE. I FOR ONE HAVE
FEEL VERY- REFRESH THAT WE HAVE
A REGULATOR THAT'S LOOKING AT
ALL THESE ISSUES THAT YOU'LL
WITH LEAKAGE. AND YOU KNOW
PUTTING A LOT OF THOUGHT INTO
IT I YOU KNOW I I'M REALLY
LOOKING TO LEARN A LOT MORE IN
THIS AREA IN I GUESS TOUGH THE
ONE QUESTION I WOULD HAVE IS
HAVE YOU DONE ANY STUDIES ON.
LIKE THE PRICE ELASTICITY ON-
YOU KNOW THIS AUCTION AND IF
IT. WE WERE TO GO TO A POINT
WHERE WE- ARBITRARILY INCREASE
THE PRICE WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
OF. YOU HEALTH. ACTUALLY
GETTING LAST OR NOT GETTING
ENOUGH- THE- MARGINALLY TO MAKE
IT EFFECTIVE IN THE LAST COPING
PLAN THAT THE BOARD ADOPTED IN
LATE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
RAN A SCENARIO WHERE WE HAD A
CARBON PRICE OF FIFTY DOLLARS A
TON. AND WHAT WE DISCOVERED IN
THAT IS THAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE INDUSTRY AND EMISSIONS
LEAKAGE OCCURRING THE STATE
BECAUSE OUR INDUSTRY WOULD NOT
BE COMPETITIVE AT THAT PRICE
AND THEY'RE ONLY. RESPONSE
WOULD BE TO EITHER REDUCE
PRODUCTION IN STATE OR HAVE
THAT ACTIVITY MOVE OUT OF STATE
AND SO WE HAVE THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSES WE HAVE ALL OF THE
TECHNICAL WORK TO SUPPORT THAT
SCENARIO AND THAT EVALUATION ON
OUR WEBSITE WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
SHARE THAT YEAH I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT. I SHOULD PREFACE THAT
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THE. SO I AND I AND- JUST TO
GET YOUR REACTION TO. THE ISSUE
OF CREDIBILITY OKAY THE
CREDIBILITY- FACTOR IS VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE DISCUSS THIS.
AND TO HAVE CREDIBILITY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION. AREA WHEN YOU
ANALYZE THE IMPACT OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS PROGRAMS ARE OPTIONS.
IT REQUIRES THE PROPER ANALYSIS
AND A PROPER FEAR ANALYSIS I
DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE OKAY
WE'RE NOT THERE SO. THE
QUESTION IS. HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
CREATING A STRUCTURE. DEAD
IMPROVES THE PROPER ANALYSIS IN
THE TRANSPORTATION AREA SO
THAT'S THE QUESTION BOB VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED I DON'T LIKE
THAT OKAY I'M A I'M A PLANNER I
WAS ON THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS OKAY SIR DODD.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IS ONE
WAY TO LOOK AT IT YOU ALSO
SHOULD LOOK AT. THINGS LIKE
CONGESTION ARE YOU ARE YOU.
LIKE MY WIFE SAYS I DON'T
REALLY CARE HOW MANY MILES HAVE
TO TRAVEL I CARE HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET TO WHERE I'M
GOING. AND I THINK THE AVERAGE
PERSON LOOKS AT IT THAT WAY
QUITE FRANKLY. THEY WANT TO
KNOW WHAT. THE TIME IT TAKES
NOW IT SEEMS LIKE THE TIME IT
TAKES. WOULD MEAN THAT THE CAR
WOULD BE RUNNING A LONGER. AND
THEREFORE POLLUTING MORE. OKAY
SO CARD OTHER OTHER IDEAS WOULD
BE HOW MUCH GASOLINE IS BEING
USED. GOT OVERALL GASOLINE
USAGE I THINK IS IMPORTANT TO
LOOK AT SOME KIND OF
MEASUREMENT DID MEASURES THAT.
I ALSO THINK I ALSO THINK. THEN
WHEN WE PROPOSED. POLICIES ON
TRANSPORTATION AREA. WE SHOULD
FIND EMILY LOOK AT IT WHAT DOES
IT DO IN TERMS OF TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP. ARE WE PROMOTING
PEOPLE LEAVING THEIR CARS
EITHER WALKING BY SCHOOLING OR
USING TRANSIT. IS THERE ARE-
APPALLED IS DOES THE POLICY-
HELD. CONVERT PEOPLE FROM USING
CARS WHICH POLLUTES. I WE I
WOULD EVEN ARGUE THAT ELECTRIC
CARS POLLUTE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
STILL HAVE THE NUMBER OF CARS
IN THE POPULATION GROWS AND
EVERYBODY BUYS CARS AND THE
FREEWAYS STATE CONGESTED.
THERE'S OTHER CARS ARE OUT
THERE THAT ARE POLLUTING MORE%
BECAUSE- THE VEHICLE HOURS
TRAVEL IS CONTAINED TO GET
LONGER THE MEDIC GASOLINE
PURCHASE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
HAVING MORE ELECTRIC CARS THEM
OUT OF GASOLINE. THAT'S
PURCHASED IS CONTINUE TO RISE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO STAY IN
THEIR CARS LONGER AND FROM THE
TAXPAYERS STANDPOINT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
AND FROM WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
IN LESS TIME OKAY THAT'S-
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOAL THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE. SO I
HAD A QUESTION REGARDING THAT
IS- IS THERE ANYBODY LOOKING
AT. CHANGING THE FRAMEWORK TO
EMPHASIZE TRANSIT. TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IS TRANSIT RIGHT IS
THE IMPACT OF YOUR POLICIES ON
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP LOOKED OUT.
OF I'M I'M A MAJOR ADVOCATE
I'VE BEEN PROBABLY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ADVOCATES IN. THE STATE
FOR TRANSIT RIDERS TRANSIT
PROGRAMS SO HOW DO YOU ANALYZE
TRANSIT. IN TERMS OF HOW WOULD
YOU ANALYZE IT ROSS AND MAYBE
CAN. AND CREATE A PROPER
SYSTEMATIC WAY OF LOOKING AT
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE I MEAN.
CENTER ABOUT MINUTES- I THINK
IT DIFFICULT QUESTION AND TO BE
QUITE FRANK I DON'T KNOW THAT I
HAVE AN EXACT ANSWER- BUT I
THINK CERTAINLY KIND OF ANSWER
ANYWHERE THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
YEAH SO I MEAN I THINK
CERTAINLY THINKING ABOUT
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE KIND OF WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
THE GOAL THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IS KIND OF AN IMPORTANT
MORE TRANSIT RIGHT PART OF IT
SO YEAH IS IT. MORE PEOPLE
USING TRANSIT RIGHT AND SO AS
FAR AS SORT OF SETTING UP A
STRUCTURE FOR GETTING GOOD
ANSWERS TO THAT AND I THINK ONE
IMPORTANT THING IN OUR MIND IS
THINKING ABOUT AS PROGRAMS ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED. IN THE EARLY
STAGES THINKING ABOUT HOW ARE
WE GOING TO GET ANSWERS TO SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
ANSWERS TO HOW IT HAS AFFECTED
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP BECAUSE THESE
ARE ARE OFTENTIMES VERY
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS TO ANSWER
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT ARE
INFLUENCING TRANSIT RIDERSHIP.
IN ADDITION TO A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED
WHEN YOU ANALYZE THE GREENHOUSE
GAS. EMISSIONS REDUCTION
POLICIES DO THEY SPECIFICALLY
LOOK AT HOW THAT IMPACTS
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP THAT'S-
THAT'S THAT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE
IN MY OPINION. BECAUSE OF AN
IMPASSE IT IN A NEGATIVE WAY.
YOU SHOULD SAY THAT ALL THE
POLICIES WE DO DO NOT. DECREASE
OR IMPACT IN A NEGATIVE WAY
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. THAT SIR MY
VIEW IF I SEE MORE. POLICIES
THAT- SOUND LIKE THEY'RE GOOD
BUT THEN THE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
IS IMPACTED IN A BAD WAY I
DON'T I DON'T PARTICULARLY
THINK THAT'S ACHIEVING OUR
THAT'S GOES IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION WHICH YEAH SO OUR
ANALYSIS LOOKED AT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS WOULD NOT FOCUS
ON- TRANSIT RIDERSHIP THERE ARE
WITH THIS SESSIONS ABOUT FROM
MY EYES SURE THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. I'M INTERESTED
IN A TRANSIT RIDERSHIP PART OF
YEAH I THINK THERE ARE FOR
CERTAIN SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT
MIGHT BE KIND OF A PIECE OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT THEY DO ON KIND
OF TRYING TO ESTIMATES-
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH IT BUT
I'D HAVE TO LOOK AT- THE
DETAILS OF THAT AND GET BACK TO
YOU OKAY THANK YOU I WILL SAY I
THINK THE NEXT PANEL- WE GOT A
COUPLE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSIT
EXPERTS- YEAH RIGHT WHO CAN.
BANG FLASH ON THE SIDE. TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP. STUFF OUT THE YOU'RE
TALKING BUT I'M PASSED ABOUT AS
WELL SO. LOSE WITH YOUR
FORBEARANCE NUMBER AMOUNT OF
GASOLINE ISN'T THAT A YEAH THE-
PEOPLE CAN. DO THEY LOOK AT
LIKE WHEN THEY LOOK AT GREEN
EYES SEEMS LIKE HOW MUCH
GASOLINE IS PURCHASED. I MEAN
THAT'S- THE GASOLINE'S BERM SO
IT'S POLLUTING SO WHEN WE SEE
THE GASOLINE. PURCHASES FROM
NIGHT DECREES THAT'S THIS KIND
OF A BAD BILL WHETHER FOR US IN
TERMS OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS RIGHT SO THE KIND OF
DEALING WITH THAT ISSUE. I'LL
JUST ADD IT IS JENNIFER DRESS
ITH A CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD JUST TO- ON YOUR TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP QUESTION WHEN UNDER
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHEN WE
EVALUATE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES OFTENTIMES NPOS DO.
PUT TRANSIT RELATED MEASURES IN
THEIR PLANS AND SO WILL WE WILL
LOOK AT TRANSIT RIDERSHIP AS
PART OF THEIR PLAN IF IT'S A IF
IT'S A KEY STRATEGY IN IT. ALSO
THERE ARE NUMBER OF TRANSIT
FUNDING PROGRAMS FUNDED BY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND
THAT TRANSIT CAPITAL PROGRAM
AND- AN AD THE SAID. AND BOTH
OF THEM LOOK AT TRANSIT RIGHT
SHIP WHEN DETERMINING WHETHER
TO FUND THEM OR NOT. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WOULD LIKE FOR
THE FOLLOW UP ON ON THIS
QUESTION. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO OUR PANELISTS
AND LET'S NOW GO ON TO THE NEXT
PANEL WHICH I THINK ACTUALLY
WILL WILL IT'S A GOOD SEGUE
BECAUSE A NUMBER OF THEM ARE
EXPERTS IN THIS AREA- LET'S
START WE'RE SERVICES IN THE
EIGHTIES THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION- I KNOW. SHE'S
GOT BACK A DAVIS AT SOME POINT
SOON SO WE WANT TO HEAR FROM%
HER FIRST- DAVID ROLE IN
HOLSTERS PROFESSOR UC BERKELEY
BURN AGRICULTURE AND RESOURCE
ECONOMICS. IN AUSTIN BROWN HIS
DIRECTOR YOU SEE DAVIS POLICY
INSTITUTE FOR ENERGY
ENVIRONMENT ECONOMY IN CAPE
GREEN. WITH EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
TO COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
COVERING TRANSIT ASSOCIATION SO
LET'S HEAR FROM YOU FIRST.
DIRECTOR HANDY. IS THE I
BELIEVE US ANSWER. YET RIGHT.
LET'S HEAR FROM YOU SEASON AND
THEN WE'LL GO DOWN THE REST THE
PANEL AND GET TO FLUSH OUT MORE
THESE TOPICS THAT WE'VE BEEN.
DISCUSSING ALL MORNING. IT'S A
GREAT PANEL SOME REAL EXPERTISE
HERE SO I WILL SERVE YOU
DRESSER HANDY. GOOD MORNING
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ALL.
I'M SUSAN HANDY I'M A PROFESSOR
AT UC DAVIS WHERE I DIRECT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION- OF MY OWN WORK-
FOCUSES ON. THE VMT QUESTIONS
SO MY COMMENTS WILL BE AND
FOCUSED ON THAT. SO AS WE HEARD
THIS MORNING THE STATE HAS MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS ON
REDUCING EMISSIONS THROUGH. OF
FUEL EFFICIENCY STANDARDS
EMISSIONS STANDARDS INCENTIVES
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES- BUT
ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT THE STATE
WILL NOT MEET ITS GHG EMISSIONS
GOALS WITHOUT ALSO REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES OF TRAVEL- BY AS
MUCH AS FIFTEEN PERCENT- THIS
IS A TALL ORDER GIVEN HOW MUCH
DRIVING CALIFORNANS DO. A IS
APPROACHING TEN THOUSAND MILES
PER YEAR PER PERSON IN THE
STATE FOR A WHILE IT LOOKED
LIKE THINGS WERE LEVELING OUT-
BUT LATEST DATA SUGGESTS THAT
IT'S TRENDING BACK UPWARDS. IF
THANK YOU SO BE AND HE IS ALL
OF IT OFTEN BEEN CALLED THE
SHAKY THIRD LEG OF THE STOOL
MUCH HARDER TO ADDRESS THAN
VEHICLES AND FUELS BUT
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO MEETING
OUR GOALS THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
IF WE CAN DO IT WE GET MANY
BENEFITS BEYOND- JUST EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS- OTHER KINDS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS ECONOMIC
BENEFITS SOCIAL EQUITY BENEFITS
AS WELL AS PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS BUT OF COURSE THE BIG
QUESTION IS HOW TO DO IT. AND
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THIS
QUESTION I APPROACH IT WITH A-
A TWO STEP FRAMEWORK- IF YOU
WILL AND ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
POINT I WANT TO MAKE. THIS
MORNING IS THAT BOTH OF THESE
STEPS ARE VERY MUCH NECESSARY.
SO THE FIRST STEP IS TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE TO DRIVE LESS AND
THAT'S GONNA TAKE EFFORTS AT
THE LOCAL SCALE AS WELL AS THE
REGIONAL SCALE. SO THE LOCAL
SCALE WE NEED LAND USE PATTERNS
THAT BRING DESTINATIONS- WITHIN
CLOSER REACH THAT WOULD MAKE
DRIVING DISTANCES SHORTER AS
WELL AS WALKING AND BIKING MORE
VIABLE- WE NEED INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE SAFETY AND THE
QUALITY. OF THE WALKING AND
BIKING EXPERIENCE THAT WILL
ALSO HELP TRANSIT- WE'VE GOT
BIKE SHARINGAND SCOOTER
SHARING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADDING TO OUR LOCAL OPTIONS BUT
WE NEED BETTER WAYS TO
INTEGRATE THOSE. INTO OUR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. AT THE
REGIONAL SCALE WE NEED
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT SERVICE
BOTH RAIL AND BUS TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY AND THE COVERAGE OF
THAT SERVICE. WE NEED LAND USE
PATTERNS THAT ENHANCE THE
VIABILITY OF TRANSIT WHICH
MEANS HIGHER DENSITIES AROUND
TRANSIT STATIONS IT MEANS
LOCATING KEY REDDICK REGIONAL
DESTINATIONS LIKE STADIUMS-
NEAR RAIL STATIONS- AND OF
COURSE WE NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN SHOP RICH AREAS. SO
IF WE CAN DO THESE THINGS WE
CREATE COMMUNITIES WHERE IT IS
POSSIBLE TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO
DO WITHOUT DRIVING SO MUCH- IF
WE DO THIS WE GET IMPORTANT
EQUITY BENEFITS. IN TERMS OF
ENSURING ADEQUATE ACCESSIBILITY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNABLE TO
DRIVE FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER- AND WE KNOW THAT WE
CAN'T DO THIS THAT WE'VE GOT
EXAMPLES OF ALL OF THESE
STRATEGIES. IN CALIFORNIA WE
HEARD ABOUT SOME OF THEM FROM
SECRETARY KIM THIS MORNING-
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
MY TIME A IN THE FIELD THAT WE
CLEARLY HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO
THE SECOND STEP. IS THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO DRIVE LESS- SIMPLY GIVING
THEM THE OPTION THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DRIVE LESS DOESN'T GUARANTEE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT. SO
WE CAN OFFER A CARROT APPROACH
WE CAN TRY AND ENTICE PEOPLE TO
DRIVE LESS- WE COULD TRY SOCIAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGNS TO CHANGE
THE NORMS AROUND DAILY TRAVEL.
THAT'S NOT LIKELY TO BE ENOUGH
WE COULD TRY PAYING PEOPLE TO
CHOOSE ALTERNATIVES AND THERE'S
SOME. EXAMPLES OF THAT AND THAT
COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE- BUT
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR WERE ALSO CAN
AND NEED TO WIELD THE STICK.
AND THEIR DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
WE CAN DO THIS SO ONE STICK WE
CAN WIELD OF COURSE IS TO MAKE
DRIVING MORE EXPENSIVE. THROUGH
VARIOUS FORMS OF PRICING WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT PARKING
PRICING THIS MORNING. ON THE
SORT OF CORDON PRICING THIS
BEING CONSIDERED IN LA AND SAN
FRANCISCO. ALL OF THESE THINGS-
I THINK NEED TO BE ON THE
TABLE. OF COURSE PRICING ALWAYS
RAISES EQUITY CONCERNS BUT- IS
PRETTY CLEAR THEIR WAYS THAT
THOSE CAN BE MITIGATED- THROUGH
INVESTMENTS IN THE ALTERNATIVES
TO DRIVING AND- EVEN PROVIDING
SUBSIDIES- WHERE NEEDED. A
SECOND STICK TO THINK ABOUT IS
MAKING DRIVING LESS
CONVENIENCE. ON AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS WOULD BE IMPLEMENTING
PARKING MAXIMIN MAXIMUMS RATHER
THAN PARKING MINIMUMS THAT
MAKES DRIVING LESS CONVENIENT.
AND ALSO HAS A SIDE BENEFIT OF
MAKING WALKING BIKING AND
pANOTHER EXAMPLE IS CLOSING
STREETS TO PRIVATE VEHICLES THE
WAY THAT SAN FRANCISCO HAS DONE
ON MARKET STREET AND APPARENTLY
LA IS CONSIDERING THIS. AS WELL.
BUT A THIRD STICK I WANT TO
MENTION IS CONGESTION ITSELF AS
A DETERRENT TO DRIVING- CLOGGED
ROADS MAY BE ONE OF THE
GREATEST INCENTIVES TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS AND
TRYING SOME OF THESE
ALTERNATIVES. AND OF COURSE
THAT THEN RAISES THE QUESTION
ABOUT- DO WE WANT TO BE
EXPANDING HIGHWAYS IF OUR GOAL
IS TO REDUCE. THE M. T. AND
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE
EVIDENCE ON THE INDUCED TRAVEL
A FACT- OF AT A CAPACITY SHOWS
THAT THE ANSWER IS A CLEAR NO-
THAT IF WE INCREASE CAPACITY WE
INCREASE THE ANTI. WITHOUT
ACTUALLY DECREASING CONGESTION
IN ANY APPRECIABLE WAY SO I
THINK WE NEED TO BE DOING ALL
OF THESE THINGS- AND CLEARLY WE
NEED TO BE DOING BOTH OF THESE
BOTH OF THESE STEPS IF WE- IF
WE PUSH PEOPLE TO DRIVE LAST
WITHOUT GIVING THEM
ALTERNATIVES THAT JUST CREATES
PAIN FRUSTRATION- BUT IF WE DO
THE FIRST STEP IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH
OPPORTUNITIES WITHOUT ALSO
ENCOURAGING THEM TO USE THEM
THAT WOULD SORT OF WASTED THE
EFFORTS- IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO
I JUST WANNA AND BY POINTING TO
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES ALL OF
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THIS IS EASIER
SAID THAN DONE- ONE OF THE BIG
CHALLENGES THAT. THAT WE'RE
SEEING IT ARE THE SO CALLED
DISRUPTIONS IN TRANSPORTATION-
THE TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES LIKE UBER AND LIFT-
THAT ARE ARE CHANGING HOW
PEOPLE ARE GETTING AROUND ON A
DAILY BASIS EVIDENCE SO FAR. IS
THAT THEY ARE INCREASING RATHER
THAN DECREASING V. M. T. OF
WHICH POINTS TO THE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE THE SHARED VERSIONS
OF THESE KINDS OF SERVICES- BIG
QUESTION ABOUT AUTOMATED
VEHICLES LOOMING OVER US IN THE
FUTURE HUGE UNCERTAINTIES ABOUT
WHEN- THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN AND
HOW IT'S GONNA PLAY OUT. BUT
AGAIN POINTING TO VERY LIKELY
POSSIBILITIES OF THE INCREASE
INCREASES IN V. M. T. AS A
RESULT. SO WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
WORK AT UC DAVIS TO LOOK AT
THESE SORTS OF QUESTIONS-
AUSTIN MAY SPEAK A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT THAT- AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT SORT OF POLICIES. WOULD
PUSH THESE DISRUPTIONS IN A WAY
THAT WILL. MINIMIZE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS SECOND
CHALLENGE AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW
IS THAT THIS IS GOING TO TAKE
ACTION AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. THEIR THINGS THE
STATE CAN DO ITSELF- I THINK
PARTICULARLY AROUND PRICING-
BUT THE STATE IS ALSO GOING TO
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WYS TO
MOTIVATE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS. A TO BE ADOPTING
THE RIGHT SORTS OF POLICIES.
AND THEN I WILL ADD A THIRD
CHALLENGE. WHICH IS THAT WE
NEED BETTER DATA AND RESEARCH-
TO REALLY SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
OF THE STATE- AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE- THAT THERE'S A LOT WE
STILL NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
WE NEEDWE NEED HELP
DEVELOPING. THIRD NEW TOOLS AND
METHODS- SO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN CAN MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISIONS- WE HAVE A
PROJECT AT AUSTIN'S LEADING. AT
UC DAVIS THAT'S LOOKING AT- HOW
TO EVALUATE- THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED
BY THE- G. G. R. F. WE NEED TO
BE COLLECTING DATA AND
EVALUATING THE STRATEGIES AS
THEY ARE BEING ADOPTED- WE ALSO
NEED IMPROVE METHODS AND TOOLS-
WE'VE GOT SOME WORK FOR. BOTH
CAR AND CALTRANS AT. THAT'S
WORKING ON THIS QUESTION- THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MANY OF THEM
ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO IT. TOOLS IN HAND- TO
DO THAT IN A IN A CONFIDENT WAY.
SO I THINK THAT'S A NICE NOTED
AND DONE MORE RESEARCH. VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU- THAT'S MY
DAD'S A PROFESSOR AND NOT
ALWAYS THE BEST WAY TO END YOUR
ESSAYS IS TO SAY THAT THIS
TOPIC RAISES THE NEED FOR MORE
RESEARCH SO. OKAY WILL WILL
WILL- WILL NEXT COULD ANOTHER
GREAT RESEARCHER THAT PROFESSOR
ROLAND HOLES TO USE FROM THE
YOU SEE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE AND RESOURCE
ECONOMICS. THANK YOU A REAL
MEMBERS- GOOD MORNING- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE- THIS
RESEARCH WITH YOU AND- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SPONSOR NEXT
TEN. A GOOD REMINDER THAT- NOT
ONLY THE- STATE AGENCIES FOR
THEIR JUSTLY CELEBRATED
EFFORTS- TO SUPPORT- BETTER
EVIDENCE ON CLIMATE TO KIND OF
POLICY BUT ALSO PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER NGOS.
LIKE NEXT TEN ARE ARE HELPING
TO IMPROVE. PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
AWARENESS OF- OF THE OPTIONS
THAT ARE OPEN TO US- NEXT TEN-
JUST TO SUMMARIZE IS A IS A
NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT-
FOUNDATION- FOUNDED BY A NO
PERRY WHO IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
AND PHILANTHROPIST IN THE BAY
AREA. I'M FORTUNATE TO ALSO
HAVE- IS RESEARCH DIRECTOR AND
CO YOU COULD TELL A WITH ME
TODAY- AND AS I SAID THIS IS A
GOOD REMINDER- OF THE MANY
INITIATIVES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
THE- DECISION MAKING ON ON
CLIMB I BRING AN UPBEAT MESSAGE
TODAY. I'M HAPPY TO SAY- THIS
RESEARCH BASICALLY LOOKED AT
THE STATE'S ASPIRATIONS FOR
EASY DEPLOYMENT AS YOU KNOW-
ACTUAL DEPLOYMENT IS SOMEWHAT
DISAPPOINTING BY THAT STANDARD.
BUT WE ASK THE QUESTION IF- IF.
THE DEPLOYMENT DID SUCCEED WHAT
WOULD BE THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS. AND WE
HAVE A VERY POSITIVE MESSAGE-
FOR YOU TODAY FIRST WE CAN LOOK
I'M GOING TO. SHARE WITH YOU
I'VE SHARED WITH YOUR HAND OUT
THAT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN PAGES LONG
THE- ACTUAL REPORT IS TEN TIMES
THIS LINK SO I'M GONNA GO VERY
QUICKLY TO SUMMARIZE- THE MAIN
FINDINGS. BUT AS I SAID- WE'VE
THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISAPPOINTMENT- THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED ALREADY THIS MORNING-
THE STATE'S NOT ATTRACTED ME TO
SCHOOLS. TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS ARE RISING AS YOU CAN
SEE ON PAGE THREE- SEVEN AND-
AND OTHER- LOW EMISSIONS-
VEHICLE TAX ADOPTION HAS BEEN
IT HAS BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
STATE'S STANDARDS. AND TO MEET
THOSE GOALS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE- A REALLY DETERMINE
EFFORT. TO PROMOTE A DOG ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE POLICY
MAKERS AND OF COURSE THE-
VEHICLE SECTOR ITSELF- WE CAME
UP WITH A SET OF SCENARIOS
WHICH ESSENTIALLY CAPTURED-
WHAT I WOULD CALL THE SORT OF
STATUS QUO PERSPECTIVE IT'S
EMBODIED IN CC SO LONG TERM
ENERGY STRATEGY- THAT WE CAME
OUT ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO I WAS
INVOLVED IN THAT- AND- WITH
SOME OTHER. A RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS IN SUPPORTING CC
NCCC GENERALISES GENEROUSLY
SUPPORTED OUR WORK ON THIS- BUT
THAT IS SORT OF THE STATE OF
THE ART AS OF TWO YEARS AGO AND
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES- SINCE THEN WE
HAVE A MUCH MORE OPTIMISTIC-
TECHNOLOGY COST ESTIMATES FOR
THE SECTOR. MUCH OF WHICH IS
BEEN SPONSORED IN COLLABORATION
WITH IDEAS AND DAVIS IS
EFFORTS- TO PROMOTE RESEARCH.
ON IN THE VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
AND THEN WE ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION WHICH IS WHAT ABOUT-
WHAT ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
VEHICLE OWNERSHIP- THIS IS NOT
WHAT WE CALL AN INCLUSIVE
PROCESS BY ANY STANDARD- THE
INNOVATIVE VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
WE'RE LOOKING AT ARE STILL WELL
BEYOND THE REACH OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AROUND THE STATE
YOU CAN SEE IN- IT THE FIGURES
I THINK IT'S ON PAGE. SEVEN THE
ACQUISITION OF THESE NEW
VEHICLES IS DOMINATED BY-
ESSENTIALLY AFFLUENT WHITE
POPULATION SO FAR THE STATE'S
WELL AWARE THIS SEE BRP IS NOW
BEING- RETOOL TO PROVIDE A MORE
INCLUSIVE. PROVIDE FOR MORE
INCLUSIVE STRATEGIES- BUT STILL
WE'RE SEEING- ADOPTION IN IN A
RELATIVELY UNEQUAL MATTER-
LARGELY BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
MIGHT BE ABLE TO AFFORD THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WITHOUT THE
INCENTIVES IRONICALLY. BUT IN
ANY CASE WE ASK THIS QUESTION.
IN ORDER TO MEET ITS GOALS-
THERE HAVE TO BE SUBSTANTIAL
EDUCATION THE VEHICLE FLEET BY
TWENTY THIRTY AN EVEN MORE
DRAMATIC- DISPLACEMENT OF
CARBON FUEL VEHICLES BY. TWENTY
FIFTEEN- WE LOOKED AT THE- WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN AS A RESULT OF
DOING THAT- ON THE KIND OF
BUSINESS AS USUAL
DISTRIBUTIONAL BASIS MEANING
THAT. OWNERSHIP WOULD CONVERGE
BY TWENTY FIFTY BUT NOT MUCH
EARLIER THAN THAT AND THEN WE
HAVE A SO CALLED EQUITY
SCENARIO WHERE- POLICIES WHICH
HAVE YET TO BE DEVISED AND WE
DON'T HAVE A ROADMAP FOR THIS.
THREAD WOULD ACHIEVE AN
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
VEHICLES BY- TWENTY THIRTY. AND
CONTINUE TO- INCREASE OVERALL
FLEET- EVEY ADOPTION- TO TWENTY
FIFTY BUT ESSENTIALLY DO SO
UNIFORMLY SO THAT THERE'S A
REAL TO THE EQUAL ACCESS AROUND
THE STATE TO THESE VEHICLES.
SIGNIFICANT SO THAT'LL BE CLEAR
IN JUST A MOMENT BUT LET ME
BEGIN WITH A KIND OF A PUNCH
LINE- THE MOST DRAMATIC RESULTS
OF THIS STUDY IS OUR DISCOVERY
THAT DEVIATE OPTION IS A POTENT
CATALYST FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE REASON FOR THAT IS ACTUALLY
VERY SIMPLE I CAN MAKE THIS
WITH AN ECON ONE- ARGUMENTS- WE
SIMPLY DEVELOP THE EVIDENCE TO
DEMONSTRATE. HOW POTENT THIS
THING IS IT'S CALLED THE CANS
IN MULTIPLIER. THE REASON-
THAT. THERE IS A STIMULUS IN
THE FIRST PLACE ARE YOU CAN SEE
ON PAGE THIRTEEN. THERE'S AN
EXAMPLE OF A VERY NICE LITTLE-
DEVICE FROM THE WE- WHICH IS
SITTING ON ITS WEBSITE RIGHT
NOW YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
COMPARES THE OPERATING COST IN
TERMS OF- OF IT OF FIVE. IF YOU
ENERGIES EITHER FOR CARBON FUEL
OR A- GASOLINE THAT SAY. OR OR
ELECTRIC TO. ELECTRIC POWER AND
IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT COST
ADVANTAGE TODAY. BETWEEN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN OPERATING
THE REASON THAT ISN'T
TRANSLATING INTO OVERALL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS IS THAT THESE
VEHICLES ARE STILL TO BE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN GASOLINE POWERED
VEHICLE SO YOU HAVE TO WAIT TO
PAY BACK THE COST DIFFERENTIAL.
ACOSTA DIFFERENTIAL BY THE
STANDARDS OF THE OF THE
RESEARCH THAT OF THIS IS BEN I
GUESS SPONSORED IN PART BUT
ALSO A PROMOTED JUST THROUGH
COLLEGIALITY BY IDEAS. INTO THE
LATEST TECHNOLOGY COST
ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT WILL
REACH PARITY WITH- CONVENTIONAL
FUEL VEHICLES BY THE MIDDLE OF
THIS DECADE. SO THIS WON'T BE A
PROBLEM ANYMORE AND THOSE COST
SAVINGS THE OPERATING BECAUSE
IT WAS WILL BEGIN TO KICK IN
RIGHT AWAY THOSE TRANSLATE INTO
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SAVINGS. OF
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES OVER THE
TERM AVERAGE SCHIRMER THEIR USE
NINE TO ELEVEN YEARS. NOW
REMEMBER THIS SIZE OF THE
VEHICLE FLEET IN CALIFORNIA. IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
CARS BEING ADOPTED REALLY I
MEAN FOR DIDN'T TAKE THIS
ASPIRATION SERIOUSLY. THAT'S AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF SAVINGS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE UNITED STATES.
EXACTLY RIGHT EXACTLY RIGHT.
FOUR THOUSAND TIMES THIRTY FIVE
MILLION THAT'S REAL MONEY TODAY
CALIFORNIANS SPEND OVER FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON
GASOLINE. AND IF THOSE SAVINGS
CAN BE REDIRECTED INTO THINGS
THAT HOUSEHOLDS REALLY WANT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
POTENT STIMULANT. SO THIS IS
THE THIS IS WHERE THE STIMULUS
COMES FROM WHAT IS A GO IMAGINE
pMETAPHORICALLY AND YOU TAKE A
DOLLAR- THAT GAS AS A HOUSEHOLD
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO WELL IT
TURNS OUT THAT HOUSEHOLDS SPEND
70% OF THEIR- INCOME ON
SERVICES. THAT MEANS THAT IF WE
CAN RE DIRECT EXPENDITURE
YOU'LL SEE THIS ON PAGE TWELVE.
IF THE EXPENDITURE OF THOSE
SAVINGS IS DIRECTED IN THE
USUAL WAY REMEMBER WE ALL LIVE
IN A POST INDUSTRIAL ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA LIKE MOST OF THE
HIGH INCOME COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD LIVES BY THE SEVENTY
SEVENTY RULE. 70% OF GDP IS
HOUSEHOLD CONSUMPTION THE
HOUSEHOLD AS A PRIMARY DRIVER
THE CONSUMERS THE PRIMARY
DRIVER OF THE ECONOMY. SAME IS
TRUE IN CALIFORNIA LOOK AT
HIGHER ACTUALLY. AND 70% OF
THAT CONCEPTION IS FOR SERVICES.
WE GET TO OVER TWO THIRDS OF
OUR EMPLOYMENT BY GIVING EACH
OTHER HAIR CUTS IN THE SERVICE
OF DRINKS WE ARE LIVING IN A
POST INDUSTRIAL ECONOMY. SO
WHAT WE BASICALLY SEE IS THAT
THE SAVINGS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR. IN ENERGY SAVINGS FROM
OPERATING ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WILL BE REDIRECTED INTO SERVICE
SECTOR DEMAND. THESE ARE JOBS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE WITH
THE POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF THE
ENERGY FUEL SECTOR SORRY BUT I
HAVEN'T FOUND A WAY TO DO CAR
MINUTES ECONOMY THIS NOT
ADVERSE TO THE FOSSIL FUEL
SECTOR. I HAD TO TALK TO A
JOURNALIST KERN COUNTY ABOUT
THIS IT WAS SOMEWHAT
EMBARRASSING BUT- THAT SECTOR'S
GOING TO SUFFER THAT CAN BE.
REALLY CAN'T BE AVOIDED BUT THE
REST OF THE ECONOMY WILL SEE
VERY STRONG STIMULUS HOW STRONG
LIMóN LET'S LOOK AT THE MACRO
RESULTS NOW THAT YOU KNOW- THAT
I'VE EXPLAINED A MECHANISM TO
YOU. LET'S LOOK AT THE MACRO
RESULTS IN TWENTY THIRTY. WILL
BE LOOKING A GROSS STATE
PRODUCT IT'S EIGHTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS HIGHER AND ARE MORE
CONSERVATIVE SCENARIO. IN IT.
BUT SOMEONE I'M A PAGE ELEVEN.
RIGHT YEAH THE TOP TABLE ON
PAGE ELEVEN YEAH I'M SORRY THIS
ISN'T AN SAID THIS REPORTS I'M
GOING OUT OF SEQUENCE WITH
REPORTS I WANT TO GET TO THE
PUNCH LINES FOR THIS WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH TIME LEFT. 86% YEAH
EIGHTY TWO BILLION TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY BILLION OF ADDITIONAL
REAL GDP AS AFTER DISCOUNTING
FOR INFLATION BY TWENTY THIRTY
BY TWENTY FIFTY WERE LOOKING IT
OVER A TRILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDED GDP BECAUSE OF THE
VERSION OF EXPENDITURE FROM THE
FOSSIL FUEL SUPPLY CHAIN. TO
THE THINGS THAT HOUSEHOLDS
REALLY SPEND THEIR MONEY ON.
TWO THIRDS OF WHICH MORE THAN
TWO THIRDS OF WHICH ARE
SERVICES. TO THIS CREATES BROAD
BASED EMPLOYMENT IT CREATES
MANY MORE JOBS. THEN THE FOSSIL
FUEL SUPPLY CHAIN MOST OF WHICH
LEAKS OUT OF THE STATE ANYWAY
CALIFORNIA PRODUCES 20% OF ITS
OWN OIL. BUT THE JOB CREATION
EFFECT IS GOING ACROSS ALL
SERVICES. AND REMEMBER THESE
ARE IN STATE SERVICES THESE ARE
JOBS THAT CANNOT BE OUT SOURCE.
SO IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
DRIVER OF THE ECONOMY BUT IN
FACT THAT'S THE STATUS QUO
DRIVERS WILL BE EXPANDING
EMPLOYMENT ACROSS ALL INCOME
GROUPS. AND ACROSS ALL SERVICE
SECTOR OCCUPATIONS AND ARE
THESE ARE JUST LOW WAGE JOBS
MEMBER SERVICES INCLUDE LEGAL
SERVICES WHICH WE KNOW IS NOT
LOW WAGE MEDICAL SERVICES
ETCETERA. SO THIS EXPENDITURE
DIVERSION THAT'S FUELED BY NOPE
INTENTIONAL PUN PLEASE AT THAT
IS FEEL BY. ENERGY SAVINGS FROM
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IF WE CAN
ACHIEVE OUR OUR- OUR LUXURY
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT GOALS. WOULD
BE A VERY POTENT CATALYST FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH THAT'S THE
FIRST MESSAGE THE SECOND MAIN
MAJOR MESSAGE OF THE REPORT
CONCERNS PUBLIC HEALTH AS
YOU'RE WELL AWARE VEHICLE STONE
JUST IN IN THAT CO TWO DAMMIT
TOXIC CHEMICALS AND THOSE
BECAUSE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEMS. WHICH ARE MORE
CONCENTRATED IN SOME
COMMUNITIES THAN OTHERS AND
STATE I KNOW IS WELL AWARE OF
THE SO CALLED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY CHALLENGE WHICH WE
ADDRESSES AS PART OF THE THIRD
PIECE OF THE STUDY. BUT WE FIND
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS.
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT
INTERNS REDUCING LOCAL CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS THE REMEMBER THEY
THEY CONSIDER TO DISCLOSE UP
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AND AFFECTS
GLOBAL WARMING WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. BUT THIS
REPORT IS NOT ABOUT SAVING THE
PLANET THAT'S A LOOK THAT'S A
VERY LAUDABLE GOAL. THIS REPORT
IS ABOUT SUBSTANTIVE MATERIAL
GAINS FOR CALIFORNIANS. BOTH
AND LIVELIHOODS AND IN THEIR
HEALTH STATUS AND WE MONETIZE
THE HEALTH STATUS IN THOSE
BENEFITS ARE IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS I DON'T HAVE TIME TO
COVER RECOVER ALL THE TABLES.
BUT VERY SUBSTANTIAL. GAINES IN
PUBLIC HEALTH JUST AS THE-
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
THE WORK WE DID FOR CC SAME
MESSAGE. DEPLOYING RENEWABLE
ENERGY REDUCES EMISSIONS WHICH-
TRANSLATES INTO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
BENEFITS AND IRONICALLY THE
COST OF THE SAVINGS IN PUBLIC
HEALTH OF THE OUR PS. ARE
MATURE SIXTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ARE COMPARABLE
TO THE COST OF BUILDING OUT THE
RPF THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SYSTEM. SO YOU CAN JUSTIFY THAT
DEPLOYMENT ON THE BASIS OF THE
GAINS OF ALONE WITHOUT ANY
REFERENCE TO GLOBAL WARMING.
THE CITY AGAIN THESE ARE
MATERIAL BENEFITS THE
CALIFORNIANS NOT THAT NOT LET'S
GO IT ALONE BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. CALIFORNIA
IS DOING THE RIGHT THING ON
CLIMATE. BUT THIS IS THE
JUSTIFICATION THAT I THINK AN
ELECTRIC CAN IMMEDIATELY.
APPRECIATE WITH RELATIVELY
SIMPLE ECONOMIC. CONCEPTS SO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS IN
THE BILLIONS VERY SUBSTANTIAL
AND FINALLY- THANKS TO THE
SUPPORTING CC AND- ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA IS SO. WE'VE BUILT
OUR ARE FORECASTING MODELS TO
INCORPORATE THE CALVET ENVIRO
SCREEN SYSTEM WHICH IS A
FANTASTIC DATABASE OF VERY
DETAILED- DEMOGRAPHIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
INFORMATION AND AS YOU CAN SEE
ON PAGE FOURTEEN WE'RE ABLE TO
ASSESS THESE IMPACTS JOBS
INCOMES HEALTH STATUS. ETCETERA
AT THE CENSUS TRACK LEVEL. AND
SO WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE AND PAGE FIFTEEN YOU'LL
SEE A SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE
FINDINGS OF MAKING A STINK TION
BETWEEN DISADVANTAGED OR BACK
COMMUNE A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND NON TAXES AND
WHAT WE FIND IS PROPORTIONALLY
THE JOB BENEFITS ARE GREATER
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS WHERE AN ECONOMIST WITH
CALL PRO POOR THAT IS THE VIEW
THE OPTION IT REGARDLESS OF WHO
BY THE VEHICLES BY JUNE. TV
DEPLOYMENT WILL STIMULATE THIS
STATE ECONOMY IN A WAY THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY PRO POOR. THE
LOWEST 25% OF THE INCOME GROUP
GETS 36% OF THE JOB GAINS
BECAUSE OF THE SERVICE SECTOR
ORIENTATION. OF THE JOB
CREATION. RIGHT RIGHT AND IF
THEY BUY THE CARS EVEN BETTER
BECAUSE THEY'LL GET MORE THE
LOCAL HEALTH BENEFITS. THAT
WE'VEI'M AN ARDENT ADVOCATE AS
THIS- THIS AN INCLUSIVE
APPROACH TO VEHICLE POLICY.
BECAUSE THE OF THE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF TRANSPORT
MISSIONS ARE VERY UNEQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED RUN STATE AND I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL WELL AWARE OF
THAT. SO THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFIT THE
JOBS BENEFIT. IT'S POSITIVE FOR
BOOK ACROSS ALMOST ALL
OCCUPATION CATEGORIES. BUT THE
IN THE IN THE CASE OF THE OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFIT IT'S
AN ABSOLUTE TERMS HIGHER.
BECAUSE THE BURDEN OF PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK IS HIGHER IN THE
LOWER INCOME TO COMMUNITIES
THEY GET A LARGER ECONOMIC
BENEFIT MUCH LARGER RELATIVELY
BUT IN ABSOLUTE TERMSIT'S
LARGER SO THOSE ARE THE MAJOR
MESSAGES POTENT STIMULUS FOR
THE ECONOMY IF WE CAN ACHIEVE
THEM AT THIS REPORT UNFORTUNATE
CAN'T TELL THE STATE HOW TO
READ BUT SHE THAT. BUT NOTICE
IF YOU LOOK SORRY ONE LAST
POINT IF YOU LOOK AT THE MACRO
RESULTS. WITCHER ON PLEASE SH
STARTED DANCING AROUND. WELL
THE SUMMARIZING FOR YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MACRO RESULTS
YOU'LL SEE THAT WE ESTIMATE
FISCAL REVENUE AS A RESULT OF
THESE SCENARIOS. AND THIS IS
THE PART THESE POLICIES COULD
BE QUITE LUCRATIVE FOR THE
STATE UP TO EIGHTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL TAX
REVENUES THAT IT'S GOING INTO
GENERAL REVENUE. SO WOULD HAVE
DID YOU HAVE TO BE A WAY TO
ALLOCATED BUT AS CHAIR AS CHAIR
BUT I BELIEVE IS SURE ABOUT BUT
THE S. IN THE BILL SAID
EARLIER. THE IDEA FINANCING
SOME OF THESE POLICY
INITIATIVES WITH BOND. OR
BARRING INITIATIVE OTHER KINDS
MAKES PERFECT SENSE IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE THE BENEFITS WILL
BE REALIZE FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
BUT THERE'S A VERY SUBSTANTIAL.
THE STATE REVENUE GAINS WILL BE
VERY SIGNIFICANT FOR- AS A
RESULT OF THE STIMULUS THAT
COMES FROM- FROM DEPLOYING
THESE VEHICLES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT'S THE POINT WHERE. ALRIGHT
LET'S NOW TURN TO PROFESSOR AND
HIS COLLEAGUES AT DAVIS AUSTIN
BROWN IS DIRECTOR OF YOU SEE
GIVES POLICIES TO FOR ENERGY
ENVIRONMENT AND THE ECONOMY.
THANKS FOR THANKS SO MUCH FOR
HAVING I'M AWARE WERE RUNNING A
LITTLE SHORT ON TIME SO TRY TO
KEEP MYSELF BRIEF THAT'S NOT A
CHARACTERISTIC I'M WELL KNOWN
FOR BUT I WILL DO MY LEVEL
BEST- SERVICING THE POLICY
INSTITUTE POLITICIANS AND
PROFESSORS. BUT I THE PROBLEMS%
RIGHT HAVE YOU EVER FIND
PROFESSOR TURNED POLITICIAN
IT'S I THINK EE SO THE POLICIES
TO WHICH A DIRECT- EXISTS TO
HELP CONNECT OUR RESEARCH
ECOSYSTEM INTO THE POLICY
PROCESS REALLY TWO MECHANISMS
LIKE THIS- AND AS AS THE-
SENATE BILL SAID WE TRY NOT TO.
SIT ON ACADEMIC BOOKSHELVES SO
OUR GOAL IS REALLY TO HELP
COMMUNICATE THE RESEARCH
BECAUSE SYSTEM AND BRING THAT
TO MAKE IT USEFUL FOR YOU FOR
YOU AND IN CONDUCTING OUR JOB.
THAT'S WHERE HERE THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE- AND IT'S REALLY BORN
TO DO SO TRANSPORTATION HAVE
DISCUSSED IN PARTICULAR HARD TO
ADDRESS- AND IT'S ALSO REALLY
HARD TO ADDRESS JUST FOR THE
CARBON PRICE THE SIMPLE
MECHANISM. A GOOD WAY TO SEE
THIS IS THAT IF YOU WERE TO GET
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS A TONNE
CARBON PRICE WHICH NOBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT. THAT WOULD
TRANSLATE TO ABOUT A DOLLAR A
GALLON GASOLINE- AND THAT'S
JUST NOT A BIG ENOUGH NOW TO
MOVE PEOPLE FOR SIGNIFICANTLY
WE SEEN DOLLARS A GALLON SPIKES
IN GAS PRICES PEOPLE CHANGE
THEIR BEHAVIOR IF YO PERCENT-
SUCH A GOOD WAY TO SEE WHY WE
HAVE THIS. ONE REASON HAVE THIS
ROBUST SET OF COMPANY POLICIES
TO KICKSTART SOME OF THE
CHANGES THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING-
SIGNAL CALIFORNIA'S LEADING ON
MANY OF THESE POLICIES AS WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT. WE ARE NOT ON
TRACK TO MEET OUR GOALS- ANDS-
NEED TO BE LOOKING MUCH MORE
AT- WHAT THE FUTURE MIGHT LOOK
LIKE- SO. AND THEN AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK MORE-
AGGRESSIVELY AT REDUCE OUR
MISSIONS THAT WE THOUGHT WE
NEED TO BEFORE NOW WITH A GOAL
NEUTRALITY ON THE TWENTY FORTY
FIVE TIME FRAME WHICH IS.
FASTER THAN WE HAVE A LOT OF
CREDIBLE STUDIES EXPLORING SO
FAR I MEAN THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE GOAL BASED ON
CLIMATE SCIENCE AND BASED ON ON
THE HEALTH AND- CONGESTION
CRISES WERE IN AS WELL- BUT WE
SHOULD BE CLEAR EYED ASIDE
SENATOR STARK SAID. ABOUT THE
SCALE THE CHALLENGE THAT WERE
FACING. UP I'M GONNA TRY TO
SUMMARIZE A REALLY HUGE MATTER
OF RESEARCH IN JUST A FEW
POINTS AND THAT MEANS THAT. A
LOT OF TELLING AT LEAST. ONE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH. I WITH YOUR
OFFICE IS GOING FOR DENISE THIS.
SO I LIKE TO. AT HOME THE A-
THE- AMATEUR CHEF AND SO I THE
ABOUT ALL THESE. IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE WANT TO PUT TOGETHER AS-
RECIPE'S INGREDIENTS- AND TO
THE INGREDIENTS. OF A- CARBON
CARBON FREE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. I THINK A PRETTY WELL
KNOWN BY NOW- NOW. ARE
COMMUNICATIONS PEOPLE TELL ME
TO LIMIT- THE NUMBERS OF LISTS
I GIVE TO. ITEMS OF THREE OR
FEWER- I THINK I MEAN OPERATE
IN THE SIMPSON MATTER. THERE
LEGISLATORS ARE TO AT LEAST
TWICE AS GOOD AT KEEPING.
INFORMATION IS. THE GENERAL
PUBLIC'S I'VE LIMITED MYSELF TO
SIX WE'LL SEE. WE'LL SEE HOW WE
GO WITH THAT- SO NUMBER ONE IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. QUITE A
BIT BEFORE AND SO I WON'T GO
INTO DETAIL IS MITIGATING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AND
INCREASING I'M TRANSPORTATION
MODE CHOICE. WITH OUR PLANNING
INVESTMENT- WE TALKED ABOUT
WAS. DR HANDY TALKS IN GREAT.
GREAT ELOQUENCE ABOUT THE NEED
TO DO THIS. AND IN PARTICULAR
THE NEED TO ENSURE THAT NEW
MOBILITY. A WHICH HAS BEEN
RAPIDLY SERVICES LIKE UBER
LIFT- ARE SHARED AND- SUPPORT.
RATHER THAN COMPETE. OUT
TRANSIT. ON THIS STILL I THINK
HAS A HUGE ROLE EVEN IF WE OVER
PERFORMING ELECTRIFICATION. AND
CLEAN UP THE VEHICLES
THEMSELVES WILL CALL. IN HER ON.
TO CHALLENGES. YES ACCESS.
HEALTH FROM ACTIVE TRADE. ALL
BENEFIT FROM A MORE DIVERSE SET
OF CHOICES AND GETTING BEYOND
THE- SINGLE OCCUPANT CAR. ON A
CULTURE- THE NUMBER. TWO IS THE
FULL ELECTRIFICATION OF LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE- THIS. IS A GOOD OPEN
QUESTION ABOUT HOW. LONG WILL
NEED. A MULTI. FUEL VEHICLES
LIKE PLUG IN HYBRIDS. ON YOU
CAN. FOR MORE. SO NEEDS. EVER
THE SOURCE. VEHICLE MAKE IT.
WE'RE SO. A BIT SLOW IN THE-
CAN EVEN WE SEEN MILLION.
AUGUST ON THE TECHNOLOGY AND
PRODUCED DIRECTIONS. OF. THE
CITY VEHICLES. I'M AT THE SAME
TIME. NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE HAVE TO BETTER EQUITY FOR.
JUST STARTING TO SEE YOU CAR
MARK. SO THE GOING TO BE REALLY
OPTION GET A LOT VEHICLES INTO.
THE THAT NEED MOST WHICH OF THE
LOWER INCOME. THAT OFTEN DON'T.
GOOD ACCESS TO TRANSFER.
SERVICES AND ALSO AS AS
RESTAURANT HOLE SAID WHAT WOULD
BENEFIT THE MOST FROM THOSE AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS OF GTTING
THOSE EASE INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. HAS BEEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT TIME FOR THAT. USED
VEHICLE MARKET. TO BE ON LIKE
THE VEHICLE IS ALSO LOOKING AT
FULL RECTIFICATION OF MEDIUM
DUTY DELIVERY. DRAINAGE AND
TRANSIT VEHICLES THESE VEHICLES
HAVE DUTY CYCLES THAT ARE
INCREDIBLY- WELL ALIGNED WITH
ELECTRIFICATION. THEY DON'T
DRIVE. TOO FAR TO BE SUITABLE
FOR A BATTERY APPLICATION. AND
THEY ALSO HAVE HUGE LOCAL AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS BECAUSE
THEY'RE OPERATING RIGHT IN
THOSE MARKETS- WHICH ARE MOST
VULNERABLE- THE NUMBER FOUR IS
A SLIGHT CONTRAST. NEED NOT
NECESSARILY FULL OF VACATION
BUT AS MUCH LIKE FOR CATIONS
POSSIBLE. OF LONG HAUL A HEAVY
DUTY FREE VEHICLES. I THINK AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE THESE
TEND TO HAVE LONGER DUTY CYCLES
TRAVEL VERY LONG DISTANCES- AND
SO- MAYBE- H. MORE CHALLENGING
MARKET- AND MAY ALSO BE GOOD
APPLICATION FEEL SUCH
TECHNOLOGIES IF BATTERY-
PROGRESS FLATTENS OUT- IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. IT'S STILL
POSSIBLE THOUGH THAT BATTERIES
WILL BE ABLE TO TRUST THOSE
IT'S JUST WE HAVE LESS
CONFIDENCE IN THE MEDIUM DUTY.
AND MORE LOCAL DELIVERY. ON
VEHICLES. NUMBER FIVE IS THE-
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO SUPPORT ALL OF THESE NEWMAN.
PLEASE BE ALL THESE NEW MODES.
I'M SO FOR PERSONALLY OWNED
VEHICLES WE KNOW THAT MOST OF
CHARGING WILL BE WALL AT HOME
AND WALL AT WORK. NUMBER TWO-
I'M INTENSE BUT SAYING WALL AT
HOME RATHER THAN AT HOME. AS WE
MOVE BEYOND PEOPLE WITH GARAGES
OWNING THESE VEHICLES WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO. SUPPORT
THEIR CHARGING WHILE THEY ARE
AT HOME WITH THIS IN A MULTI
FAMILY. DWELLING OR AWAY FROM
THEIR- OR ON THE STREET OR WE
FROM THEIR ACTUAL HOME. AND
WHILE AT WORK BE ABLE TO CHARGE
THERE IS A NUMBER TWO. NUMBER
ONE OPTION FOR THOSE A- CHART
BUT HOME. FOR PUBLIC CHARTER
STILL HAS A ROLE OF FOR
IMPROMPTU CHARGING AND- THE
BILL SOME CONFIDENCE. ON NEARLY
CHARGING. OUT ACTUAL US OF
STATIONS. THAT WHEN YOU START
LOOK AT THE NEW. A USE OF LIKE
VEHICLES. FOR WERE ARE SEEING
WITH UBER LIFT THAT MUCH HIGHER.
ON CHARGING. AND SO CITIES NEED
TO GET AHEAD OF THAT AND THINK
ABOUT. HOW TO BUILD A CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THE GOOD APPLICATIONS OF THESE-
OF THESE NEW ABILITY FLEETS AND
ALLOWS THEM TO ELECTRIFY MORE
RAPIDLY- THEY WOULD OTHERWISE.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF THIS TURNING
INFRASTRUCTURE INTEGRATES WELL
WITH THE GRID- AND I KNOW THIS
IS BEING CONSIDERED BY SOME
OTHER COMMITTEES A LEGISLATURE
BUT- THINKING AHEAD ABOUT HOW
TO USE. TRANSPORTATION CHARGING
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INCORPORATE MORE HIGH LEVELS OF
IN THE WINTER G. RATHER THAN AS
A RISK FACTOR. WE CAN ACTUALLY
FORGET THE POLICIES RIGHT- HELP
SUPPORT OUR NEW ENERGY GOALS
AND THE STABILITY THE GREAT AT
THE SAME TIME AS WE MOVE TO
ELECTRIFICATION. I'M IN MY
FINAL. A NUMBER SIX INGREDIENT
IS ADVANCED RENEWABLE LIQUID
FUELS FOR THE REMAINDER AND
THIS GETS TO THE- AIRCRAFT AS
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
AS WELL AS MARINE APPLICATIONS.
THAT WOULD BE VERY VERY
CHALLENGING TO- TO MOVE TO
ELECTRIFICATION- FEELS MAY BE A
GOOD WAY TO GET AHEAD OF THIS.
AND WE NEED TO BE THINKING IN
ADVANCE ABOUT SOME TRULY LOWER
CARBON FUELS. THAT AREN'T
REALLY IN THE MARKET YET. SO
THOSE ARE SIX INGREDIENTS THIS
ALSO MEANS THAT ARE OTHER
OPTIONS THAT. SORT OF LOOK
APPEALING AT THE BEGINNING BUT-
JUST BASED ON THE- LONG TERM
RESEARCH. WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGE BEING A PART OF THE
FUTURE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
SETS TECHNOLOGIES LIKE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE VEHICLES FOR
LIKE TWO VEHICLES. I EVEN IF
YOU GET THE MORE EFFICIENT
THERE IS NOT COMPATIBLE WITH AN
80% OR MORE REDUCTION- WE
DEFINITELY CAN'T CONTINUE
BUSINESS AS USUAL. AS WE BUILD.
HOUSING AND INVEST IN TRANSIT
WE NEED TO BE THINKING VERY
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THE-
INVESTMENT PATTERNS WE'VE
DOING. DISCUSSED A LOT SO I
WILL MOVE. MOVE THROUGH THAT
WOULD QUICKLY- WE ALSO NEED TO.
LOOK VERY CRITICALLY AT EFFORTS
TO INCORPORATE NOTHING HOUSTON
TRANSPORTATION- AND THERE'S
JUST NO APPLICATION OF FOSSEL
GAS- OTHER THAN WITH VERY HIGH
LEVELS OF CARBON CAPTURED AT A-
ELECTRIC. GENERATION PLANT.
THAT'S PROBABLY PERCENT
REDUCTIONS- RULE MATCH GOT DOES
IT DEFINITELY VIABLE LOW CARB.
FUEL SPEAK SUPPORTED
APPROPRIATELY BUT WILL COVER
FUELS. ANDERSON CENTER THE
TOTAL PLY. MUCH LOW. AND WOULD
BE NEEDED JUST FOR. THE CURRENT.
AFTER GAS IN A SECTORS. NO WAY
FOR TO SCALE UP TO MEET.
SIGNATURE PORTION PASSED.
YOU'LL I'M JUST BASED ON THE
RESOURCES. AND THAT'S WELL. IN
NOT. AS FAR AS AN SUBJECT.
REPORTS WE HAVE ON THE TOP.
UNCONVENTIONAL BUT RENEWABLE
WALLS AFTER FOR A VENN THE
PHASE OUT THINGS START A AT THE
FOR AND POTENTIAL BODY VERY
BRIDGE IN THE IMPORTANT TO OF
LIQUID FUEL. BUT THEY THOSE
EARLY TECHNOLOGIES TO CAN'T GET
TO CUSTOMERS RUSSIAN. I'M IN
THE LAST WE CAN'T GO TO
AUTOMATE POLICY BLIND CAN'T
JUST AUTOMATE THESE. AND AS
SOON SOUL OF OUR AS THE DOCTOR
HAD HE SAID WE REALLY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS- FROM
HOW TO INCREASE THEIR BENEFITS
SUPPORT POOLING SHARING
ELECTRIFICATION- AND THE CLEAN
MILE STANDARD ON THAT CHAIR
NICHOLS MENTIONED EARLIER IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT POLICY OOL
HERE. OKAY SO WE KNOW ALL THOSE
INGREDIENTS AND WHAT'S THE
RECIPE HOW MUCH OF EACH OF
THESE I DON'T THINK WE KNOW ANY
OF THAT YET EXACTLY NUMBER WE
DON'T HAVE TO GET STARTED I'M
HAVE TO DO OUR BEST AND JUST AS
WE GO ALONG BUT YOU KNOW SOME
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO FIGURE
THIS ALL OUT IT'S NOT A LOT OF
TIME AND- RATIFIED STATE IS
MOVING FORWARD A LEADERSHIP
POSITION- AND TRY TO TAKE ON
THESE INCREDIBLY TOUGH.
CHALLENGES THE LAST POINT I'LL
MENTION IS THAT THE- YOU SEE IN
SUITS OF TRANSPORTATION STUDIES
ARE STARTING A CONFERENCE OF
FOR CAMPUS STUDY NOW- WHICH IS
FUNDED IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR
LOOKING AT THESE COMBINED
SCENARIOS FOR CARBON NEUTRALITY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THAT WILL BE
FIRST OF KIND STUDY WE'VE NEVER
HAD A- ROBUST ACADEMIC STUDY
LOOKING AT A D. CONVERSATION
SCENARIO THAT. AND THAT DEEP
AND WHAT IS ASKED TO PROVIDE
SOME. THINGS THE- I'M MISPRINT.
A GOOD OUT. SLASH MORE. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
REALLY APPRECIATE. BEING BACK
HERE TO BACK CLEAN UP GHG CLEAN
UP- CHAIR BELL JR ALLEN'S
MEMBERS OF THIS. HEARING PANEL
THIS MORNING. I AM CAIT GREEN
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION'S EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. AND DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. OUR
AGENCY IS THE SECOND LARGEST
TRANSIT OPERATOR IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE OPERATE THE LARGEST YOUR
OMISSION FLEET IN NORTH
AMERICA. A FOR THOSE UP IT AS
FAR AS C. T. IN GENERAL WE RE
WE RE REPRESENT- TRANSIT
OPERATORS AND MOST OF YOUR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS. FROM NAPA
VALLEY. SANTA MONICA BIG BLUE
BUS VTA PART. OF ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA TRANSIT AND BART. AND
SENATOR DOLLY WE WELCOME. THE
TRANSIT SERVICE IN YOUR PART OF
THE STATE AS WELL- I'M PLEASE
HAVE IT BEEN INVITED HERE BY
CHAIR BELL TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT PUBLIC TRANSITS ROLE IN
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S RISING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS. AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER TODAY THE
STATE CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE
WITH CURBING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. OR OTHER METRICS AS
SENATOR DOLE HAS POINTED OUT
VMT HOW YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
MATTERS. SO CONGESTION. DESPITE
ITS CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGIES ALTERNATE. MODES
THE TREND IS WORRISOME. BUT
LOST IN THE HEADLINES OF
DECLINING TRANSIT RIDERSHIP AND
OUR AFFINITY FOR OUR CARS. IS
THE REALITY THAT MANY OF THE
KEY STRATEGIES FOR REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS. AND
SIMPLE AND SUPPORTING PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATIONS. HAVE SELDOM
BEEN PURSUED. IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ACADEMIC LITERATURE AND THE
ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE FROM
SEATTLE PORTLAND HOUSTON AND
SACRAMENTO CITIES WHERE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP IS RISING IS CLEAR.
WE CAN TAKE CARS OFF THE ROAD
AN INCREASE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
WHEN TRADITIONAL TRANSIT
SERVICE IS FAST CONVENIENT
FREQUENT RELIABLE AND COST
COMPETITIVE. AND YOU MAY SAY
GREAT THE STATE PROVIDES
TRANSIT AGENCIES WITH
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING NOW SO DO
EXACTLY THAT. IT'S A HERE THAT
IT IS IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE SOME STRATEGIES
THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN AND
SHOULD PURSUE THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS THAT WE DAYS SIMPLY HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER. TRANSLATION
SEES CAN CONDUCT OPERATIONAL
ANALYSES TO ASSESS AND RECAST
THEIR SERVICE NETWORKS BASED ON
CHANGING DEMO DEMOGRAPHICS
SERVICE NEEDS SHIFTING
POPULATION ETCETERA. AND
SEVERAL CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCIES HAVE HAVE CONDUCTED
ARE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CONDUCTING THESE ANALYSES WE'VE
DONE THIS IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
OUR MUNY FORWARD PROJECT REALLY
WE REALIZE THAT 75% OF OUR
RIDERSHIP IS ON THIRTEEN OF OUR
PRIMARY ROUTES. AND YET WE
OPERATE OVER HUNDRED ROUTES SO
TRYING TO LOOK AT HOW TO
PROVIDE BETTER SERVICE MORE
EFFICIENTLY WHERE THE MOST
DEMAND IS A KEY PART OF THE
BUSINESS PROVIDING A BETTER
PRODUCT. IN SAN DIEGO WITH
SIMILAR WORK THEY SAW ONE POINT
4% RIDERSHIP INCREASED OVER THE
LAST YEAR IN SACRAMENTO A SIX
POINT 35% WRITER IN IN THE
QUARTER TWO NINETY. ADDITIONAL
NINE LIGHT. THAT WOULD PROVIDE
ON SB ONE THE STATE'S ONGOING
ABOUT OF GREEN GAS FOR. FUNDS
WE CAN INCREASE SERVICE LEVELS
AND BE CAPACITY ADVANCE
TARGETED FOR REDUCTIONS IN
REHAB OUR VEHICLES. THAT IS TO
MAKE THE DIRECT INVESTMENTS
THAT WE KNOW WILL REDUCE
EMISSIONS DIRECTLY FROM
TRANSIT. AND THAT HELP MAKE
TRANSIT MORE COMPETITIVE WITH
AUTO TRAVEL. TO PUT A FINER
POINT ON IT CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS IN THE TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
AND LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAM WHICH HAVE
BEEN REFERENCED YET THIS
MORNING. HAVE DIRECTLY
SUPPORTED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CORE CAPACITY PROJECTS THE
REPLACEMENT OF AGING TRANSIT
VEHICLES AND INCREASE TRANSIT
OPERATIONS THAT HAVE
COLLECTIVELY. ENDS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE EQUIVALENT WITH THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN ZERO
MISSION BUSES CALIFORNIA IS NOW
ON TRACK TO HAVE ONE THOUSAND
ZERO EMISSION BUSES IN
OPERATIONS ON THE ORDER OF BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY THIS
PROGRESS IS IN KEEPING WITH
CARBS INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
REGULATION AND IS MADE
CALIFORNIA THE DOMINANT MARKET
FOR ZERO MISSION BUSES IN THE
COUNTRY AND AS A SIDE I WOULD
NOTE IN THE PRESENTATION BY THE
LEAD ANALYST THIS. THEY
REFERENCED HOW CAN CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS SOME OF THESE CONCEPTS
TO BRING OTHER STATES ALONG AND
ONE THING TO CONSIDER AND THIS
GOES TO PROFESSOR ROLAND'S-
COMMON ABOUT THE I WOULD CALL
IT THE EEVEE DIVIDENDS LIKE A
PEACE DIVIDEND IS CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST MANUFACTURER ZERO
MISSION BUSES IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY THERE.
THREE STATE EFFORTS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA INTEGRATED TRAVEL
PLAN OR PROJECT TO TRANSIT
AGENCIES WILL SOON HAVE THE
TOOLS TO PRESENT AN INTEGRATED.
AND SEAMLESS MOBILITY.
EXPERIENCE TO WOULD BE WRITERS.
BUT IMPORTANTLY AND I THINK
WE'VE HEARD THIS A LOT THIS
MORNING THERE ARE MANY-STRATEGIES THAT MANY IF NOT
MOST TRANSIT AGENCIES CANNOT
PURSUE THEMSELVES AND THAT
REQUIRE EXTERNAL SUPPORT TO
ACCOMPLISH INCLUDING FROM YOU
ALL. THESE STRATEGIES INCLUDE
SOME OF THE TOUGHER CHALLENGES
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN WRESTLING
WITH HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
LAND USE. AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THIS MORNING THE SORT OF
CONSISTENT MESSAGING AROUND THE
NEED FOR PRICING. IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE A TRANSIT
FIRST POLICY WHICH MEANS THAT
WE CAN ADVANCE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THE TYPE OF TRADE OFFS
NEEDED. IN TERMS OF THE STREET
RIGHT OF WAY TO MAKE TRANSIT A
PRIORITY AND THERE WAS
REFERENCE EARLIER TODAY ABOUT
OUR RECENT DECISION TO CLOSE
MARKET STREET AND IF YOU'VE
BEEN TO SAN FRANCISCO YOU KNOW
THAT MARKET STREET IS. OUR MOST
IMPORTANT DOWNTOWN CORRIDOR IN
JANUARY WE ELIMINATE ALL
PRIVATE AUTOMOBILES ON MARKET
STREET WE SEE TWO HUNDRED BUSES
PER HOUR DURING THE PEAK. AND
MANY TRAVEL TIMES HAVE IMPROVED
BY 12% SINCE JANUARY I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WHEN I WALK ON MARKET
STREET NOW. IT'S AND IT'S YES
THERE ARE NO PRIVATE CARS- YES
WE'VE REMOVED. UBER AND LIFT.
BUT WHAT PEOPLE HAVE COMMENTED
ON IS HOW QUIET IT IS. IT'S
ACTUALLY AN INCREDIBLE SHIFT IN
AN EXPERIENCE AS A PEDESTRIAN.
OR AS A MODE USER YOU CAN
ACTUALLY HEAR BIRDS AT THIS
POINT ON MARKET STREET WHICH IS
REALLY INCREDIBLE. HOWEVER IN
MOST CALIFORNIA CITIES BUSES
LIGHT RAIL VEHICLES ARE FORCED
TO OPERATE IN MIXED TRAFFIC.
MEANING THAT WHEN THERE ARE
TRAFFIC DELAYS ON THE ROADWAY
DUE TO AN ACCIDENT TRAFFIC
LIGHT TRANSIT IS LOADED PUSHED
OFF SCHEDULE. THIS REALITY IS
THE RESULT OF DECISIONS MADE BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO GOVERN
THE RIGHT OF WAY AND WHO ARE
OFTEN THOUGH NOT ALWAYS
DIVORCED FROM HER TRANSIT
AGENCIES. ACTIONS TO CREATE BUS
ONLY LANES. SUCH AS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND
DEMOCRATIC DEDICATED RIGHT OF
WAY LIKE LA METRO SILVER AN
ORANGE LINES. OR TRAFFIC LIGHT
PRIVATIZATION FOR PUBLIC
TRANSIT ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
HEAD ON BY GIVING TRANSIT
VEHICLES TRAVEL PREFERENCE OVER
SINGLE OCCUPANCY VEHICLES. IN
DOING SO THEY IMPROVE ON TIME
PERFORMANCE RELIABILITY
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION MAKING
TRANSIT MORE ATTRACTIVE TO
WOULD BE WRITERS. AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES EXPECT THAT CHAIRMAN
BILLS BUS ON SHOULDER
LEGISLATION. COULD DELIVER
SIMILAR BENEFITS TO COMMUTER
BUSES OPERATING ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM. HOWEVER THERE
IS THEN LAND USE AND HOUSING.
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE PUT INTO
PLACE THE FRAMEWORK FOR LINKING
LAND USE AND TRANSPORTATION
DECISION MAKING BUT IT LACKS
THE FUNDING SUPPORT AS WELL AS
THE STICK TO ENSURE THAT
REGION'S CAN COMPLY WITH THEIR
OWN PLANS AND TARGET SETTING.
WHAT RESULTS AND THIS IS BORNE
OUT BY THE DATA PUBLISHED
RECENTLY BY A RP IS THAT SPRAWL
WHICH IS INHERENTLY CHALLENGING
FOR TRANSIT TO PERFORM WELL
ACROSS. CONTINUES TO CONSUME
OUR STATE AND OUR STATE. AND
OUR RELIANCE ON AUTUMN ABILITY
BECOMES MORE AND MORE
ENTRENCHED. AT THE SAME TIME
OUR STATE CONTINUING PROBLEM
WITH HOUSING AFFORDABILITY HAS
SUBURBANITES PROPERTY PUSHING
ONE SCORE TRANSIT RIDERS AWAY
FROM THE CITY CENTERS WERE
TRANSIT IS A PRACTICAL OPTION.
TO AREA OF THE STATE WHERE THE
ONLY REASONABLE OPTION FOR
COMMUTING IS THE CAR. ACCORDING
TO A JUST RELEASED UC ITS STUDY
ON BAY AREA TRANSIT TRENDS AND
I COMMEND THIS TO YOU- AS A
REALLY GREAT CONCISE IN ITS
POLICY BRIEF SUMMARY ON THE
TRENDS THAT ARE IMPACTING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. MORE THAN
THREE AND FIVE BAY AREA WORKERS
NOW LIVE AND WORK IN
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH RELATIVELY
POOR TRANSIT ACCESS TO
EMPLOYMENT. WHAT'S MORE WE ARE
NOW SEEING THAT FEWER BAY AREA
RESIDENTS LIVE AND WORK IN THE
SAME CITY. AND THAT COMMUTE
DISTANCES FOR ALL BAY AREA
WORKERS HAVE INCREASED. IF WE
ARE TO STEM THE TIDE OF RISING
BMT AND TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS WE NEED TO CONFRONT
THESE CHALLENGES HEAD ON. BY
DISCOURAGING SPRAWL SUPPORTING
AFFORDABLE TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT IN AN IN ACTING
ANTI DISPLACEMENT POLICIES.
FINALLY THERE'S PRICING AS
SECRETARY KIM STATED SO WELL
AND UNEQUIVOCALLY THIS MORNING
IT MATTERS. IT'S A BIT
REDUCTIVE BUT WHEN COMMUTERS
HAVE THE OPTION OF TAKING A
TRANSPORTATION AND UBER A LIFT
FOR FIVE DOLLARS OR A BUS WITH
TRANSFERS FOR THREE DOLLARS.
IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT THOSE
WITH MEANS CHOOSE THE FORMER.
WE NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
PRICING OUR TRANSPORTATION
MODES TO BETTER INTERNALIZE THE
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED. IF WE LEAVE OUT.
GGG AND CONGESTION. REDUCE
REDUCING THESE WE OUGHT TO
APPLY A COST TO THAT AND BAKE
IT RECIPE INTO THE PRICE OF
CHOOSING A SINGLE OCCUPANCY
CAR. VERSUS TRANSIT WHILE ALSO
BEING CAREFUL TO CONSIDER THE
EQUITY EQUITY IMPLICATIONS OF
SUCH POLICIES. AND TO SEIZE
PLANET PLANNED AREA TWENTY
FIFTEEN BLUEPRINT DOES THIS
WELL BY CONSIDERING ALL LANE
FREEWAY TOLLING FOR DISCOUNTS
FOR CAR POOLING LOW INCOME
DRIVERS AND OFF PEAK TRAVEL. ON
QUARTERS WITH BART AND CALTRAIN
ALTERNATIVES. AND BY THE SAME
TOKEN WE MUST REEVALUATE
PARKING WHETHER IT'S FREE OR
CHEAP STREET PARKING OR PARKING
MINIMUMS WITH NEW CONSTRUCTION.
AND REALIZE THAT WE PASSIVELY
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF
AUTOMOBILES BY MAKING THEM TO
CHEAPER TO CAN BE AND TOO
CONVENIENT. IN CLOSING
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE
PROUD OF THE VITAL ROLE WE PLAY
AND WILL CONTINUE AND MUST PLAY
IN ADDRESSING THE STATE'S
RISING TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS. I HOPE MY COMMENTS
HERE TODAY LEAVE YOU WITH A
LASTING IMPRESSION THAT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL TO REALLY REDUCE THE
M. T. AND CONGESTION
TRANSLATIONS HE'S WILL REQUIRE
THE SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP OF
ALL ENTITIES. THAT GOVERN OUR
STATE TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
YEP YEP GIVE THE GREEN. WELL
THE TOWN QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
FROM THE MEMBERS. NOT SURE
ABOUT- ONE OF ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES- TO GET MORE TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP OF WOULD BE TO. THERE
IS SOME KIND OF EXTREME FAIR
DISCOUNT PROGRAM IN OUR STAND
SACRAMENTO. TRANSITION SEE- HAS
BEEN GIVING TRANSIT PASSES TO.
STUDENTS AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
IS THERE IS THERE. A RIDERSHIP
INCREASE WHEN THE TRANSIT
DISCOUNT FAIRER YOU KNOW LIKE
THE GIVE TRANSIT PASSES SOME
PLACES THE GIVEN FOR FREE THEY
GET THEY GIVE HERE'S YOUR PAST
YOU HAVE A BASS YOU. CAN CUT
AND RIDE TRANSIT AND THEN THE
OTHER THE OTHER STRATEGY ON THE
OTHER HAND ON TRANSIT DISCOUNTS
IS TO HAVE THE EMPLOYER PROVIDE
ALL THEIR- EMPLOYEES WOULD
TRANSIT PASSES ARE THOSE KINDS
OF OPTIONS- DO THEY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON. A RIDERSHIP AND TO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS INTO
FOR THE WE'VE SAID. WELL SO I
WOULD SAY- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
IN GENERAL OF ALL PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE TRANSIT AND ENCOURAGE
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH EMPLOYERS OR USE PASSES
ON IN SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVE A
VERY ROBUST ROBUST FREE MUNY
FOR LOW INCOME YOUTH SENIORS
AND DISABLED RESIDENTS. AND
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE ON RIDERSHIP
AMONG STUDENTS USING MUNY- I
THINK THE KEY ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE IDEAS I HAVE IS THAT WHEN
YOU GO TO KINDERGARTEN SHOULD
GET A TRANSIT PASS. IT SHOULD
BE HOW WE BRING ALONG
GENERATION OF WRITERS BUT THE
KEY IS TO THINK ABOUT HOW HOW
WE PAY FOR THAT I THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ON THIS AS
A AS AS A AS A PROGRAM THAT WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE WE DO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT. ALL THAT THE CALL
THAT. HE I IT IS INSURANCE OUR
PROGRAM I JUST AS FREE. COST US
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
JUST A STRAIGHT UP THAT COMES
OUT OF OUR OPERATING BUDGET- WE
HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO HAVE A SORT OF OUR
OPERATING BUDGET SUPPORTED BY
THE GENERAL FUND OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO. I
DON'T BELIEVE ANY OTHER
OPERATOR IN CALIFORNIA HAS THAT
AND SO AS WE LOOK TO THESE.
PUSH AND PULL LEVERS AROUND
PRICING. FOR EXAMPLE IF E'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT CORDON
PRICING OR CONGESTION PRICING
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO SUPPORT.
THE PRICING THAT WE NEAR THE OF
THE FUNDING THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THESE KINDS OF
PROPOSALS UNDER. THE COMMENT.
ASKING PROFESSOR OF ROLEN HOPES
THE WHOLE STE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT- REACHING THIS PARITY ON-
EVEY. PURCHASING PER OWNERSHIP
RIGHTS BY THE YEAR TWENTY FIFTY
AND WE HAVE WE HAVE A PROGRAM
NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR LOW INCOME FOR OUR FOLKS
SAID CARS FOR ALL THAT WE WANT
WE HAVE A DESIRE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO PURCHASING- E.
V. MY- VEHICLES. IS THAT
REALISTIC BASED ON YOUR
RESEARCH ME SEEMS LIKE A NICE
PROGRAM. OR COULD THAT MONEY BE
SPENT BETTER- IN THE SHORT TERM
RATHER THAN THE LONG TERM I
WOULD CERTAINLY ADVOCATES-
SHORT TERM COMMITMENTS AND I'M
VERY CONCERNED THIS BAG I. I
CERTAINLY SHARE THE CONCERN
THAT WAS EXPRESSED ABOUT THE-
DOWNWARD- ADJUSTMENT- IN C. B.
R. P. RESOURCES POTENTIAL
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS VIA THE
RESOURCES BECAUSE I THINK THE
STATE SHOULD BE DOUBLING DOWN
RIGHT NOW AND- AS I. INDICATED
OUR PROJECTIONS OF THE BE VERY
SUBSTANTIAL REVENUE DIVIDENDS-
AS A RESULT OF THE GROWTH
STIMULUS SO THE STATE COULD GET
THIS MONEY BACK IF IT HAS A
LONG TERM FINANCING SCHEME.
THAT WOULD ENABLE THAT AS FAR
AS THE DISTRIBUTIONAL
IMPLICATIONS YES I AM
PERSONALLY AN ADVOCATE OF A
MORE INCLUSIVE APPROACH TO- TO
THESE INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES
AND I THINK THIS STATE. COULD
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVE THE TERMS
OF ACQUISITION FOR THESE
VEHICLES FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS TO FIX
COST THEY'LL BENEFIT
PROPORTIONALLY MORE FROM THE
FUEL THINGS BECAUSE- THAT'S
EVERY YOU KNOW IT'S THE SAME
COST PER GALLON. FOR EVERYBODY
WHO DRIVES A GUESS MY QUESTION
IS AS AN ECONOMIST WE HAVE. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED A BUDGET
THAT REDUCES THE C. B. R. P.
FOUR HUNDRED. AND TWENTY WE'VE
GOT A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE 30% OF
THAT HAS TO GO TO LOW INCOME
FOLKS SO THAT REDUCE. THE
AMOUNT EVEN MORE. TO IN THIS
OTHER ENOUGH LIKELY VOTER.
GIVEN THE NINETY FIVE DOLLAR
INCENTIVE. GIVEN EVERY ALL THE
OTHER STRAINS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
TODAY TO PARTICIPATE MAY I
GUESS WE'LL KNOW AT THE END OF
THE YEAR WILL KNOW IT IT'LL
DEPEND ON YOUR CONSTITUENCY OF
COURSE RIGHT BUT- I THINK THAT
THEY'RE JUST VERY STRONG
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR TRYING TO
MAKE THESE VEHICLESMORE
ACCESSIBLE- AS SOON AS WE COULD
DO THAT AND YOU THE FOLLOWING
IS NECESSARY TO DO IT AND AS I
SAID I THINK THE STATE SHOULD
REALLY BE DOUBLING DOWN
INCENTIVES. ACROSS THE BOARD
BUT PARTICULARLY IN THOSE
CATEGORIES- THEY'RE-
UNDERSERVED BY THESE- BUT IT'S
TECHNOLOGIES AND NEED THE
BENNETT THIS LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS AND EVEN THE
FUEL SAVINGS BENEFITS WILL MEAN
MORE TO THEM AND SAYS SO I JUST
I REALLY THINK. THE STATE
SHOULD RECONSIDER- AND THINK
ABOUT MAKING A MUCH MORE
SUBSTANTIAL COMMITMENT TO
INCENTIVES BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THEY'LL BE PAID BACK OVER THE
MEDIA. IN THE LONG TERM BY
TWENTY FIFTY THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT AND EVEN YOU KNOW
EVEN IF WE REACH PARITY IN
TERMS OF COST PREDICTING
TECHNIQUE BUDGET OPTION IT IS A
FOOL'S GAME IT'S REALLY HARD-
WE DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE THE
DOOR WE- A CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES
AND NOT OTHERS BUT- IT'S CLEAR
THAT. WE NEEDED SOMETHING IT'S
LIKE AN IPHONE ON WHEELS THIS
HAS TO BE A CONSUMER GOOD THE
PEOPLE WHAT YOU CAN GET PEOPLE
TO BUY YOU THESE BY GUILT
TRIPPING ABOUT THE CLIMATE. YOU
CAN DO IT BY GET SHOWING THEM
LONG LISTS OF ACCOUNTING
NUMBERS ABOUT PAY BACK THEY
HAVE TO DESIRE THESE THINGS AND
OF COURSE YOU KNOW TEXAS SEEMS
TO BE GAINING MOMENTUM NOW
WHICH IS A GOOD SIGN- THE OTHER
BELIEVE ME WHAT IS REALLY GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE OR THE
OTHER. ESPECIALLY INTERNATIONAL
PRODUCES BOOK INSTITUTE TO WELL
RIGHT IS IT LIKE VEHICLES BY
THE NECK TO YOUR- AND WE'LL SEE
UP TO THIRTY FORTY AS YOU'LL
SEE IN THIS REPORT IN SURVEY OF
MERGING OF VEHICLES CHOICE. W.
PARITY AND THEY'RE JUST GOING
TO BE TREMENDOUS PRIDE VARIETY
SO I HOPE THAT THIS WILL AS A
RESULT OF THE PUZZLE ABOUT WHY.
DUSTING THESE VEHICLES TO SHARE
BRING YOU INDICATED THAT. THE
THAT THOU IN ET BUT IS. YES
SOME OF. MANY OF THEM ARE
PRODUCER CAL. HAS A BONA AFFECT
OUTSIDE THE- TO SAY CAL WE HAVE
PROVIDED. A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO-
HAVE A BUS IS NOT A WHOLE LOT
OF MONEY BUT IT'S BUT SOME WHAT.
WHAT MIGHT WHAT TYPE OF
INVESTMENT DO YOU THINK THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE IN ORDER TO GET
THAT TO SCALE ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL TO. I MEAN I THINK THERE
IS AS WE WERE GOING THROUGH THE
WORK WITH THE CARBS INNOVATIVE
CLEAN TRANS REGULATION WE- THEY
CAME TO UNDERSTAND I THINK THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE INDUSTRY TO
SCALE UP. LIKE THERE IS THIS%
GETTING UP TO A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN PRODUCE ENOUGH OF THE
VEHICLES THAT THE DEMAND IS
GOING TO BE FOR. SO I THINK THE
MORE THAT WE CAN ADVANCED
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURERS- TO SUPPORT
PRODUCTION. OF THAT WOULD BE
ONE APPROACH- I WOULD BE HAPPY-
TO ROGER WAS MORE INFORMATION
ON THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION- IF
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL. MMHM YEAH.
THANK YOU PAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE REACHING THAT
WITCHING HOUR AND WHEN WE WILL
HAVE A COUPLE FOLKS ON MAKES
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT BUT THIS IS
THIS IS FANTASTIC AND THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD INFORMATION FOR US
TO WORK OFF OF THE FOR VITIS
WITH TODAY SIR THANK YOU. OKAY
WERE TO BRIEFLY GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT I KNOW A LOT OF THEM
JUST TO HAVE THEM GET GONE SO
LET'S LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS.
GREETINGS MY NAME IS JEFF HARDY
KIA. VERY INTERESTED IN
TRANSPORTATION- JUST
PARTICIPATED RECENTLY IN SAY
COG LOOKING AT HOW THE
COMMUNITY SERVER. SO REMINDER
IS. ON PUTTING THE BRAKES ON
RISING TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS.
WE SEE THAT IT'S OPEN SOURCE.
TRAFFIC CONGESTION I'M
SUGGESTING TO YOU THAT THAT
SHOULD BE SOMETHING BECOMING IN
THE MANDATES OF YOUR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION BECAUSE THAT IS
A SINGLE THING THAT AFFECTS
MOST PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ES
EVENS LOS ANGELES HAS HAD TO
COMMENT ABOUT THAT REPEATEDLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOW DISMANTLING
THEIR RAPID TRANSIT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T PUT THE SIGNAL
ENHANCEMENTS AND OTHER THINGS
THE DEAL WITH CONGESTION SINGLE
GREATEST THING. SECOND THING I
WILL OFFER TO YOU IS I'M GOING
TO SUGGEST TO YOU IS THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE- ABILITY. OF
NATURAL GAS AS A TAX REVENUE
SOURCE DO NOT EXEMPT TRANSIT OR
AGENCIES FROM IT SO THAT YOU
CAN FIND THIS CHANGE OVER
BECAUSE YOU REPEATEDLY SAY YOU
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING FOR IT.
SO AGAIN FOR PUTTING THE BRAKES
ON IT I WILL SAY TO YOU YOU'VE
NOT DONE ENOUGH OF DEALING WITH
CONGESTION. REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT SO THAT WILL
ASSIST YOUR WRITER YOUR
INDIVIDUAL I'M GIVE ME TO BE
PUSHING ON THE ON THE SHOULDER
BECAUSE THAT IS A
TRANSPORTATION. THE ABILITY BUT
THE OTHER THING IS FIGURING OUT
HOW DO YOU GET PEOPLE OUT OF
CARS I WISH YOU TRAIN GUY WAS
HERE BECAUSE WITH THE FACT THAT
ANOTHER TEN YEARS WE'RE LIKELY
TO SEE CLIMATE. CHANGE TO
ANOTHER TEN DEGREES WHICH MEANS
AVIATION IS GOING TO BE
DRASTICALLY IMPACTED SO WE CAN
TRAIN RIDES ARE GOING TO BE THE
MEANS OF MOVING UP AND DOWN.
CALIFORNIA OKAY THANK YOU. YES
SIR. MISTER CHAIRMAN MR MEMBERS
BRIAN WHITE HERE ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL
GOVERNMENTS ALSO KNOWN AS A COG
WE APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS WE REPRESENT TWENTY
TWO CITIES IN SAID COUNTIES
WITHIN URBAN RURAL AND SUBURBAN
DISTRICTS WE HAVE RESPONDED
LOCALLY TO THE EMERGING AIR
QUALITY CHALLENGES BY ADOPTING
A PILOT PROGRAM. THAT SEEKS TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY 19% AND FIFTEEN YEARS EACH
OF OUR JURISDICTIONS HAVE
IDENTIFY PROJECTS TO INCREASE
INFILL DEVELOPMENT REDUCE
VEHICLE MILE TRIPS TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP ANALECTS FUND LET'S
FIND REMAINING TRIPS THIS IS
KNOWN AS OUR GREEN MEANS GO
PROGRAM WHICH ALSO TARGETS OF.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH OUR
HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND THOSE
ARE EVEN WITH SB THREE SEVEN
FIVE IN STATUTE WHICH REQUIRES
COUNTS OF GOVERNMENTS TO REACH
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION LAND
USE ME HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
MEET THE REGION IN
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
NEEDS HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
THERE WITH THE NEED OF FUNDING
UNFORTUNATELY NOT MUCH OF OUR
NEED OF FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
GRANTS ARE LYING TO THREE SEVEN
FIVE BECAUSE THEY WERE DONE
POST THREE SEVEN FIVE. IN ON US
AND AN UNNECESSARILY TO MEET
THESE AMP IMPLEMENTATION GOALS
WE NEED TO LINE SB THREE SEVEN
FIVE TWO ARMIES GRANT PROGRAMS
WHICH IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO. PRESS THIS WE ARE. YOU KNOW
THE REASON. TO THIS 9% GOA WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT BOTH
HOUSING PRODUCTION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS ARE NOT. MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE. SO IN SHORT WE THINK
THE SACRAMENTO REGION WE'RE
REALLY ON THE EPICENTER BECAUSE
WE HAVE A PLAN THAT IS THE
FIRST ONE OUT THE DOOR. AXE AXE
ACCESS TO MEET THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING EVEN WITH THESE
PROGRAMS ARE OUT THERE. HAVE TO
ALIGN WITH SB THREE SEVEN FIVE
AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE YOUR COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE INSPIRATION
EVERYBODY TO TALK ABOUT HOW.
SACRAMENTO REGION IS REALLY AT
THE CUSTOMER FOR TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT.
FEDERAL CASKEY CRITICAL STAFF
ABOUT. UP COMMITTEES MANY
MISTER FULL BORE I'M WHICH
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT
CENTER BILL HAD JUST LAUGHED
BUT WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT. BECAUSE OF THE FREE FAIR
PASSES BUT WE WERE ABLE TO
RECEIVE AND FUNDED THROUGH TO
CITY SACRAMENTO. A SOURCE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WE DID
GET UP TO SEVENTY PERCENT. AND
IN JANUARY HUNDRED FIVE
PERCENT. INCREASE IN STUDENT
RIDERSHIP. NOW WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT TO YOU THAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE NOT
EXISTING IN A VACUUM WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE PARTNERS
NAMELY. CALISTO CARB CTC
CALTRANS WE EXISTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THESE ENTITIES
AND THEY HAVE. AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A VERY
STRONG- INVOLVEMENT IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE POLICIES. IN
THESE DECISION MAKING BODIES
WHEN YOU. ALLOCATE GRANTS
WEDNESDAY HOLD OUR AGENCIES
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THEY PLEASE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND DELIVERING
THESE CRITICALLY NEEDED.
TRANSIT PROJECTS IN SACRAMENTO
WHEN WE HAVE SUBURBAN SPRAWL
NOW ARE AGENCIES INNER CITIES
ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH US. ON
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEING THAT
SOCCER T. S. MOVING THE NEEDLE
FORWARD. IN NOT ONLY MEETING.
THE BURNERS ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS BUT ALSO
IMPROVING THE CLIP YOU FLOOR.
CREASE THIS IS. GETTING STATE.
TO A NEUTRAL OPEN FOR KAREN
SACK SO. AND BUT COMMITTEE TO
WORK WITH US AND ALSO THANK YOU
YOUR TIME KEEP. THANK YOU NEXT.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE JORDAN
LEADERS COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
IT KIND. FOR A LOOK A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND WE WORK WITH
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY RESIDENTS- WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION TODAY
AND REALLY. BRING TOGETHER KIND
OF THIS INTERSECTION OF CLIMB
IN TRANSPORTATION- IT'S REALLY
CLEAR THAT THERE'S A NEED FOR
MORE COORDINATION IN THIS AREA
OF WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AGENCIES. AND LOCAL AND
REGIONAL JURISDICTIONS- AND AS
MANY OF TALKED ABOUT ALREADY SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IS CLEARLY
RIGHT AN ATTEMPT TO DO THAT
WASN'T A TIME TO DO THAT AND WE
HAVEN'T REACH THOSE GOALS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S ALSO AND
WHAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS
REALLY THAT THERE HASN'T BEEN A
STRONG EQUITY AND ENVIRONMENT
ON CLIMATE JUSTICE COMMITMENT-
OR POLICY APPROACH IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SPACE. AND YOU
KNOW I HEARD THE PROFESSORS
FROM UC DAVIS DISCUSS THIS TO
SOME DEGREE- BUT IT IS WHAT WE
SEE ON THE GROUND IN
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK WITH.
REALLY KIND OF COOL UNMET NEEDS
IN TERMS BASIC MOBILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE CLEAN VEHICLES
AND- NEEDS IN TERMS OF LAND USE
POLICY ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES- IN PARTICULAR THE
DISADVANTAGE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES. HAS ALL THOSE JUST
IT WAS BEYOND JUST SORT OF
PERSON LOCAL OWNERSHIP RATE A
LOT OF BOOKS WE WORK WITH STILL
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE THESE. ELECTRONIC
VIEW- ELECTRIC VIEW THOSE WITH
THE REBATES. SO JUST PLAN TO
POINT OUT THAT REALLY ALL
POLICIES. PRIORITIES PRACTICES
IN. WERE MAKING A TRANSFER HAVE
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT A CLIMATE
JUSTICE APPROACH. THAT IS NOT
ONLY ABOUT REDUCING GHGS AND
THE EMPTY. BUT ALSO ADDRESSING
LOCAL AIR QUALITY ACCESSIBILITY
SAFETY MOBILITY JUSTICE AND
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY. AND ONE
THING THAT INCLUDES IS MOVING
IN PART BE ON PILOT PROGRAM SO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS A SINGLE
TRANSFER TAKEN TATIAN EQUITY
PROGRAM A CAR BUT REALLY. KIND
OF A PROMISING SEEMS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE KIND OF A GREAT
PROGRAM. BUT WE REALLY WANT TO
TALK ABOUT INSTITUTIONALIZING
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING PRACTICES
THAT REALLY DIRECTLY SUPPORT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES-
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND THOSE
HAVE REALLY BEEN DIS INVESTED
IN AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL COST OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM- SO
LASTLY I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT THIS KIND OF CLIMATE
JUSTICE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
APPROACH TO TRANSPORTATION.
ALSO INCLUDES THINGS LIKE HEAVY
DUTY AND GOODS MOVEMENT SO THAT
CAME UP SOMEWHAT TODAY BUT- WE
NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT FULLY
ZERO MISSION- NEAR ZERO IS NOT
ENOUGH FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND AIR
QUALITY. WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT TRAFFIC THEIR HOMES WERE
TALKING THAT IN THE TRUCKS PER
LOCAL LAND USE POLICY THAT'S
GOING TO SUPPORT. CLIMATE AND
EQUITY GOALS SO. HOW MUCH TIME.
Q. X. THANK YOU CENTER WHERE
HOUSE SKI STEP MY FOR US HAS
BEEN VERY FORM HEARING LIKE TO
JUST SORT OF EMPHASIZE THAT-
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HEARD FROM
A LOT OF THE PANELISTS TODAY
IS- AS WELL AS FROM- SOME OF
THE SANDERS- IS THAT THERE'S
CLEARLY A NEED FOR STABLE
PREDICTABLE MULTI YEAR- AND
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED FUNDING
THAT WE'VE PUT A LOT OF FOCUS
ON THE G. G. R. F. AS A SOURCE
FOR MOST GHG REDUCTION
PROGRAMS. EVEN IF UNDER RULES
THAT WE COULD POTENTIALLY
INCREASE THE SIZE OF THAT POOL
OF MONEY I'D STILL POTENTIALLY
IN ORDER TO A MAGNITUDE TOO LOW
TO REALLY ADDRESS THE SCALE OF
THIS ISSUE- INTERVIEW IN
ADDITION TO LOOKING AT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET RESTORING THE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THOSE
PROPOSED TO BE CUT BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REALLY
CONSIDER SCALING UP AND GOING
MUCH LARGER- AS WAS PROPOSED BY
THE ECONOMIST ON THE LAST
PANEL- TO THINK ABOUT THIS IS A
REAL PLUS. A FEW WITH CLEAR
MONETARY HEALTH AND CLIMATE
RETURNS FOR THE- A GOOD
AFTERNOON CENTER CASKEY AND
ESTEEM STAFF I MY NAME IS LINDA
COMMISSION I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION-
WE ARE INTERESTED INVESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE. A HEALTHY
AFFORDABLE AND THAT BICYCLING
IS A PART OF THE EQUATION. IN
TRANSFORMING OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR OUR OUR SYSTEM TO BE
SAFE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
TO GET AROUND TO PEOPLE TO MOVE
I THINK THE BIG. DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
SENDING IT ON REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WHICH
A LOT OF SOLUTIONS AND HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED. IN ADDITION
TO A AND IT'S TENSION TO THE
FUNDING THAT. IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT IS THAT WE HAVE TO
ALSO CENTER OUR DISCUSSION ON
WHAT IS A TAKE TO MOVE MORE
PEOPLE MORE OF THE TIME. AND
NOT JUST TO A YES WE NEED TO
CLEAN UP OUR OUR FLEET MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE CLEAN. OF
VEHICLES BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT MOBILITY IS A
RIGHT FOR PEOPLE AND THAT THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
SAFELY. AND INACCESSIBLE
WICKETS IT'S A WAY THAT YOU ARE
A MAKING SURE YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO JOBS ACCESS TO RESOURCES. TO
OPPORTUNITY. IT'S ALSO FOR AT
IS GLAD. WE'VE A DESIGN AND A
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY OUT OF OUR
LIVES BY BEING IN THE CAR MORE
OF THE TIME. SO WE HAVE TO
REDESIGN HOW WE GET AROUND SO
THAT WE CAN. IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AS WELL SO FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT IS PUT INTO A BIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU GET TO AN IT
TO WAS IN A- SENSE BY. CAN HELP
US IT CENTER WE THE IF WE'RE
LOOKING FROM OF. SO FIRST THE-
I'D AND. FOR BIKING AND WALKING
SO YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE NOT
JUST BUILDING PIECE MEAL. A
BIKE INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE THE
BIKE LANE ENDS OR THE PROTECTED
BY CLINT ENDS AND THEN THE
PERSON DOESN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
AND WHERE TO GO BUT THAT
THERE'S A NETWORK THAT CAN
ACTUALLY GETS PEOPLE TO PLACES-
CONTINUE. TO EXPAND AND INVEST
IN BIKESHARE- ONE OF THE- THE-
PROGRAMS THAT WAS MENTIONED WAS
THE EQUITY SUITE OF PROJECTS
OUT AND THROUGH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION SO THAT. FOR
EXAMPLE CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS
AND ALSO CLEAN OURS FOR ALL- AS
YOU MENTIONED SENATOR AYE
CASKEY. IS ACTUALLY AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO HELP TO
TAKE CARS OFF THE ROAD THAT ARE
POLLUTING AND- AND HELP TO GIVE
BACK REBATES TO FOLKS TO GET
OTHER OPTIONS- ENDING SUBSIDIES
FOR DRIVING. LOOKING AT
CONGESTION PRICING MECHANISMS
AND THEN ALSO AS WAS MENTIONED
HERE TODAY ENDING A ROAD
EXPANSION PROJECTS ARE SEVERELY
REDUCING HOW. WE DO
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING TODAY
INSTEAD OF BUILDING THE FUTURE
BUILDING THE TRANSPORTATION AT
SYSTEM OF THE PAST WE LOOK AT
WHAT WHAT TYPE OF FUTURE THAT
WE NEED AND I'D LEAVE. A QUOTE
FOR YOU TODAY IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WAS MENTIONED BY LEWIS
MUMFORD ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS
AGO. BUILDING MORE ROADS TO
PREVENT CONGESTION IS LIKE A
FACT AND LOOSENING HIS BELT.
FRIENDS BE E. IN OVER STE WE'RE
CREATING MORE SPACE BUT- YOU'RE
NOT ACTUALLY GETTING TO THE
ISSUE SO THANKS FOR THE- THANK
YOU NEXT. I DO NOT A GOOD
QUOTE- TERESA COOK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION A ONE I THINK I THOSE
OF YOU UP THE DíAS I'M FOR THE
GOOD DISCUSSION TODAY AND FOR
STAFF AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
BEING AS I'M TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
AS POSSIBLE ON I ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IN PARTICULAR SO THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
IS A GROUP COMMITTED TO SEEING
HIGHER USAGE- AND BROADER USAGE
OF FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AND HYDROGEN WILL USE TO SUPPLY
IT. I'M ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
TO AS MANY OF YOU KNOW HAD A
LOT TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE
SCHOOLS WERE ALREADY A PART OF
MANY OF THEM WE HAVE A LOT MORE
TO OFFER I THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF GAPS THAT WERE MENTIONED
BY THE SPEAKERS TODAY AND HEARD
BY THOSE OF US IN THE AUDIENCE
OF HOW WE'RE NOT ABLE TO GET
THE PENETRATION LEVELS THAT WAS
THAT WAS THAT WE NEED I THINK
SOMETIMES THERE'S A TEN. TO
SORT OVER THE FUEL CELLS PLAY
AND MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING THESE TO
COMMITTEES TO REALLY MAKES THAT
YOU KNOW WERE WORK WERE
COVERING GAP AND GET DEPEND
LEVELS THAT WE KNEW TO ORDER TO
MEET STATE'S GOAL. ARE TO THE
CA THAT OUR UNSURE BY THE
ACADEMIC AND ALL AND THE VERY
AND I'M SURE OF IT I AM NOT AS
MAKE IT BE USED IN HYDROGEN
FUEL. THERE'S KIND OF A WIN WIN
OFF A OUR IN CAL. HI LIMIT. IN
YET DON'T HAVE ROGER IS THEY
DON'T HAVE A- TO A CHARGING. OR
WORKPLACE CHARGING A AN ISSUE
THAT'S A PLACE IN A SPACE THAT
WERE REAL HOPING TO MAKE FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES. A MORE
FRIENDLY AND MORE VIABLE OPTION
FOR THEM SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID THANK YOU AGAIN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE TWO
COMMITTEES ON THESE ISSUES
FURTHER. THANK YOU NECKS. GOOD
AFTERNOON- KATHY VAN AUSTIN NVM
STRATEGY GROUP REPRESENTING
UNITED AIRLINES AND- WAS
TOUCHED ON JUST A COUPLE OF.
TIMES IN THE HEARING TODAY
ABOUT AVIATION AND COMMERCIAL
AVIATION. AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO A
MOVEMENT THAT- WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE COALITION OF OVER A
HUNDRED ENTITIES. TO TRIED TO
DEVOTE HELPED DEVELOP THE
MARKET FOR SUSTAINABLE AVIATION
FUEL- WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING SOUTH AND TO THE LC OFF
US A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND
THAT IS HOLE- IT HAS TRIGGERED
INVESTMENT INTO EXPANSION FOR
ARE ONLY STATE. ARE ONLY
FACILITY CURRENTLY IN THE
COUNTRY THAT'S PRODUCING SELF
ON A DAILY COMMERCIAL BASE US-
BUT WHAT WE DO NEED IS WE NEED
SOME PARTNERSHIP FROM THE
STATE- THIS IS A DROP IN FUEL
THE DEMAND IS THERE THE
AIRLINES WANTED BOTH. DOMESTIC
AND INTERNATIONAL- BUT WE DO
NEED SOME ASSISTANCE WITH IN
SOME INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING FOR A- OF A- BASICALLY
BUDGET ASK TO TRY TO HELP BUILD
OUT SOME INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT
WE CAN GET. THE FUEL FROM POINT
A TO POINT B. AND INCENTIVIZE
THIS MARKET ALSO DEAL WITH SOME
OF PRICE DISPARITY. RIGHT NOW
IT WE IF THE STATE CAN INVEST
THE- SOME SOME REVENUE INTO
INFRASTRUCTURE WE THINK BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WITH THE 5%
UP TAKE AND SELL OFF. OF THAT
WE CAN REDUCE. EMISSIONS BY TEN
MILLION METRIC TONS ANNUALLY SO
THAT'S JUST WHAT 5% OUR GOAL IS
TO GET 250% SOUTH USE BY TWENTY
FIFTY- SO WE'LL BE TALKING WITH
YOU FURTHER ABOUT THAT BUT WE
DO YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T. YOU
CAN'T REALLY SET EMISSIONS FOR
US I MEAN THAT'S A FEDERAL
PROGRAM UNFORTUNATELY. BUT BUT
WHAT YOU CAN DO IS INVEST IN
WITH WHAT IS THE FUTURE IT'S
THE REALLY THE ONLY WAY THAT
WILL HAVE TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS. AND THANK
YOU NEXT. BUT AFTERNOON SENATOR
BUDGET MCALLEN FROM AT ALL
SINGLE PART ROPES AND SMITH ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT WE ARE
THE CONVENER OF THAT COALITION
THAT AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
UNITED AIRLINES WAS- JUST
SPEAKING ABOUT AND WHEN IT
COMES TO AVIATION EMISSIONS AND
WE'VE ALREADY. MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT WERE SO FAR AWAY
FROM AIRPLANE ABOUT TO VACATION
IN ALL THE AIRPORTS ARE DOING
WHAT THEY CAN ON THE GROUND TO
REDUCE OUR EMISSIONS SO. CW
PATIENT WHO WAS THE ONLY REAL
VIABLE OPTION WE HAVE TO
DRASTICALLY REDUCE OUR AVIATION
EMISSIONS AS WELL AS- INCREASE
AIR QUALITY FOR NEARBY
COMMUNITIES AND- ALL THEIR
FIELD WORKER SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR PARTNERSHIP FOR THE STATE
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THE ISSUE. NEXT
THANK YOU SENATOR CODEY BOILS
IN BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED BIO WHOSE ALLIANCE. I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PERMITS EVERY PANEL AGREED ON
IS THE NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM
A- PETROLEUM BASED THAT
TRANSPORTATION- FUEL. AND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A NINE
PRODUCERS- BY- DIESEL AND
RENEWABLE DIESEL. AND BY USING
EIGHTY TWENTY BLAND WE CAN
REDUCE. 71% OF THE GHG
EMISSIONS. AS WELL AS 60% OF
THE DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER.
AND THIS IS READY TO GO TODAY
SO YOU CAN BY REPLACING THE
FUEL YOU OFFER REPLACE- SINGLE
ENGINE SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. HI A GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR LIKE OWSKI- MY
NAME IS RYAN KENNYWOOD CLEAN
ENERGY LIKE TO MAKE JUST TWO
QUICK POINTS- ONE BASED ON COST
EFFECTIVENESS FOR A HEAVY DUTY
LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES TRUCKS- THE
LA A REPORT. MENTION THAT-
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES INCENTIVES
ARE. AMONG THE LEAST COST
EFFECTIVE. FOR INCENTIVES BUT
IF YOU REMOVE FIVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE TRUCKS AND BUSES AB
THAT CATEGORY IN JUST INCLUDE
LOW KNOX IS ONE OF THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AND VESTMENTS
THE STATE CAN MAKE AS FAR AS-
PERTAINS OF- GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND KNOCKS. IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR HIM IMMEDIATE AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND-
CLIMATE BENEFITS THE KNOX
TRUCKS WITH RENEWABLE FUEL WHAT
WOULD BE THE DO THAT. I ALSO
LIKE TO MENTION TO- REGARDING
FUNDING- WE ALL WANT MORE
FUNDING IN LOVE TO SIT STILL
AND STATE YOUR PURSUE A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE. IN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE LIMITATIONS ARE
ARE CLEAR AND IF YOU LOOK AT G.
JURA FUNDING ALONE- I THINK
THERE'S IT'S NOT JUST COST
EFFECTIVENESS WITH AIR BE
DECISIONS BUT I THINK THEY'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT A PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE. AND THIS YEAR IN-
THE CLEAN TRUCK AND BUS PROGRAM
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS BUDGETED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THERE WAS A- AN ATTEMPT
LAST YEAR BY AIR BE STAFF TO
GRADUATE LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES
OUT OF THAT PROGRAM AT AGE
FIFTY WHICH IS UNDER CONDUCT.
IN TRUCKS AND BUSES AND- MAKE
IT MORE OF AN EASY FUNDING
SOURCE. FORTUNE THE BOARD I AM
IT'S WISDOM DOT DECLINED TO
PURSUE THAT BUT THAT IS STILL-
HANGING OVER THE FUNDING THAT
FUNDING PLAN DISCUSSIONS FOR
THIS YEAR. SO WE DO ASK THAT-
THE LEGISLATURE- EXERT AT THE
ALREADY AND- EXPRESSLY- INCLUDE
LOW KNOCKS- TRUCKS. TRUCK
FUNDING IN AT THE AGE THAT
PROGRAM- FOR THE NEXT FUNDING
YEAR BECAUSE IT'S UNCERTAIN IF
I AB STAFF WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN DOING THAT TO THEMSELVES SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAX. GOOD
AFTERNOON JULIE AROUND OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR A NONPROFIT FOCUSED
ON PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND IMPROVING AIR QUALITY-
WE'VE SEEN THE NEED TO REDUCE
OUR TRANSPORTATION. EMISSIONS
AND TO GET THEIR CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO PROPERLY TRANSITION
ENGINES TO ZERO MISSION AND
NEAR ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
THROUGH. REGULATION SUCH AS THE
ADVANCE CLEAN TRUCK ROLL AND
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE STANDARDS
AS WELL AS INCENTIVES. WE NEED
TO MOVE QUICKLY FROM OUR
RELIANCE ON PETROLEUM DIESEL
AND GASOLINE TO CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES THROUGH.
REGULATIONS LIKE A LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD WE NEED TO REFORM
OUR LAND USE POLICY. OF OUR
LAND USE PLANNING TO CURB
LOGISTICS FOR ALL IN THE FREE
INDUSTRY TO HELP OUR ESIDENTS
REDUCE COMMUTE TIMES. WE NEED
TO REDUCE OUR VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED BY PROVIDING CLEAN
MOBILITY FOR ALL SUCH AS
TRANSIT AND BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FINALLY- WE
NEED TO SHIFT OUR PARADIGM THAT
ARE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
FROM BUILDING CAPACITY WHICH
ONLY INDUCES MORE DRIVING TO
MULTI MODAL PLANNING THAT
REDUCES EMISSIONS ON THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REFLECT
THESE PRIORITIES. AND ITS
BUDGETING SPEND LESS ON THE
ROADS AND MORE UNCLEAN TRUCKS
BUSES AND CARS PUBLIC TRANSIT
AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION THANK
YOU. X. I AM A LIPO PARDON ON
THE POLICY ADVOCATE CLIMATE
PLANET CLIMATE PLAN IS A
NETWORK A FIFTY PLUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT LOOK AT THE
INTERSECTION OF LAND USE
TRANSPORTATION CLIMB IT AND-
QUESTION OF THIS OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD. A AND HOUSING SORRY-
AND WE DO THIS BY CONVENING THE
GROUPS AND TALKING ABOUT A
MULTITUDE OF ISSUES WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HAD TODAY BUT OUR LITTLE
DISHEARTENED BY THE LACK OF
ADVOCACY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND EQUITY THAT WERE ON THAT
WAS ON THE PANELS.
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS WILL
REDUCE NOT JUST THROUGH POLICY
BUT THEY HAVE TO INCLUDE
COMMUNITIES AND WE HOPE THAT
THE COMMITTEE MOVES FORWARD
THERE GREATER PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
WORKING AND KEEP COMMUNITIES
HEALTHIER SAFER AND CLEAN-
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE ALSO NOT
GOING TO BE THE SAVING GRACE TO
REDUCING EMISSIONS. WE HAVE TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES IN A
MULTITUDE OF VENUES MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE ALREADY LEFT BEHIND
BY TRANSPORTATION INNOVATIONS
AND AS WE PUSH FOR
ELECTRIFICATION WHICH IS GOING
TO BE LEAVING THOSE COMMUNITIES
BEHIND EVEN MORE. THANK YOU. X.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRANDING RCM
HAVE A CAL STAR A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS MADE ONE ECHO THE ONES
MADE BY SECRETARY CAME IN
CENTER BELL ABOUT LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES FOR
TRANSPORTATION- YOU KNOW WON'T
REPEAT THE COMMENTS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RUNNING
TRANSPORTATION BUT WE THINK
THAT W. DOWN IS VERY NECESSARY
NOT ONLY JUST TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS REDUCE EMISSIONS
BUT YOU KNOW FOR THE SAKE OF IN
THE INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
SENDING MARKETS CANDLES IS
CRITICAL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE INVESTORS THOSE MANY
FACTORS FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
STATE THAT IS COMMITTED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES- COMMENT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE REGARDING- THE-
AIR BE CLEANED THE BUS PROGRAM-
THEIR INCOME IS MADE ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S COST EFFECTIVENESS
BUT- THE SOURCE. OF A MISSED
TRANSPORTATION AND EVERY GIVE
STERN NUMBER BEHALF FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS COME
FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES THE TOWARD ON BY THE
BIG TRUCKS TO BE BUSES GETTING
THOSE AS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE IS
THE BEST WAY TO REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS NOT ONLY JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BEFORE AN EQUITY
COMPONENT- DO MUCH SAID ON THE
FINANCE PART THAT THE CREATURE
THE BUS FROM GRAHAM LARGELY
OPERATED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS A LOT OF PLACES
WHERE WAREHOUSES ARE IT'S A LOT
OF PLACES WHERE TRUCKS HAVE TO
TRAVEL THROUGH THOSE CORRIDORS
SO BEING THAT W. DOWN ON THIS
SPECIFIC PROGRAM DOES HELP BOTH
HONOR GHG EMISSIONS BUT ALSO
HAS A LOT EQUITY COMPONENT.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE THINK
IT'S PART. OF THANKS. THANK YOU.
I JOSH A STAR WITH TRANSFORM
ORGAN. THAT TO. AND SUSTAINABLE
LAND USE ENTRANCE. POLICY IN
ADDITION TO ALIGNING MY
COMMENTS AT THOSE OF CLIMATE
PLANNING COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR LEADERSHIP COUNCIL- I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS LITTLE BIT ON THE
TRANSIT PORTION- DOCTOR HANDY
REMARKS ON THE NEED FOR LAND
USE CHANGE. I'D AND NEEDS TO BE
NOTED ARE WILDLY POPULAR AND
BORN OUT IN HOUSING MARKETS.
INVESTMENT SHE MENTIONED ARE
OFTEN SO VALUED BY CALIFORNIANS
THAT THEY DRIVE HOUSING PRICES
FAR ABOVE THE ABILITY FOR. THE
HIGHEST PROPENSITY TRANSIT
RIDERS SO THIS THIS IDEA THIS.
ILLUSION THAT WE'RE JUST THIS
WE ARE THIS CAR CENTER CULTURE
WHO LOVES A CAR'S LOVES OUR
CARS SO MUCH. ISN'T BORNE OUT
AS MUCH IN THE MARKETS FOR YOU
SEE SUBURBANIZATION OF POVERTY
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE FALLING
LAND VALUES. BECAUSE THE DEMAND
ISN'T THERE WERE AS WERE YOU
GET HIGH QUALITY TRANS OR IN
DEVELOPMENT THE LAND USES I'M-
AT THE PRICES FOR LAND.
SKYROCKET AND BECOME ACTUALLY A
PROBLEM FOR KIND OF A RIDERSHIP
FOR GREATER RIDERSHIP ISSUES SO
WITHOUT THINGS LIKE
AFFORDABILITY EMBEDDED IN TEO
DE. UM SO THAT'S ACTUALLY A YOU
KNOW AT. A LESS BAD PROBLEM TO
HAVE RIGHT IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
CLAMORING TO LIVE WHERE THEY
CAN HAVE GOOD ACCESS TO BUSES
AND TRAINS- MS BREEN'S COMMENTS
ABOUT THE NEEDS IN WAYS TO
IMPROVE TRANSITS
COMPETITIVENESS AND PUBLIC
THOROUGHFARES THROUGH BUS ONLY
LANES AND OTHER WAYS. ARE KNOWN
ONLY ENCOURAGING. THEY
REPRESENT THE KINDS OF
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS THAT
REQUIRE NO NEW TECHNOLOGIES NOR
ANY MAJOR SHIFT IN OUR
THINKING. AND THESE GO TO WHAT
SENATOR BELL HAD SAID WHEN HE
TALKED ABOUT TIMES AND
CONGESTION. THE TIMELINESS OF
TRANSIT IN COMPETITION WITH
OTHER MODES IS A VITAL
COMPONENT. AND GOES DIRECTLY TO
THE CONGESTION PROBLEM. TOO
OFTEN PUBLIC TRANSIT IS STUCK
IN THE SAME TRAFFIC. AND IT IS
AN ESTABLISHED FACT THAT THE
MORE ROADS WE BUILD THE LONGER
WE MAKE CONGESTION FOR ALL
USERS. AND THE MORE WE
INCENTIVIZE AND ST
UNSUSTAINABLE GREEN FIELD
DEVELOPMENT. AND WHEN I SAY AND
SUSTAINABLE I MEAN IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE BUT ALSO AN EXPENSE TO
FAMILIES FORCED INTO DRIVING
RIDICULOUSLY LONG COMMUTES. PAY
FOR PARKING INSURANCE AND
EXPENSE TO CITIES FORCED TO USE
VALUABLE LANDS FOR PARKING
SPACES. INSTEAD OF HOUSING.
WHAT WE NEED A SICK. REFER OF
CALIFORNIA'S. INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS WENEED TO ASK HOW
TO DRAMATICALLY GROW TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP. UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE EXPENSE WILL BE LARGE BUT
THE RESULT IN TREMENDOUS JOB
CREATION BUT WILL RESULT IN
TREMENDOUS JOB CREATION. AS
WELL AS INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
ALREADY GREATLY VALUED BY
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S KNOWN ISSUE
ABOUT. HOW TO BEST GROW TRANSIT
THROUGH WRITER DEMAND IN
TRANSIT SUPPLY IN A NOTED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOWING GREAT
LEADERSHIP IN ITS SUPPORT FOR A
VARIETY OF WAYS TO GROW
RIDERSHIP. AND SHOW THE KIND OF
DEMAND NEEDED THROUGH TO PUSH
TRANSIT IN PARTICULAR CURRENTLY
THROUGH BILLS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR FAIR FREE ACCESS
FOR PARTICULAR GROUPS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. HELLO MY NAME
IS SHEER LANE I RUN THE ATRIUM
WHICH IS A CREATIVE INNOVATION
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABILITY- I
WANT TO SAY THAT A LOT OF
MENTION WAS HERE ON
TRANSPORTATION BUT NOT A LOT
WAS MENTIONED ON MANUFACTURING
AND I THINK WE NEED TO CONSIDER
THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY. AS PART
OF THESE EQUATIONS TO REDUCE
THE GRENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS-
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON A LINEAR
ECONOMY WHERE EXTRACTING USING
DISPOSING WHICH MEANS IS
GREENHOUSE GASES OF TRENT
CREATING IT GREENHOUSE GASES OF
TRANSPORTING IT IN GREENHOUSE
GASES OF THROWING IT AWAY WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE USE
OUR RESOURCES HOW WE CAN TAKE
THIS VALUABLE STUFF AND RE USE
IT AND KEEP IT AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE IN A SMALLER CIRCLE-
IF WE CAN START OPENING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT I THINK
THAT WOULD BE REALLY REALLY
VALUABLE. TO OTHER THINGS APART
FROM THE SEXY TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU. Q.
ALAS SAYS SPEAKER IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. YES HI- MY NAME'S DEAL
PAGE I'M JUST A LOCAL PERSON
INTERESTED IN TRANSIT. AND
LISTEN TO A CONVERSATION TODAY
I'M WONDERING WHY YOU'RE
DANCING AROUND THE ISSUE OF
FUNDING. THERE'S A REALLY
SIMPLE WAY TO FUND THIS STUFF
IS TO PUT A PRICE ON CARBON
EMISSIONS. PUT A PRICE ON
CARBON EMISSIONS. CREATE A
BORDER ADJUSTMENT FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE EXPORTING GOODS
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE. AND THEN
REBATE THE REVENUES TO THE
POPULATION SODA SWISHES THE
IMPACT. I A I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE IS ALL
THIS TALK ABOUT MAKING IT SHINY
AND IN DO SEEING PEOPLE TO TRY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING WHEN WE
JUST PUT A PRICE ON THE COST.
OF THEIR- EMITTING DELETERIOUS
GASES INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M SURE THERE'S SOME PEOPLE
WATCHING WE THINK THAT THE LAST
SPEAKER WAS THE PLANT BY CENTER
Y. CASKEY ON HIS- HIS CONTINUED
EFFORT TO RAISE THE PRICE OF
CARBON IT'S A SOMEWHAT POETIC
THAT WE HEARD FROM TE AIRPORT
AND THE- SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION ON REDOUBLING
OUR- EMISSION REDUCTION EFFORTS
AS WELL AS OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST ON THE- CALIFORNIA'S
POLICIES IN ACADEMIA AS
SPEAKING TO US ON THE CLEANER
FLEETS IN THE- RIGHT FOR OUR
ORDERS DESIRABILITY OF HAVING
FEWER VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
AS WE SEGUE FROM THE- CHAIRMAN
OF THE POLICY COMMITTEES
THROUGH THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES AND WE HAD
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE NEED
FOR FUNDING IT WAS I WAS STRUCK
BY THE POIGNANCY OF THE OF THE
HEARING AND WITH THAT WE ARE
TURN.